THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES TODAY WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ANTI POVERTY AND
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. I HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO READ SOME INSTRUCTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE STATE CAPITOL IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA-
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
1-877-692-8957 WITH THE ACCESS
CODE OF ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. THOSE
WHO ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON MAY DO SO BY MUST WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES AND FOLLOW ALL
OTHER POSTED GUIDANCE. WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER ALL
MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL. THERE
WILL BE NO VOTES IN TODAY'S
HEARING AS THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO DISCUSS
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB ONE AT S. M. DOT CA
DOT GOV. BEFORE WE INVITE OUR
FIRST PANEL TO BEGIN I WILL MAKE
JUST A FEW INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS
. OUR FOCUS AND SOMEONE THIS
YEAR HAS BEEN TWO FOLD WE ARE
FIRST REVIEWING PRIORITY ISSUES
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
SECOND WE ARE EXERCISING OUR
CRITICAL OVERSIGHT ROLE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
PHASE. AS PART OF BOTH OF THESE
EXERCISES WE DISCUSS AND
DELIBERATE ON WHAT ADDITIONAL
MEANINGFUL CHANGES THIS TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUDGET CAN FACILITATE
TO MAKE PROGRESS TOWARD SOLVING
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS FACING OUR
STATE. POVERTY AND ITS SIBLINGS
OF HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS ARE
PERVASIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
DISTINCTION OF HAVING THE
HIGHEST RATE IN THE NATION MEANS
THAT THERE REALLY ARE TO
CALIFORNIA'S. ONE WHERE THE
DREAM OF SELF SUFFICIENCY EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND PERSONAL SAFETY
AND SUCCESS AS POSSIBLE AND ONE
WHERE IT IS NOT. TODAY WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR FROM A PANEL ON
ENDING POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
INFORMING US ABOUT THE VISION OF
ACCOMPLISHING THIS ON A
POPULATION SCALE IN OUR STATE.
AND THEN WE'LL DISCUSS THE CORE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EACH OF THEIR
ROLES WITH THE GOAL OF ENDING
POVERTY CENTRAL TO THIS
DISCUSSION. WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY AND LEARNING AND TALKING
ABOUT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ABOUT THE BRAIN IMPACTS OF
POVERTY TRAUMA AND ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES. AND THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
WE HAVE THE INFORMATION AND
TOOLS TO TAKE ACTION TO END
POVERTY I HOPE THAT TODAY'S
DISCUSSION WILL PROVIDE A
FOUNDATION FOR BIG STEPS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BUDGET TO END
POVERTY TO CLOSE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC GAPS AND TO MAKE PERSON
CENTERED OUTCOMES THAT ALLEVIATE
SUFFERING. A CORE PART OF OUR
EFFORTS WORKING FORWARD. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE AGENDAS
FOR TODAY WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN. OUR FIRST PANEL ON ENDING
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. WE WILL
GO THROUGH THE YOUR ORDER THAT
IS AS IT APPEARS WITHIN THE
AGENDA AND WE HAVE FIVE
DISTINGUISHED PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL TODAY WE WILL BEGIN WITH
DR DAVID GRETZKY PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
. FOLLOWED BY MICHAEL TUBBS
SENIOR ADVISER FOR ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND OPPORTUNITY TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. AND FOUNDER OF
THE END OF POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
EPIC. THIRD DOCTOR W'KABI SEAN
PEDIATRICIAN AND ACTING SURGEON
GENERAL. FOURTH DIRECTOR TIM
JOHNSON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND FINALLY SONYA PADDOCK WITH
THE L. A. L. WE WILL HOLD ALL
MEMBERS QUESTIONS ON THE PANEL
UNTIL AFTER THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED LET US BEGIN WITH DR
DAVID CRUSTY WELCOME AND PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. I'M
HONORED TO HAVE BEEN INVITED BY
THE CHAIR TO MAKE A PRESENTATION
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY I'LL
GET RIGHT TO IT. THE OBJECTIVE
OF THE REPORT THAT I RECENTLY CO
AUTHORED IS TO LAY OUT A LONG
RUN PLANNED FOR BUILDING A JUST
INCLUSIVE AND POVERTY PRETTY
CULTIVATE. BECAUSE THE TASK
COMPLETELY ELIMINATING POVERTY
CAN SEEM DAUNTING WE WANTED TO
DESCRIBE IN STEP BY STEP
BLUEPRINT FOR. EXACTLY HOW WE
CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN. THE
BLUEPRINT COMES IN TWO PARTS.
FIRST PARK RECOGNIZES THAT IF
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT ELIMINATING
POVERTY WE CAN'T BANK
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE SAFETY NET TO
GET THAT JOB DONE. INSTEAD NEED
TO BEGIN BY FIXING THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE GENERATING
SO MUCH POVERTY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. INSTITUTIONAL WORK IS PRE
DISTRIBUTED BECAUSE IT PREVENTS
POVERTY FROM HAPPENING. AND THUS
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF AFTER THE
FACT REMEDIATION THAT THE SAFETY
NET HAS TO TAKE ON. THE
BLUEPRINT DESCRIBES FOR STARTING
POINT REFORMS WITHIN KEY
INEQUALITY GENERATING
INSTITUTIONS. NUMBER ONE WE SHOW
THAT OUR LABOR MARKETS NEED TO
BE REBUILT BY BREAKING DOWN
LABOR SUPPLY BARRIERS EQUALIZING
ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND TRAINING
AND EMPOWERING AND PROTECTING
WORKERS. NUMBER TWO WE SHOW THAT
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
REBUILT BY DECRIMINALIZING
QUALITY OF LIFE OF FENCES ENDING
PRACTICES THAT TARGET PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND PROVIDING MEANINGFUL
SECOND CHANCES. NUMBER THREE WE
SHOULD OUR WEALTH GENERATING
INSTITUTIONS NEED TO BE REBUILT
BY INCREASING ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPENING UP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND REGULATING
PREDATORY FINANCIAL SERVICES.
AND FINALLY NUMBER FOUR WE
SHOWED THAT THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS TO BE
INCREASED BUT BEFORE MEANS
OPENING AND INCENTIVIZING IN
FUNDING DEVELOPMENT STREAMLINING
BUILDING APPROVALS AND ENFORCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TARGETS. THIS
FIRST ROUND TO PRE
DISTRIBUTIONAL WORK WHICH IS
DESCRIBED OF COURSE IN MUCH MORE
DETAIL IN THE REPORT ITSELF.
BEST TARGETS THE UPSTREAM
SOURCES OF POVERTY AND INEQUITY
. THE SECOND PART OF THE
BLUEPRINT PROCEEDS FROM THE
RECOGNITION THAT THESE PRE
DISTRIBUTION REFORMS AS
IMPORTANT AS THEY ARE WILL
ALWAYS BE INCOMPLETE. EVEN IF
THEY WERE FULLY IMPLEMENTED AND
HAD PRECISELY THE INTENDED
EFFECTS THEY WOULDN'T ROAD OUT
OLD IN EQUITIES BUILT INTO OUR
INSTITUTIONS. IF THE JOB OF OUR
SAFETY NET THE SACRED TO ALL OF
OUR SAFETY NET TO PICK UP THE
PIECES. AND HANDLE THESE
RESIDUAL DESIGN FAILURES THAT'S
A BIG JOB AND THERE WILL
INEVITABLY THE SHORTFALLS WHEN
SO MUCH IS ASKED TO THE SAFETY
NET. DO THEN NOW TURNS RESEARCH
OF KEY SAFE NET REFORMS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE SHORTFALL.
FOR WHICH I'LL MENTION. NUMBER
ONE. WE NEED TO BETTER SUPPORT
OVERLOOKED POPULATIONS BUT
CURRENTLY AREN'T ELIGIBLE. FOR
ALL THE SAFETY NET BENEFITS THEY
NEED. NUMBER TWO WE NEED TO
REDUCE HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS BY BOLSTERING
SUPPORT FOR HOUSING IN SECURE
HOUSEHOLDS. NUMBER THREE WE NEED
TO SET UP DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEMS THAT MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
COORDINATE THE DELIVERY OF
EXISTING SAFETY NET BENEFITS.
AND NUMBER FOUR WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO SECURING
SUPPORT AND END STATE
INTERCEPTION OF DEATH THE
PREVENTATIVE FROM GETTING THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED. WE WILL
OUTLINE TO NEW PROGRAMS
GUARANTEED INCOME AND BABY BONDS
THAT ADDRESS PROBLEMS THAT COULD
NOT BE FULLY HANDLED VIA THESE
FORMS A LOAN. THESE TWO PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHING INCOME AND WEALTH
FLOORS WOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR EVERYONE EVERYONE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR ECONOMY-
THERE'S MUCH RESEARCH SHOWING
THAT CASH TRANSFERS WORK. WE
NEED TO FURTHER EXPERIMENTALLY
THIS PARTICULAR TYPES OF
TRANSFER PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY COORDINATE WELL WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS. THE IMMEDIATE
PROPOSAL THEREFORE IS NOT JUST
REFORM EXISTING SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
ONGOING EXPERIMENTATION WITH TWO
NEW PROGRAMS. SO WHY IT MIGHT BE
ASKED WE NEED TO EXPERIMENT WITH
GUARANTEED INCOME AND THE ANSWER
IS SIMPLE GIVEN FEDERALLY
MANDATED ELIGIBILITY RULES
WITHIN EXISTING SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. WILL LIKELY BE
IMPOSSIBLE IMPOSSIBLE LIMON A
PARTY WITHOUT A GUARANTEED
INCOME SUPPLEMENT. THE CLOSES
GAPS IN COVERAGE. THE SECOND
PROBE. A BABY BONDS PROGRAM THE
PARALLEL MINIMUM WEALTH FOR IT
TAKES ON THE MASSIVE
INEQUALITIES OF OPPORTUNITY
GENERATED BY THE STATE'S WELCOME
. THE KEY POINT HERE BECAUSE
WELL BODIES OPPORTUNITY SOME OF
OUR CHILDREN GREW UP IN A WORLD
RICH WITH OPPORTUNITY WHILE
OTHERS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CAPITAL NEEDED TO REALIZE THEIR
DREAMS. IT BABY BONDS WERE
ESTABLISHED OVERSTREET'S
CHILDREN WOULD HAVE GUARANTEED
ACCESS TO THE CAPITAL NEEDED TO
PURSUE THEIR DREAMS OF GOING TO
COLLEGE STARTING A BUSINESS OR
CONTRIBUTING IN OTHER WAYS. THE
CORE IDEAS THIS IS A DYNAMIC
SYSTEM IN WHICH PRE DISTRIBUTION
AND REDISTRIBUTION WORK HAND IN
HAND. IT PRE DISTRIBUTION
REFORMS BLUEBIRD IN EXCESS OF
OUR EXPECTATIONS. WE CAN SIMPLY
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
REDISTRIBUTION IF THEY FAIL TO
DELIVER WE CAN BE THE AUTOMATIC
STABILIZER OF REDISTRIBUTION
BILLION WHAT. THE UPSHOT WE CAN
INDEED COMPLETELY ELIMINATE RP
THROUGH DYNAMIC ADJUSTMENT
BETWEEN PERCENT UPSTREAM AND
DOWNSTREAM REMEDIATION. I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU DR NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM MICHAEL TUBBS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
GREAT TO HEAR FROM YOU DR
GRANT'S GAME MY NAME IS MICHAEL
TO HELP THEM FORMER MAYOR CITY
OF STOCKTON. I'M CURRENTLY
SPECIAL ADVISER TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ON ECONOMIC MOBILITY
OPPORTUNITY FROM ACCOUNTS OF THE
PERFORMER TEACHER BUT I THINK
MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THIS
DISCUSSION- A YOUNG PERSON LIKE
UNFORTUNATELY MILLIONS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE- IS THAT CALIFORNIA WHO
GREW UP IN POVERTY. AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TESTIFIED IT
SPEAKING- AS A FORMER ELECTED US
ON WITH ACCESS TO AGENCY AND
WITH SOME POLICY KNOWLEDGE BUT
I'M ALSO DEEPLY SAD THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE I
GREW UP WITH I'M AT THE SCHOOL
WHERE I PLAYED BASKETBALL WITH
BY. SIX SWIMMING CLASSES WITH
WHO WHO AREN'T HERE WHO WHO WHO
DIDN'T WEREN'T ABLE TO GO TO
COLLEGE TOO MANY HOME DIDN'T
MAKE IT TO TWENTY FIVE WITH THE
UNDERLYING A PRETTY BUSY
CONDITION BEING THAT POVERTY IN
POVERTY AS YOU POINT OUT MR
CHAIRMAN THAT'S BEEN PERVASIVE
IN IN OUR STATE. AS WE TALK
ABOUT THIS BUDGET ARM IT WITH
THE BUDGET SURPLUS WE TALK ABOUT
IT IN THE CONTEXT THAT THE
SURPLUS IS BECAUSE SOME FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DONE INCREDIBLY
WELL DURING A TIME A MASS
EFFORT. DURING A TIME OF THE
MILLIONS OF WOMEN LEAVING THE
WORK FORCE COULD BECOME A CHILD
CARE ISSUES- HAVE DONE WELL TIME
WHEN MANY PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS AND IN THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND THAT THOSE WHO
HAD A LOT OF MONEY AT EVEN MORE
LIKELY AND THOSE TO START OFF
BEHIND ARE EVEN FURTHER BEHIND
AS WE PERSIST YOU THIS PANDEMIC
AND THAT'S WHY THE. TOPIC OF
THIS- COMMITTEE. THAT'S WHY.
SERVE THE WORK WE'RE ALL
CONNECT. CAN ARSON TO THE ENTIRE
. HOW IT IS IT'S SO WITH. IT IS
NOT. THERE ARE SAY IS NOW. FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO BE THE
GO TO. ALL RIGHT THIS CAR MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WAS IN IN. BUT THE
FOR WITH MY NAME. I'M WITH HER
GROW SON I. WAS GOING TO LAW OFF
THE LOG ON TO THIS SHE SAID MAN
I AM EXCITED ABOUT THAT POVERTY
STAFF YOU'RE DOING. ANOTHER
WOULD YOU ME ISSUE BEGAN TO TELL
ME HOW SHE LOST HER HUSBAND LAST
YEAR. ON THE DIFFICULT. HAVE SHE
HAS THREE KIDS SIX FIVE SEVEN.
AND HOW IT'S BEEN HARD FOR HER
TO BE CARE TAKER TO BE BREAD
WINNERS TO BE CHILD CARE TO BE
TEACHER TO DO ALL THAT TO BE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND THAT THE
ISSUE WASN'T AS SHE'S. THE ISSUE
WASN'T ACTUALLY HAVE WILL POWER
THE AC IT WASN'T BAD IT WAS THE
BEST YOUTH BY THE SMART OR
INTELLIGENT THE ISSUE WAS AT THE
TOP OF WORK SHE DOES. THE TYPE
OF WORK SHE THAT THAT THEY HAVE
A CHILD CARE WORKER HERSELF PAYS
POVERTY WAGES IN IN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ALL KNOW THE
STATS WE ARE THOUGH THAT
CALIFORNIA THE GOLDEN STATE HAS
THE FIFTH LARGEST GDP IN THE
WORLD. WE ALL KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA THE GOLDEN STATE HAS
MORE BILLIONAIRES THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THIS WORLD BESIDES
THE UNITED STATES AND CHINA. WE
KNOW THE FACTS WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
RICHEST PEOPLE. IT'S ALSO THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN AND IN POVERTY WE SEE THE
ISSUES WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS WE SEE THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE TO DO. IT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
CAST A BOLD VISION FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE STATE INCLUDING
TWENTY TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE IN
INVESTMENTS IN HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. TO ENSURE HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN
REGARDING IMMIGRATION STATUS WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S ALSO A GREAT
PARTY GIVES INVESTORS INCLUDE
INCLUDING EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT.
TO OUR PAYING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND
FUNDING THE RETURN HOME WELL PRO. PRO PROGRAM AND WE ARE ALL
VERY BY SPEAKER THIS IS A MATH
WEEK. TO CREATE BACK ON PO THERE
. AND. ACTING THIS YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE ENTIRE SET KNOWS
THAT WE TO LOOK AT HOW WE BILL
BACK BETTER THE STATE THROUGH
THE WITH. IN THE OP. BEFORE IT.
IS EMAIL. BECAUSE IF WE SAW
POWER IN. WE CREATE A- FOR THE
RED OF THE COULD THE- WE KNOW
THAT HOW. OFTEN THE COUNTRY'S
GROUND FOR A BIG POWER THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE CO LOOKS TO ENACT
IN THIS MOMENT WORK HALTED A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER IN DO MORE IF
IT WAS REALLY GRAPPLE WITH THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
POVERTY. WE SHOULD TOLERATE
PARTY WE SHOULD OF WORK AROUND
PARTY WE HAVE THE END IT IS NOT
CONCLUDE BY SAYING THAT BIG PART
OF ENDING POVERTY ISN'T JUST AN
POLICY IT'S AN UNDERSTANDING A
COUPLE FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH. TRUTH
NUMBER ONE THE ISSUE IS THAT
WITH PEOPLE LIVING IN POVERTY
THAT THE PEOPLE ARE NOT THE
PROBLEM THAT THE PROSTHESES THAT
THE POLICIES THAT THE STRUCTURES
THAT THE WAGES THE LACK OF THE
LACK OF BARGAINING IN BAD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT TERRIBLE
SCHOOLS THAT THE UNSAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS- BUILDS. THOSE ARE THE
ISSUE. NOT THE PEOPLE IN NUMBER
TO OUR PROGRAMS HAVE TO BE
DESIGNED WITH GETTING AS MUCH
PEOPLE IN THAT'S POSSIBLE AND
NOT FROM EXCLUSIONARY LEADS WE
SHOULD WHAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO QUALIFIES FOR BENEFITS. IN
CALIFORNIA TO EASILY ACCESS
THOSE BENEFITS IN FACT THERE IS
THIS A REPORT FROM USC THAT'S
SPOKE TO THE FACT THAT THE FOLKS
ACTUALLY. WERE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO HAVE A WEDDING
COUPLE SUB AND BURDENSOME AND
DIGNITY STRIPPING IN THE
HUMANIZING. THEY WILL HAVE A
HUGE. DENT IN POVERTY. THEY GET
PROFESSOR GRABS THE- REALLY LAID
OUT FROM FROM A WHAT SHE BE
DONE. AND I THINK I'M TO THE
CHALLENGE AS TO MY WITH THE-
WILL PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THAT
ONE PERSON. WHO WORKS ON HARVEY
ISSUES FULL TIME. WHO'S ACTUALLY
IN POVERTY. I HAVE A WIDE. WHO
WHO ADVOCATES ORGANIZES AROUND
HARVEY ISSUES. THAT ARE IN
POVERTY IT I THINK WHAT'S GOOD
FOR US IS GOOD ENOUGH FOR
EVERYONE IN THE STATE SO WE GET
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME IN CALIFORNIA IT'S TIME
TO BE TRUE TO WHAT WE SEE ON
PAPER IT'S TIME TO LIVE UP TO
OUR VALUES IS TRYING TO TRULY BE
A GOLDEN STATE. GOLDEN STATE FOR
ALL OF GOLDEN STATE FOR EVERYONE
THE STATE WORK FOR EDWARD
EVERYONE HAS OPPORTUNITY WHEN
THE POLICIES ARE CHEST WHEN THE
SYSTEMS. ARE CREATED AND THAT
TOO. CREATE THIS FUNDS. BUT IT'S
REALLY TO WE KNOW WE SHARE THAT
ALL HE HAVE BEEN HERE DICK. AT
ALL PEOPLE HAVEN'T VALUE AND ALL
PEOPLE HAVE INHERENT WORTH AND
NOT THE VERY LEAST SAID NOT LIVE
IN MISERY SO NOT LIVE IN A LACKS
TO NOT LIVE IN POVERTY. IN THE
STATE WITH SUCH IMMENSE ABOUT
DATES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM DOCTOR TO BE
COUPLE SEAN WHO IS THE ACTING
SURGEON GENERAL. FOR THE STATE
ACCOUNTABLE CALIFORNIA PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DR DAVID COMPLETION. I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN CHIEF HEALTH
OFFICER AND ACTING CALIFORNIA
SURGEON GENERAL IT'S A TRUE
PLEASURE TO JOIN THIS PANEL
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF EARLY LIFE STRESS AND
PROPERTY. ADDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA POVERTY MEASURE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AS MANY AS A
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS LIVES IN
POVERTY OR IN NEAR POVERTY. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE AS FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AS THIS
PANEL WILL KNOW WELL. SINCE THEN
COBIT NINETEEN IS ONLY LIKELY TO
HAVE INCREASED POVERTY AND OTHER
SIGNIFICANT STRESSORS AND
INEQUITIES. IN THIS WILL FURTHER
SEPARATE AT THE TO CALIFORNIA'S
THE CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA MENTIONED.
THE SCIENCE TELLS US THAT EARLY
AND PROLONGED STRESS CAN HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON LIFE ON
HEALTH. WE KNOW THIS IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE LANDMARK BURKE MY
CHILDHOOD ADVERSITY THAT WAS LED
BY THE CDC AND BY KAISER
PERMANENTE A- IN THAT WORK THE
DEFINED TEN EXPERIENCES. ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES OR ACES
WHICH INCLUDED CHILD ABUSE CHILD
NEGLECT AND GROWING UP WITH A
CHALLENGE SUCH AS SOMEBODY IN
THE HOUSEHOLD FACING
INCARCERATION WERE UNTREATED
MENTAL ILLNESS. HE SAYS ARE
EXTREMELY COMMON THE MAJORITY OF
US MORE THAN SIX IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS WILL HAVE
EXPERIENCED AT LEAST ONE ACE BY
AGE EIGHTEEN. AND ONE IN SIX OF
US WILL BE EXPERIENCED. FOUR OR
MORE ACES. AND WHEN A SAYS A
WITHOUT STIFF PROTECTIVE FACTORS
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE SUPPORTED CARE
GIVING. A WHOLE SET OF
BIOLOGICAL CHANGES CAN GET SET
INTO MOTION CALLED THE TOXIC
STRESS RESPONSE. TOXIC STRESS
DESCRIBES ALTERATIONS IN BRAIN
STRUCTURE AND FUNCTION IN
HORMONAL REGULATION IN METABOLIC
PROCESS SEES IN THE IMMUNE
RESPONSE AND IN THE WAY THAT
CELLS IN BODIES AGE. THESE
BIOLOGICAL CHANGES CAN BECOME
INCLUDED INTO THE WAY THAT OUR
GENES ARE READ AND EVEN PASSED
DOWN FROM ONE GENERATION TO THE
NEXT. SO HE SAYS IN THE
RESULTING TOXIC STRESS RESPONSE
THAT CAN OCCUR OR A ROOT CAUSE
TOO MANY OF THE MOST COMMON
SERIOUS AND COSTLY HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE TODAY.
THIS INCLUDES NINE OUT OF TEN OF
THE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH
NATIONALLY. SUCH AS HEART
DISEASE CANCER DIABETES AS WELL
AS SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
LIFE EXPECTANCY AND HEALTH CARE
COSTS. SO WHILE POVERTY WAS NOT
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL TEN PIECES
POVERTY IS CERTAINLY A PROFOUND
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. AND IT'S
A RISK FACTOR BOTH FOR PIECES
OCCURRING AND INDEPENDENTLY FOR
TOXIC STRESS AS WELL. AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT CASES AFFECTING
ALL COMMUNITIES WE DO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE OF SIGNIFICANT SOCIAL
AND STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES SOME
POPULATIONS ARE AFFECTED
DISPROPORTIONATELY. BREAK FOR
INSTANCE FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY ALMOST TWICE AS LIKELY
TO EXPERIENCE HE SAYS AND OTHER
ADVERSITIES IN ADDITION TO BEING
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE KINDS OF RESOURCES NEEDED TO
REALLY PREVENT THOSE ACES FROM
LEADING TO TOXIC STRESS. SO
POVERTY CAN NOT ONLY AMPLIFY THE
IMPACT OF BASIS BUT HE SAYS MAKE
IT MORE LIKELY THAT A PERSON
WILL SUFFER FROM CHALLENGES LIKE
POVERTY HOMELESSNESS AND
INCARCERATION. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
POVERTY CAN INDUCE SIGNIFICANT
STRESS ON A DAILY BASIS AND CAN
LEAD THEIR BY TO THE TOXIC
STRESS RESPONSE IN AND OF ITSELF
. FORTUNATELY ONCE WE HAVE A
TOXIC STRESS RESPONSE IN PLACE
WE CAN ACTUALLY TREAT IT AS A
HEALTH CONDITION. AND SEVEN
SUPPORTED THE S. IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
LAUNCHED THE PIECES AWARENESS
SHOULD OF THROUGH WHICH
CLINICIANS WILL RECEIVE TRAINING
CLINICAL TOOLS AND PROTOCOLS AND
REIMBURSEMENT TO SCREEN FOR AND
TREAT. TOXIC STRESS THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH EAST AS- THE
TREATMENTS THAT WE RECOMMEND
BETTER EVIDENCE BASED INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE ENHANCING SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS HIGH QUALITY SLEEP
SLEEP. ANTI INFLAMMATORY
NUTRITION EXERCISE MINDFULNESS
PRACTICES EXPERIENCES IN NATURE
AND WHEN NEEDED AND TO HEALTH
CARE. SO FAR THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
TRAINED AND MORE THAN HALF A
MILLION MEDI CAL PATIENTS HAVE
BEEN SCREENED FOR HE SAYS. THE
ACES EQUITY ACT WHICH WENT INTO
EFFECT EARLIER THIS YEAR HAS
ALSO NOW SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED
COVERAGE FOR EAST GREETING TO
ALL PRIVATE HEALTH PLANS. OUR
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS POSITION
US TO CONTINUE REDUCING THE
IMPACT OF EARLY ADVERSITY AND
TOXIC STRESS IN FUNDAMENTAL WAYS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR WORK TO POSITIVELY TRANSFORM
LIVES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM DIRECTOR TIM JOHNSON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR. THANK YOU
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON KIM JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND GLAD TO BE ON THIS
DISTINGUISHED PANEL THIS
AFTERNOON. THE COMMITTEES ASKED
ABOUT THE PRIORITIES OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ON ENDING
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA AND
CRITICAL NEAR TERM STEPS THAT
MUST BE ACCOMPLISHED TO DO SO. I
WANT JUST SAY HERE WISH SO MUCH
THAT WE DO AND ACT TOGETHER
ESPECIALLY WITH THE
UNPRECEDENTED AND HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS AT BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
THE LEGISLATURE I JUST IN THIS
PAST YEAR THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPERATIONALIZED ALTERNATELY. WE
ARE WORKING TO ACHIEVE A
CALIFORNIA WHERE RACE ETHNICITY
GENDER IDENTITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND OTHER FORMS OF
SOCIAL CATEGORIZATION NO LONGER
PREDICT A PERSON'S FOR
COMMUNITIES HEALTH AND LIFE
OUTCOMES YOU JUST HEARD A LOT
ABOUT SOCIAL DETERMINANTS AND
REALLY ENSURING THAT HOUSING AND
FOOD SECURITY WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. DR DISEASE
AND WORSEN HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY SO HOW WE ARE
FOCUSED. ON ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES OUR STRATEGIC PRIORITIES
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCIES INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE REDUCING HOMELESSNESS
ESPECIALLY CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
BY FOCUSING ON THE HOUSING FIRST
STRATEGY AND BUILDING UP
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND THE SUPPORT SERVICES NEEDED
BY THOSE WE HOUSING SUPPORT
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AS A
PATH OUT OF POVERTY AGAIN A
SPACE WHERE JUSTIN THIS PAST
YEAR OVER TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS. I WAS. INVESTED TO
SUPPORT THIS GOAL. OFF THE
RECORD. AND UTILIZE MANY HOW A
TOOL HELP YOU MANY THE COMP
CHALLENGES FACING CALIFORNIA'S
MOST MOBILE RESIDENTS INCLUDING
THE HOMELESS. THOSE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS CHILDREN WITH
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND
THOSE WHO ARE JUSTICE INVOLVED
IN THE GROWING AGING POPULATION.
THERE'S ALSO A STRATEGIC
PRIORITY AROUND STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY NET TO
DISTRACT THE INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES THAT FUEL THE
PANDEMIC IN ORDER TO LIFT
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY. AND
CREATE ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY
AND THE SPACE THERE ARE
PROPOSALS IN THIS YEAR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUCH AS THAT.
MAXIM A PAYMENT INCREASE THINK
HOW WORKS OF SEVEN POINT ONE
PERCENT. ACTUALLY I WOULD
ACTUALLY OPERATIONALIZE IN MORE
IN THAT SPACE. I WE ALSO OF
COURSE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES. AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO STRENGTHEN OUR PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA OUTCOMES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW SYSTEM
OR CAL OR WERE ABLE TO REALLY
IDENTIFY WHAT IS WORKING. IN
TERMS OF THE PROGRAM DESIGN AND
RESOURCES THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD. WE ALSO HAVE A
STRATEGIC PRIORITY AROUND THE
PEOPLE NEW AND INNOVATIVE PATHS
TO TRAIN AND HIRE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WORKERS TO MEET THE
FULL DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES NEEDS
AND AGAIN. THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSES A ONE TIME ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
OVER THREE YEARS IN THE CARICOM
YOU WORK FORCE I BY BOTH THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THAT'S TRUE.
NOT ONLY OF THE STRATEGY OF THE
DELIVERY COMPONENTS OF OUR
SAFETY NET BUT ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE CAREER PATHWAYS. THAT CAN
SUPPORT THEM. TO MEET THEIR
GOALS. A LOT THERE I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE AT THE FEW THAT
FOR QUESTION. BUT WILL ON TO SAY
QUESTION WAS WHAT ARE THE DID.
OF THOSE. AND CORE SOCIAL NET.
AND WHAT THIS MEAN TOWARDS OUR
APPROACH TOWARDS EQUITY AND
EQUITY. I CAN HELP WORKS I WOULD
NOTE THAT- 79% OF THE COW WORKS
ACT HE SLOWED OUR POPULATION
BEING SERVED OUR CHILDREN THEIR
CHILDREN UNDER EIGHTEEN. AND
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF. THE ONLY
STATE IN THE NATION WHO PASS A
SAFETY NET THAT CONTINUES THE
CASH ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT. FOR
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING PROPERTY A
PROPERTY FOR THE CHILD EVEN. IF
THE PARENT IS NOT PARTICIPATING
GIVEN THAT STABILITY TO THE
FAMILY. NEARLY 90% OF THE
OVERALL EXPLODING CAL WORKS IS
FEMALE. I WOULD ALSO HAVE 31% OF
THE CASELOAD SPEAKING AT AND AT
FIRST LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH. IN CALFRESH I WOULD
NOTE THAT NEARLY 39% OF THE
OVERALL FOUR POINT SIX
INDIVIDUALS SERVED OUR CHILDREN.
AT OVER TWO MILLION ARE AGES
EIGHTEEN TO FIFTY NINE. I AM
JUST A HUNDRED MILLION ARE OVER
SIXTY. WE ALSO SEE A TWENTY SIX
POINT 5% OF THAT CASELOAD AT.
SPEAKING ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE AS AN EXAMPLE. SO JUST
IF YOU'VE BEEN A GRAPHICS
STATISTICS BEAR I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT IN OUR HOUSING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HOMELESS
PROGRAMS DISPARITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXISTS THERE.
AGAIN ESPECIALLY. FOR A LOT OF
OUR- THESE INDIVIDUALS COLOR. I
AM INTO THE MEASURE WHAT THE
PANEL RT SPOKE INTO TOO SO I
TERMS THAT EQUITY. I HOW WE LOOK
AT INFORMATION AND IN. OUR TOP
AND THAT IT IT'S LIKE RECOGNIZE
. AT THE IN THE K. AND HOW WORKS
DAM FOR CARE AND- MAKING THAT
ACT. TO BEGIN HIGH CHILDCARE AND
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES AS IT IS AS
ROBUST AS IT CAN BE. A LOOKING
AT DEVELOPING OUT WHICH WE DID
TOGETHER AT THE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE H. DRANK THE
BASED APPROACH TO CONNECTING.
OUR FAMILIES EXPERIENCING CAR TO
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO.
ARE LOOKING AT KOKORIN
STRATEGIES IN OUR TRAINING AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS LOOKING AT
LANGUAGE ACCESS IN TERMS OF. OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AND MORE AND HOW
WE ARE REACHING OUT PROGRAM SO
AGAIN. ALL OF OUR POLICIES I
WILL NOTE THAT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY AT TWO YEARS AGO
NOW WE ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF
EQUITY TO REALLY ENSURE THAT.
OUR TEAM OUR STAFF HAS THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT OUR POLICIES
THROUGH A RACIAL EQUITY TRAIN
AND LANDS. ARE IN THERE BUT
THERE BY CONTINUE TO PROPOSED
POLICIES THINGS LIKE OUR OUR
WORK ON AT SUPPORTING IT CAN TO
CONTINUITY FOR FAMILIES
CONNECTED TO CAL WORKS EVEN
MAYBE WHEN THEY ARE LOOKING TO
GET. BY WITH THEIR CHILD AND
THEIR MANY OTHER EXAMPLES THAT I
CAN GIVE THAT SPACE BUT I WOULD
ALSO JUST SAY. THE DATA IS KEY
ABOUT WE ARE LOOKING AT OUR DATA
TO SEE WHO WE ARE SERVING HOW
THEY ARE DOING AND WHY. AND WHO
ARE WE ARE SERVING- AND HOW WE
CAN MEET BETTER REACH THOSE
POPULATIONS WHICH BRINGS ME TO
YOUR NEXT QUESTION ON THE
AGENDA. AROUND HOW CAN BE BETTER
FASTER POPULATIONS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE. I'LL JUST NOTE NOTE IN
TERMS OF AGAIN THE CAN. XIN WE
HAVE A SAFETY NET THAT HAS MANY
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS. I WITHIN
IT REALLY LOOKING AT NOT ONLY
CASH SUPPORTS THE FOOD SUPPORTS
THE HOUSING SUPPORTS THE HEALTH.
SUPPORTS BUT HOW THESE TIED
TOGETHER IN THE WHOLE PERSON AND
THAT PERSON CENTERED. APPROACH
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING. I WE CAN
SIR LEARN A LOT INTO OF OUR
EVERY STRATEGY. ARE AND YEAH AND
AT A CERTAIN. FROM IN CALFRESH
HOW MAKE SENSE TO THE S. I SS
KEEP. HOW WE TARGETED
INTENTIONAL FACT DIFFERENT MODES
. TO REACH POPULAR THAT THEM THE
SCHOOL. SUPPORTS I WOULD DO IN
THE SPACE OF. STUDENTS WHICH
WOULD FEEL MORE ABOUT. THAT
LATER IN YOUR- THIS AFTERNOON.
IT'S HOW WORK WE HAVE IN OUR
BALANCE. ACT THROUGH. OUT BOTH
AGAIN LET'S JUST. IN THE- AT
SUPPORT INVEST AROUND HOW WORKS
OUT REGIONALLY. LONG A K. WORKS
THEY- STATEWIDE ADVISED COUNTY.
AGAIN WORK LOOKING TO BUILD ON
THIS. THAT HAVE WORKED IN THE
CALFRESH SPACE BUT AGAIN. I
DEFINE HOW WE CAN CONNECT TO THE
FULL ARRAY OF SERVICES AND AGAIN
THINKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND TARGETED.
AND FOCUSED OUTREACH TO
POPULATIONS WHO WE KNOW ARE
ELIGIBLE AND NOT BEING SERVED.
AND THEN FINALLY YOU HAVE A
QUESTION RELATED TO AT THE
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT PROGRAM
WE ARE THRILLED. TO BE LAUNCHING
THIS INITIATIVE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. OVER FIVE YEARS
. LISA PAUL. AB WILL GIVE US.
ELIGIBLE INTO T. TO. HIGH
PROGRAM THAT FOR THAT TEETH IN
TO PER. WILL BE PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR PILOT PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THAT SERVE. AT
CALIFORNIANS WHO AGE OUT OF AT
THE FOSTER PROGRAM. AT OR AFTER
AGE TWENTY ONE AND- OR WHO ARE
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS. I WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED WITH MANY ADULTS ON
THIS PANEL AND OTHERWISE AND
WITH MANY MANY STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP
EMPLOYEES WHO WANT TO BUILD ON
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE TO
DATE IN THE SPACE AND- LESSONS
LEARNED. WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
DIRECTLY TO THE PRIORITY
POPULATIONS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF THE DESIGN
AND THE RESOURCES AND
CONNECTIONS THAT WOULD MOST
BENEFIT THEM. AT TO REACH THEIR
GOALS SO THAT HAS BEEN THAT
THERE AT BOTH. OF OUR WORK OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. THE
CHEST AND- AB RELEASED OUR- OUR
OUR- FOR IN ABOUT. IN WILL BE.
THAT SPACE AND I FINALLY AT THIS
WEEK WE WILL BE RELEASING A
PLANNING DOCUMENT TO HELP OUR
PERSPECTIVE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
PREPARE. FOR THAT FINAL REQUEST
FOR APPLICATIONS WORK TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PILOT. I
WHICH WILL BE RELEASED IN LATE
SPRING. AND I WORK WITH THERE
THANK YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. L.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA MEMBERS AS
SUNNY PEDIG WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY PREPARED REMARKS BETTER HERE
TO- TAKE NOTE OF ANY. SPECIAL
REQUESTS OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAIRED TO BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION I FIRST WANNA THANK
DR- CRUSTY FOR THE ENDING
POVERTY BLUEPRINT- IF NO ONE HAS
READ IT IS LINKED TO THE AGENDA
AND I'M HAPPY- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE. TAKING A LOOK AT IT
BUT WANTED TO DIG INTO SOME OF
THE CONCLUSIONS THAT YOU ARE
MOVING TOWARDS. AS I WOULD LIKE
TO ECHO WHAT YOU SAID DURING
YOUR TESTIMONY THAT WE CAN'T
BANK EXCLUSIVELY ON THE SAFETY
NET. AND THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO DO THE INSTITUTIONAL WORK
THAT IS PRE THIS TRIBUTE ED THAT
I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE
NEED FOR US TO HAVE DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEMS AND
SPECIFICALLY. HOW THOSE SYSTEMS
CAN ASSIST US IN ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE ARE- AND ROLLED INTO
PROGRAMS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
APPLICABLE TO SINCE IT SEEMS
THAT WE AS A GOVERNMENT HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE THOSE
SYSTEMS TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
ENROLLING INTO PROGRAMS AND
WONDERING HOW YOU CAN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US TO
INTEGRATE AND ALLOW THOSE POSTS
PROGRAMS TO ASSIST. US TO EXTEND
AS WELL. DR EMULATING DR GRETZKY
HAD TO LEAVE TO TEACH A CLASS HE
LEFT A MESSAGE IN THE CHAT THAT
UN FORTUNATELY HAD TO LEAVE THE
PANEL. WITH THAT I WILL FOLLOW
UP AS- I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY THEN
TURN THE QUESTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION- THE CLAIM THAT
WE HAVE FROM HIM IS THAT OUR
CURRENT DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEMS
DO NOT ALLOW US TO APPROPRIATELY
DO CRISIS DETECTION PROBLEMS AS
WELL AS LEGACY MICRO SIMULATION
MODELING. AND AS I WAS STATING
EARLIER AT THE COURT OF
APPLICATIONS I'M WONDERING IF WE
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO INTEGRATE THESE DATA SYSTEMS
TO BETTER ALLOW US TO STREAMLINE
THE APPLICATION SYSTEMS TO THE
US REDUCE BARRIERS AND
ENROLLMENT I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FOLLOW UP
WITH DOCTOR CRASKE. TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ACTUALIZE SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS INTO
CHANGES WE MAKE GOING FORWARD
I'M HOPING TO HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION COMMENT ON THAT
IF POSSIBLE. SURE JOHNSON AT THE
PROPOSAL SERVICES I WILL JUST
THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE OTHER
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES I DIDN'T
MENTION JUST IN TERMS OF BEING
BRIEF IT'S CERTAINLY A FOCUS OF
OURS WITH A CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AND
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING WITH MANY
MANY PARTNERS SO WE'D BE GLAD TO
AT ITS BEST THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THIS
REPORT. I WORK WITH DOCTOR
DOCTOR RESCUE MATTERS AT TO
DETERMINE THE FEASIBILITY OF
THIS. I'D LIKE NOW FOLLOW UP
WITH. MAYOR TUBBS OF FIVE COULD
AND SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY. CHANGES
THAT YOU CAN RECOMMEND TO US FOR
THE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT ARE
COVERED UNDER. TODAY'S AGENDA
AND FOR CAL WORK SPECIFICALLY.
EFFORTS TO SHIFT THE CULTURE IN
THE PROGRAM AWAY FROM WORK FOR
FOCUSED TOWARDS BARRIER REMOVAL.
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT MATERNAL
HEALTH AND FAMILY STABILIZATION.
BUT I'M WONDERING WHAT ELSE CAN
WE DO TO FURTHER FACILITATE THIS
CHANGE IN OUR FAMILY
STABILIZATION PROGRAM. AND WHERE
WE SEE SO MUCH STIGMA AND SO
MUCH DESTITUTION STILL EXIST.
I'M HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THAT MAYOR TOPS. YEAH YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND APPRECIATE BOTH THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN ONGOING
DIRECTOR JOHNSON INTO QUESTION
YOU POSED AROUND SERVICE AND THE
COORDINATION OTHER THINGS
ANYTHING TO DO BETTER- MEET
MISTER CHAIR IN TERMS OF. YOUR
QUESTION I THINK WE HAVE TO
AGAIN REALLY DOUBLE DOWN ON THIS
IDEA THAT. IT'S NOT LIKE IF
PEOPLE ARE WORKING IS BECAUSE
THERE'S BARRIERS TO WORK OUTSIDE
OF DESIRE I THINK SO MANY OF THE
WAYS THIS COMES FROM SORT OF MY
GRANDMOTHER SPENDING HER TIME AT
THE CONGRESS AS BOTH THE
OFFICER. IN SAN JOAQUINCOUNTY
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND SO MUCH OF.
THE ORIENTATION WAS AROUND THANK
FORCING PEOPLE TO WORK WITH I
THINK THIS THIS FOCUS ON LIKE
LET'S REMOVE BARRIERS TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO WORK. IS
THAT RIGHT ONCE THE REALLY
DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT IN WE HAVE
TO GET RID OF WORK REQUIREMENTS
AND I KNOW THAT SEEMS RADICAL I
KNOW THAT SUBSTANCE IN TWO
DIFFERENT PARADIGM SHIFT BUT BUT
I'LL KNOW. TO YOUR POINT TO THE
POINT IS CONVENING THAT WERE IN
A MOMENT WHERE WE HAVE TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE IMAGINATIVE IN
OUR THINKING AND REALLY PUSH
BACK. ON DEC BAY HELD SACROSANCT
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
ACTUAL OUTCOMES ARE NOTHING DO
WITH SERVICE DELIVERY AND I
REALLY HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
DEEPLY HELD AND INGRAINED
BELIEFS ABOUT WHY PEOPLE FIND
THEMSELVES IN IN IN IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS I THINK. CANCER
QUESTIONS ARE CLEARLY MISTER
CHARMING GETTING RID OF WORK
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE- SORT OF
THE THAT THE NORTH THE NORTH
STAR AND ALSO. CONNECTING TO TWO
OTHER SUPPORTS I THINK DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND- PROFESSOR GRETZKY
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S OVERLAP
THAT VERY RARELY WILL YOU FIND.
ONE PERSON WHO JUST QUALIFIED
FOR ONE OF OUR PROGRAMS BUT THEY
QUALIFY FOR A BUNCH OTHER
PROGRAMS ALTHOUGH THEY MAY BE
ONLY ABLE TO ACCESS A COUPLE OF
PERHAPS THE QUALIFY FOR. SOME
RELIEF BEGIN LEGALISTIC WEEK
ABOUT OUR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT OUR
CITIZENS. AND THAT SOMEONE NEEDS
. CALCOT WORK SUPPORT PROBLEM.
THAT THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
PROBLEM HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING.
BORDER PEPPERONI CHARGES SUPPORT
NINETY CREATORS WAY AT MAKE IT
EASY. FOR FOLKS AT THEIR- SO
THAT THEY CAN GET ON THE PATH.
THIS THAT. BUT HARD. TO GET ON
THE PATH OF THE- WHEN DON'T WANT
TO FLOOR. THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO STAND A THIS DIDN'T CRASHED
INK. IN GAPS. I WILL EXPOUND.
WHAT YOU DO SAID ABOUT HOW WE-
USED. TO HELP TO PREVENT JUST TO
REALLY MAKES I. MAKE THE TWO WE
AS A- STATE ARE REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW TO DO INCOME AND
EMPLOYMENT VERIFICATION SYSTEM
MATCHES FOR THOSE WHO ARE ON TO
CAL WORKS CALFRESH AND MEDI CAL.
BUT WE DON'T TURN AROUND AND SAY
IF THEIR INCOME WAS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT THEY WOULD THEN QUALIFY
FOR A. B. AND C. AND I BELIEVE
THAT WHEN WE TURN THOSE PROGRAMS
TO HELP US TO ASSIST PEOPLE. TO
SECURE THE BENEFITS WE WILL MOVE
A BIG STEP FORWARD TO ENDING
POVERTY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT FOR US TO LEAVE
THE CONVERSATION TODAY WITH. IS
THAT THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE THERE
TO HELP. THOSE WHO CALL THIS
STATE HOME SECURE RESOURCES
RATHER THAN TO PREVENT AND
HINDER- THOSE WHO ARE. WHO ARE
ASKING FOR HELP IN WHO NEED THE
HELP. RIGHT NOW. WITH THAT. I DO
FEEL OBLIGATED TO HIGHLIGHT AND
UPLIFT MUCH OF THE WORK THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO
SUPPORT OVERLOOKED POPULATIONS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
HEALTHCARE WAS MENTIONED AND
MEDICAL EXPANSION TO ALL IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FOR US TO
ADDRESS WHAT HAS BEEN MEAN
POVERTY DRIVER FOR MANY WITHIN
OUR LATINO POPULATIONS BUT ALSO
WANTS TO HIGHLIGHT THE WORK THAT
IS GOING ON WITHIN THE PATH FOR
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATIONS
WHO ARE. NEEDING A REAL SECOND
CHANCE TO- COME BACK INTO
SOCIETY AFTER BEING JAILED AS
EXAMPLES OF HOW WE ARE HELPING
TO SUPPORT OVERLOOKED
POPULATIONS I KNOW THAT THERE'S
MUCH MORE WORK FOR US TO DO- I
DON'T. WANTS TO END THIS
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY AS I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION FOR US TO HAVE. BUT
WILL POINT TO THE FACT THAT THE
SPEAKER HAS JUST BEGUN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON POVERTY AND
ON ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND WILL
MOVE MUCH OF THIS CONVERSATION
INTO THAT SELECT COMMITTEE. AND
WITH THAT WILL THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL ONE AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PANEL TO. MOVING ON TO
ISSUE TOO TODAY WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND OVERSIGHT OVER KEY
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS AND CAL
WORKS. WE WILL HAVE EIGHT
PRESENTERS ON PANEL TWO. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH JENNIFER HERNANDEZ
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND
EMPOWERMENT DIVISION DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE WILL THEN HAVE CRISTINA MESSA
CAL WORKS AND FAMILY RESILIENCE
BRANCH CHIEF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
JANINE DR FINANCIAL BUDGET
ANALYST FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE
L. A. RO. JAMAICA GASKINS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF GRACE AND
CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIA.
JENNIFER BRETT B. THE LEAD
CHAPTER ORGANIZER FOR PARENTS
VOICES CALIFORNIA MIKE HERALDS
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND KATHY CENTRELINE
MCDONALD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. LET'S
BEGIN WITH DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HERNANDEZ WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE THIS IS
ACTUALLY CRISTINA MESSA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AT YOU FOR THE PRODUCTS
AND END THE RESILIENCE FRENCH
AND I WILL BE KICKING US OFF
THIS AFTERNOON. I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HAVING US AS STARTING
FIRST WITH ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THAT YOU POSED AROUND
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION SEEMS A
ROLL CALL WORKS IN ITS OVERALL
ANTI POVERTY STRATEGY. SO AT THE
BED THE PRIMARY CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING POVERTY AT CAL
WORKS PLAYS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN ENSURING THAT OUR FAMILIES
ARE SUPPORTED. ECONOMICALLY BUT
ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO CRITICAL
RESOURCES TO HELP OUR FAMILIES
MEET THOSE BASIC NEEDS ARE AS AN
INTERVENTION OF ME WE KNOW
CAPTIONS ASSISTANCE APPROVED
HELP. AND EDUCATION OUTCOMES AS
WE HEARD EARLIER ESPECIALLY FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE
PROBABLY- ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
WE'RE NOT QUITE AT THE
LEGISLATURE THERE'S A GOAL OF
INCREASING THE MAXIMUM EIGHTEEN
MINUTES. AT 250% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AFTER ALL
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THE CURRENT
PROPOSED INCREASE AS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON MENTIONED EARLIER I HAVE
A SEVEN POINT 1% WILL BRING AYE
THOSE NON EXEMPT- MAPPING AT
THAT TIME MAXIM EIGHT PAYMENT
LEVELS TWO NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE DOLLARS PER MONTH.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE UNIT OUR
FAMILY THREE RESIDING IN ONE OF
OUR HIGH COST COUNTY. WHICH IS
AT LEAST A 54% OF THE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. THIS PROPOSAL POINT ONE
PER. IN IS ON THE OF. AT CURRENT
PRODUCTION OF THE FUNDING IN THE
HARPER AND SUPPORT SEVEN. I A
REMINDER THAT SUB ACCOUNT IS TO
THE BILL. OF TO THE- THESE
INCREASES. JUST LAST YEAR IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WE-
WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT A FIVE
POINT 3% MAPPING CREATES. THAT
INCREASE BROUGHT OUR OUR MAP
LEVELS TO NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER MONTH
ACCORDING TO THE STATE UNIT OF
THREE RESIDING IN THOSE HIGH
COST COUNTIES WHICH EQUATED 251%
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. IN ADDITION TO
THE- A INCREASE ON THE MAP
LEVELS COLORS HAS EXPERIENCED.
THAT THROUGH. A ROBUST
INVESTMENT ONCE BUDGET CYCLE
SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
OTHER IMPLEMENTING THIS YEAR TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BROADER ANTI POVERTY
STRATEGY. FIRST WE WANTED TO
MENTION TO THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD INCREASED SO AS A
REMINDER THAT EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD. ALLOWS APPLICANTS TO
WAIT A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF EARNED
INCOME FOR EACH EARNER IN THE
FAMILY AT TIME OF APPLICATION
FOR COWARDS BENEFITS. CURRENTLY
IS THE AMOUNT THAT EARNER CAN
WAIVE THE APPLICATION IS NINETY
DOLLARS. AND THAT IS MOVING UP
TO FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR EACH EARNER
AFFECTIVE JULY AT THIS YEAR. WE
ALSO SAW EXPANSION AND
INVESTMENTS FOR THE PREGNANCY
SPECIAL NEEDS PAYMENTS THAT
RECIPIENTS RECEIVED. AS WELL AS
EXPANSION FOR PREGNANCY
ELIGIBILITY RULES. AFFECTED IN
MAY OF THIS YEAR WILL SEE THAT
INCREASE TO THE PREGNANCY
SPECIAL. PAYMENT WHICH IS A
MONTHLY SUPPLEMENT THAT'S
PROVIDED TO PREGNANT CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS AND THAT IS MOVING
FROM FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH. THEN
EFFECTIVE IN JULY- WE'RE
EXPANDING CAL WORKS ELIGIBILITY
TO ALL PREGNANT ADULTS. WHO ARE
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR CAL WORKS
CASH EVEN SERVICES INCLUDING
THAT MONTHLY PREGNANCY SPECIAL
NEED PAVEMENT. AS A REMINDER
PRIOR TO THIS MOVE A FOLKS HAD
TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE FIRST
TRIMESTER OF PREGNANCY I TO
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR A WORK. I
WERE ALSO MOVING INTO IN MAY OF
THIS YEAR TO A SIXTEEN MONTH
TIME LIMIT SO THE CAL WORKS
MAXIMUM TIME LIMIT WILL INCREASE
FROM FORTY EIGHT MONTHS TO SIXTY
MONTHS ADDING TWELVE ADDITIONAL
MONTHS AND EVERYONE'S. AT A TIME
EIGHT. WE ALSO SAW IT INVESTMENT
TO SUPPORT FAMILY REUNIFICATION
ARE THE BUDGET AS PROPOSED
INCLUDES NINE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
SIX MONTHS OF CASH EVEN SERVICES
WHICH IS INCLUSIVE OF THE
CONTINUATION OF CHILD CARE
SERVICES FOR THE CHILD TO THE
PARENTS OF CHILDREN. WE HAVE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE HOME BY
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND THAT
IS THE FACT AND JULY OF THIS
YEAR. THIS CONTINUATION OF AID
AND SERVICES INTENDED TO HELP
PROMOTE. THE PREVENTION OF
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT AND
SUPPORT THE REUNIFICATION OF OUR
POWERS FAMILY. THERE'S ALSO A
QUESTION THAT- IN THE AGENDA
AROUND HOW IT WORKS HE SPOKE. AT
SO QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY TO
WHAT ARE THAT THE RECENT TRENDS
IN COLOR SCHEMES VOTE.
APPLICATION DENIALS EXIT RATES
WHAT ARE THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONCERNED ABOUT TAKE UP RATES IN
THE PROGRAM FOR FAMILIES THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE BUT NOT ENROLLED IN
COLOR. SO START FIRST SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR COLOR
EXCUSE OVERALL AND THEN I'LL
SHARE A OF I THOUGHT. THAT THE
COLOR EXTRA UP RIGHT. SO I'LL
CAL WORK AT CONTINUE EXPERIENCE
IN THE CO IN OVERALL KEY FEDERAL
FIRST HALF. SB TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALENDAR YEAR AT WORKS X. A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
APPLICATION VOLUME DURING THE
LATE SUMMER AND FALL MONTHS OF
LAST YEAR AROUND THE SAME TIME
THAT MANY CALIFORNIANS WERE
EXPERIENCING. A LOSS OF THOSE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS I HAD BEEN
EXPANDED. BY THE DEPARTMENT
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
FOLKS OVER AT UT DETAINED SURE%
THAT. RECIPIENTS THAT WERE
FACING THAT BENEFIT CLIPPING
EDT. HAD ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
AND INFORMATION NEEDED TO APPLY
FOR SAFETY NET BENEFITS THROUGH
A COLECTIVE OUTREACH STRATEGIES
THAT INCLUDED. BOTH CALFRESH AND
HOW IT WORKS. WHERE STILL
WAITING ON FINAL DATA THEM
WHETHER THE INCREASE THAT WEEKS
. APPLICATION VOLUME AT
CONTRIBUTED TO AN INCREASE IN
CASE LOAD BUT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE WILL SEE THAT INCREASE I ONCE
THAT DATA IS AVAILABLE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE DENIALS OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WERE PROCESSED
DURING THE PANDEMIC WERE HEAVILY
DID NINETY TWO BEING OVER
INCOME. A LIKELY ATTRIBUTED TO
BE ADDED TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS OF FOLKS WERE
RECEDING HOWEVER WE ONLY HAVE
DATA AVAILABLE THROUGH JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO WE'RE
UNABLE TO SEE AT THIS TIME IF
THAT TREND REMAINED VERY NICE
EDT BENEFIT CLASS. CURRENTLY ARE
KEY IS. OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES BUT AGAIN
WAITING ON MORE ACCURATE DATA TO
DEMONSTRATE A THE CASE OF
INCREASES THAT WERE ANTICIPATING
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT CANGES. TO
EXIT RATES IS THE KEYSTONE. HAS
HELD FAIRLY STEADY THIS PAST
YEAR. AND THEN THE LAST NOTE ON
OVERALL COLOR SCHEMES VOTERS BE
IMPLEMENTED COULD CAUSE FOR MANY
OF OUR WELFARE TO WORK
PARTICIPANTS. WE ALSO
EXPERIENCED A DECLINE IN OVERALL
SOLUTION PEACE BOAT I THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC A BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE BLANKET GOOD BECAUSE FOR
MANY OF OUR WELFARE TO WORK
PARTICIPATING. AT WORST THING
SHOULD. NOW MAKE UP A JUST UNDER
3% OF OUR TOTAL PEACE LOVING CAL
WORKS. SPEAKING OUT TO CALL
WORKS PICK UP RATES HOW TAKE A-
THAT WAS. BY THE L. A. O. AND-
LAST YEAR. A IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWO ONE- REPRESENTS A MOST READ
DATA. AT THE L. OF DEVELOP THE
METHODOLOGY IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE FOLKS OVER AT OUR
DEPARTMENT- IN A RESEARCH
AUTOMATION DATA TEAMS. AND THE
DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THAT THIS IS
AT THE BEST AND MOST RECENT
ESTIMATE OF THE LOCAL. A
CALCULATING THE TAKE UP RATE
RELIES ON THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY DATA. ATTENDRE STAND THE
POTENTIAL POPULATION. AND THE
CENSUS BUREAU HAS NOT RELEASED
MORE RECENT ACS DATA I DO TO
DATA COLLECTION CHALLENGES.
RESULTING FROM THAT COMPANY.
TEAM PANDEMIC. THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS THIS BUREAU TO RELEASE
THE NEXT. OF THAT THE NEEDED
DATA AND EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. WE ARE LOOKING AT SOME
ADDITIONAL DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS THAT TO SEE IF
THERE'S MORE INFORMATION WE CAN
PROVIDE. IN ADDITION TO THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS CONDUCTED BY
THE ATLEO AT JUST LAST YEAR. IN
TERMS OF BEING BUDGET- AND THE
QUESTION PERTAINING TO THE
BUDGET PROPOSED REDUCTION OF
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO.
ELIGIBILITY IN ADMINISTRATION
FUNDING FOR COUNTIES- WE WANTED
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING FOR
COMICS ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION IS DETERMINED BY.
A NEW YOUR METHODOLOGY THAT WAS
DEVELOPED IN COORDINATION WITH
ACCOUNTING. AND IMPLEMENTED IN
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AT THE VERY VERY HIGH CASELOAD-
AT PROJECTIONS DURING THE
PANDEMIC COULD NOT BEREALIZED
HOW WORKS ALTHOUGH THE FUNDING
INCREMENTS WERE MAINTAINED AND
PROVIDED YOU COUNTIES IN BOTH
FISCAL YEARS. NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AT THE CASE IT IS PRETTY TO
INCREASE FISCAL YEAR TWO
EIGHTEEN THREE IT'S NOT
INCREASING AND NOT TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THEM. ALL OF THOSE
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE PROVIDED TO
INCREASE YOUR AND CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. BUT
BASED ON THE APPROVED
METHODOLOGY THAT HE SPOKE WITH
ME TO BE A FORECASTED INCREASED
TO JUST OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIX THOUSAND HE SAYS. TO BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THE FUNDING LEVEL
THAT WAS PROVIDED. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ZERO. AT JUST AS A
REMINDER FOR HOW THE CALL WORKS
IN THE ALLOCATION IS FUNDED.
THAT COLOR THE ALLOCATION FUNDS
THREE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES ONE
BEING EMPLOYMENT SERVICES THE
SECOND BEING ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN THE
THIRD IS CAL LEARN INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT BUTTON. BUT OF
THE TOTAL SINGLE OUT. FUNDING
FISCAL YEARS TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO WHAT WE SAW WAS 63% WENT TO
PLYMOUTH SERVICES. 36% WENT YOU
ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATION AND
JUST ABOUT 1% WAS DISTRIBUTED
OUT. FOR THE THIRD CATEGORY. WE
ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER COMPONENTS WITHIN THE
CALL WORKS BUDGET THAT ARE NOT
FUNDED WITHIN THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION THAT ARE FUNDED
SEPARATELY AND THAT IS INCLUSIVE
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES. AS WELL AS
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH ART IN HEALTH CLINIC
PARTNERS- IT THAT SINGLE
PUBLICATION DOES NOT INCLUDE BE
EXPENDED SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE WORK
EXPERIENCE PROGRAM IN WHICH BUT
WAGES ARE SUBSIDIZED FOR
PARTICIPANTS SETTING EACH. IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE FAMILIES PEOPLE
IS EACH AND THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND THE COW WORKS IN
PROGRAM BUT THE THAT YOU CAN
FIND AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION SIDE. OF THAT
PROGRAM. AND THEN LASTLY ON THE
PEACE AROUND AT THE- BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE STATUS OF THE COLOR
WORKGROUP. BUT WE IN NOVEMBER OF
LAST YEAR LAUNCHED THE POLICY
ALIGNMENT WORK GROUP. OF THE
WORK GROUP HAS MET THREE TIMES
WITH A FOURTH AND FINAL SESSION
SCHEDULED FOR THIS WEEK. I JUST
OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
ORIGINAL COLOR POLICY ALIGNMENT
WORKGROUP REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. A REPORT ON THE
WORKGROUP. RECOMMENDATIONS AS
WELL SOME OF THE FEEDBACK AND
INFORMATION IS BEING SHARED IN
THAT SETTING. A TO SUPPORT BOTH
CALOR AS WELL AS COUNTY DRIVEN
COVERS TWO POINT OH PRINCIPLES.
IS SCHEDULED TO STILL BE
RELEASED ON APRIL FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM JANINE DR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI THIS
IS JEANINE DR WITH FINANCE I
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS POINT BUT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE L.
L. GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN ANDERSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- NUMBERS TO ADD BUT DO
YOU THINK IT BE HELPFUL TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
ON ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THE
- IT MINISTRATIONS JUST
ADDRESSED- THAT BEING ABOUT THE
CASE OF DYNAMICS IN THIS
PROGRAM. I KNOW THIS IS BEEN. A
CONTRAST TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
GENERAL TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR AS IT HAS BEEN TO OUR
OFFICE. THE CONTEXT IS THAT
HISTORICALLY WE EXPECT THEM ONE
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS ARE FOR THAT
IN. SPECIFICALLY WHEN
UNEMPLOYMENT IS HIGH THE
CASELOAD FOR CAL WORKS AND OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WILL GROW BY
US OUR OFFICE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WERE PROJECTING
LARGE CASELOAD INCREASES- AS A
RESULT OF THE ECONOMIC RECESSION
FOLLOWING THE PANDEMIC LAST
YEAR- NOW ACTUALLY TWO YEARS
AGO- BUT- THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
WHAT WE SAW WAS A TEMPORARY
INCREASE THAT SEEM TO BE. AS
PRIMARILY BY SOME POLICY CHANGES
IN THE FIRST COUPLE MONTHS
FOLLOWED BY LOVE PRECIPITOUS
DROP THAT REALLY HAS NO PARALLEL
THROUGHOUT THE HISTORY OF CAL
WORKS- WE ENDED UP WITH THE
LOWEST CASELOAD IN THE PROGRAM'S
HISTORY- SOMEWHERE AROUND THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES- AS OF
LAST SUMMER. NOW THIS OF COURSE
WAS A CONCERN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE RESTORATION
PROCESS IN PART BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS REACHING AS MANY
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES AS POSSIBLE IS
ALSO A CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE'RE
TASKED WITH PROJECTING HOW MUCH
THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO COST SO
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF PROPER
FORECASTING- SAID THAT AND FOR
OUR OFFICE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
INDEPENDENTLY INVESTIGATED. THE
POTENTIAL CAUSES OF THIS AND I
THINK REALLY THROUGH A PROCESS
OF ELIMINATION WE BOTH CAME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT THE MOST
LIKELY CAUSE OF THIS DYNAMIC HAS
TO DO WITH THE EXCEPTIONAL OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT'S BEEN
OFFERED BY THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS- THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC OKAY AN EXAMPLE OF THIS
WOULD BE THE EXPANDED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WHICH NOW
REACHES MORE PEOPLE THAN IT USED
TO AND FOR A LONG TIME WAS
OFFERING A REALLY SUBSTANTIAL
BONUS- DOES YOUR Y. BENEFITS-
LAPSED LAST SEPTEMBER AND SO
BOTH OF OUR BOTH OUR OFFICE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION PROJECTED.
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE THE
INFLECTION POINT THE POINT AT
WHICH CASE THAT BEGAN TO GROW
AGAIN IN LINE WITH OUR HISTORIC
EXPECTATIONS FINANCIAL DATA WE
NOW HAVE THROUGH DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR AT LEAST IN PART IT
DOES SUGGEST THAT SEPTEMBER OF
LAST YEAR WAS AN INFLECTION
POINT FOR CASE THOUGH THAT WE
DID SEE RESUMES GROWTH AFTER
MANY MONTHS OF DECLINE BUT TODAY
THAT GROWTH APPEARS RATHER
MODEST SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWO THOUSAND
CASES PER MONTH OLD OUR OFFICE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION PROJECTED
SOMETHING CLOSER TO TEN THOUSAND
CASES. PER MONTH. NOW ONE
POSSIBLE. WHY WE'RE SAYING
GROWTH THERE THAT THERE STILL.
WAS SOME. EIGHT AND- TAKES CHILD
TAX CREDIT- WHICH ONLY ALLOW
LAST DECEMBER SO PERHAPS- WITH
BATTLE ABSENT WILL WILL START TO
SEE A SLOW GROW AT AN EVEN
GREATER. ASIDE FROM THAT AND NO
REAL SUB COMMENTS OF WHAT'S BEEN
SAID SO FAR OR WHAT'S CONTAINED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM SHEMITAH GASKINS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF GRACE AND
CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY AGAIN I'M
SINGING ATKINS- RACED IN CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AND
OUR ORGANIZATIONAL MISSION IS TO
DARE TO IMAGINE A LIBERATED
FUTURE. FREE FROM SYSTEMIC
RACISM AND POVERTY IN WHICH ALL
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE THE
CHILDHOOD OF ABUNDANCE DIGNITY
LOVE AND OPPORTUNITIES TO DRIVE
. OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS ARE
CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN HARD AT WORK
IMPLEMENTING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE END CHILD POVERTY TASK
FORCE PLAN. ONE THAT YOU ALL
WORKED ON AS A LEGISLATURE BUT
ALSO BY PROFESSOR DAVID GONSKI
WHO YOU HEARD FROM EARLIER.
TODAY THIRTY EIGHT OF THE FORTY
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
EVIDENCE BASED HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED. THESE ACTIONS HAVE
RESULTED IN COMBINED PERMANENT
ONGOING COMMITMENTS TOTALING
ABOUT ELEVEN BILLION AND
202-021-2020 TWO AND WILL REACH
OVER THIRTEEN BILLION ANNUALLY
WHEN ALL PROGRAMS GO INTO
EFFECT. TOGETHER CALIFORNIA HAS
LIFTED THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY. THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THE SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CHILDREN
LIFTED OUT OF POVERTY BY FEDERAL
ACTIONS TAKING OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS INCLUDING EXPANDED CHILD
TAX CREDITS AND THE MULTIPLE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM MISTER ANDERSON. HOWEVER WE
ARE ALREADY SEEING TELL POVERTY
RATE PARTLY BOUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO ASK FEDERAL AND STATE
ONE TIME SOLUTIONS FALL AWAY AND
MANY SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AND THE
POST PANDEMIC ERA. CALIFORNIA
MUST TAKE FURTHER ACTION TO
SUSTAIN AND BUILD ON ITS RECENT
REDUCTIONS IN CHILD POVERTY. A
CORNERSTONE OF THE INTEL POVERTY
PLAN IS IT INDEED CHILD POVERTY
ACROSS THE STATE AND CUT OVERALL
POVERTY BY FIFTY PERCENT.
CHILDREN BORN INTO DEEP POVERTY
FACE SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGES
THAT MAKES SCALING THE ECONOMIC
LADDER ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING.
40% OF PEOPLE BORN INTO DEEP
POVERTY HAD INCOMES IN THE
BOTTOM FIFTH OF THE INCOME
DISTRIBUTION AS ADULTS COMPARED
218% OF PEOPLE BORN TO MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES. ONE NATIONAL
STUDY FOUND IN OTHER WORDS BEING
AND DEEP POVERTY MORE THAN
DOUBLES CHILDREN'S CHANCES OF
HAVING VERY LOW INCOMES IN THE
FUTURE. RELATIVE TO MIDDLE
INCOME CHILDREN. THE STATE YOU
SAID CHAIRED. A CHAIR AROUND AND
MAY MADE STRIDES IN MOVING
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY IT'S
DEEP ON. WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN
THERE YET AND WE KNOW OUR CAL
WORKS FAMILIES ARE AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY AS EMERGENCY SUPPORT
SUBSIDE. WITH THE UNPRECEDENTED
BUDGET SURPLUS WE SEE STRONG
AVENUES TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
THIS BUDGET CYCLE. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP THE MOMENTUM
ON ITS PROMISE TO END EACH OUT
POVERTY BY INCREASING CAO WORKS
GRANTS 250% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE. USING AN
ASSISTANCE UNIT PLUS ONE
APPROACH AND TO CONTINUE THE
SUSPENSIONS OF THE LIFETIME
LIMITS BEYOND THE PANDEMIC.
ADDITIONALLY THEM PORN VESTMENTS
AND TE COW WORKS PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT RACIAL
EQUITY IN BIAS TRAINING FOR
COUNTY LEVEL CAO WORKS STAFFERS
ARE VITAL TO CREATING A SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAM THAT IS
TRAUMA INFORMED. AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. LASTLY CALIFORNIA
SHOULD INVESTIGATE STATE
FLEXIBILITIES THAT ALLOW THE
REMOVAL OF HISTORICALLY RACIST
CLASSES IN CFO THE POLICIES IN
THE CALVET PROGRAM. TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM IS CENTERED IN
WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILIES TO
PRODUCE THAT PARTICIPANTS WITH
DIGNITY AND CARE. MEMBERS AND
THE WEALTHY ESTATE AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT SO FAR IT IS A
MORAL AND FISCAL IMPERATIVE THAT
NO FAMILIES OR CHILDREN LIVE IN
DEEP POVERTY. THANK YOU AGAIN.
FOR YOUR TIME AND OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
HEAR FROM JENNIFER. WITH PARA
VOICE CAL. HELLO CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CRAPPIE WITH PARA
PLACES CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE
PARENT LED ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING A DIVERSE GROUP OF
THEM. MY TESTIMONY WILL OFFER TO
EXPERIENCE OF FAMILIES
NAVIGATING THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
. FOR SO MANY PARENTS THE
PROCESS TO APPLY FOR CAL WORKS
IS OVERWHELMING AND BURDENSOME
WHEN FAMILIES ARE IN CRISIS THE
LAST THING THEY NEED IS
ADDITIONAL STRESS AND TRAUMA
FROM THE ONE PLACE. THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO HELP. AS A FORMER
CAL WORKS PARTICIPATE MYSELF. I
KNOW ALL TOO WELL JUST HOW SCARY
IT CAN BE TO WALK THROUGH THE
DOORS OF THE SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCY ASK FOR HELP. WHEN I MADE
THAT JOURNEY ALMOST SEVENTEEN
YEARS AGO I WAS TERRIFIED
GRIEVING AND RECOVERING FROM
UNSPEAKABLE TRAUMA. FILLING OUT
THE APPLICATION GETTING APPROVAL
AND STARTING MY JOURNEY WAS NO
EASY TASK. BUT ONCE I WAS IN I
WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO LEARN ABOUT
A SPECIAL PROGRAM AT MY
ORIENTATION CALLED THE FAMILY
SERVICE TEAM. STARTING THAT DAY
I WAS MET WITH FIVE SOCIAL
WORKERS ALL THERE TO HELP ME
SUCCEED WE WORKED ON MY CHILD
CARE NEEDS MY SCHOOL ENROLLMENT
BY LEGAL CHALLENGES MY HOUSING
CHALLENGES MY MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND HONESTLY MORE
CHALLENGES THAN I CAN EVEN
REMEMBER. THE SERVICES STARTED
ROLLING IN IMMEDIATELY AND EACH
MONTH ALONG THE WAY MY TWO YEAR
JOURNEY WE MET AROUND A TABLE
AND TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
HELP TO SUPPORT ME AND WHAT THEY
COULD DO TO HELP. BECAUSE OF
THAT IN MY HARD WORK I RECEIVED
MY A DEGREE BEGAN WORKING FULL
TIME AND HELD ON TO MY CHILD
CARE UNTIL MY CHILDREN AGED OUT
. MY EXPERIENCE WITH CAL WORKS
DEMONSTRATES THAT THERE IS A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR SOME
PEOPLE. OUR SYSTEM INVOLVES
WRAPPING OUR ARMS AROUND THESE
PARENTS SUPPORTING THEM WITH
THEIR OWN CHALLENGES WHATEVER
THEY MAY BE. THE EXPERIENCE I
HAD WITH CAO WORKS UNFORTUNATELY
IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF THOSE SEEKING
SERVICES TODAY. NOW LET ME SHARE
THE EXPERIENCE OF ONE OF THOSE
FANS. GALLERY STORY REPRESENTS
SO MANY OF THE CHALLENGES
PARENTS FACE WHEN TRYING TO
ACCESS OUR WORK. VALERIE IS A
BLACK ENGLISH SPEAKING MOTHER OF
FOUR HAS A MASTER'S DEGREE AND
AS A- FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDER
. SALARY ALSO SUFFERED FROM
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION AFTER THE
BIRTH OF HER FOURTH CHILD. THE
ISOLATION FROM EPENTHETIC
COUPLED WITH THE POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION SALARY NEEDED SUPPORT
FROM THE SOCIAL SERVICES SAFETY
NET THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
TO HELP PEOPLE IN HER SITUATION
. AND AS A FORMER CAL WORKS
RECIPIENT. VALERIE WAS ALREADY
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE STAGE TO
CHILD CARE SHE NEEDED TO GET
BACK ON HER FEET. HOWEVER SHE
WAS TOLD THAT SHE NEEDED TO
REAPPLY AND ENDED UP WAITING
MONTHS SUBMITTING A MOUNTAIN OF
PAPERWORK AND MAKING COUNTLESS
PHONE CALLS OFTEN TO CENTRAL
PHONE SYSTEMS WERE CALLS WERE
NEVER ANSWERED. AFTER MONTHS
WITH NO REYES RESOLUTION SHE
GAVE UP. VALERIE DIDN'T BAIL THE
SYSTEM DID. THIS IS NOT THE
SYSTEM THAT WE NEED. THIS IS THE
SYSTEM WE WALKED. BUT THIS IS A
SYSTEM THAT IS FAILING FAR TOO
MANY FAMILIES. WE HAVE TO FACE
THE FACT THAT THERE IS RACISM IN
THE SYSTEM. I CANNOT IGNORE THAT
MY EXPERIENCE AS A WHITE MOTHER.
WAS SO DIFFERENT FROM VALERIE'S
AS A BLACK MAN. MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS TODAY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A METAL DETECTOR. AND THE FIRST
PERSON THAT THEY SEE AND COME IN
CONTACT WITH IS A SECURITY GUARD
. MY FIRST CONTACT WAS WITH A
SOCIAL WORKER READY TO HELP. LET
ME LOOK AT HOW OUR PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR STRUCTURE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WITH THE MOST
CHALLENGES WHEN IT ENGLISH
SPEAKING MASTER DEGREE HOLDEN
MOM WHO IS A MEMBER OF AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND SITS
ON A VARIETY OF POLICY COUNCIL.
CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT. NEARLY THE
SYSTEM IS FAILING WHEN WE MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PARENTS WE MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL
PARENTS. AND THAT MAKE ISN'T. TO
REBUILD AND RE CREATE SYSTEMS
THAT ACTUALLY WORK FOR FAMILIES
BUT IN ORDER TO DO THAT IT HAS
TO BE DRIVEN BY THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. RECENTLY WE WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ENGAGE FAMILIES
AROUND IMPROVING THE CAL WORKS
AND CHILD CARE SYSTEMS TO THE
CREATION OF A PARENT ADVISORY.
IF CONDUCTED FOCUS GROUPS WITH
BLACK FAMILIES CHINESE AND
SPANISH SPEAKING FAMILIES AND
TRIBAL. WE WILL SHARE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LADY UP AS
SOON AS THEY'RE READY IMPROVING
THE SYSTEM CANNOT WORK WITHOUT
CENTERING THE VOICES THAT HAVE
BEEN IGNORED FOR FAR TOO LONG.
CAREFULLY SAYS IS READY TO
PARTNER WITH ANYONE WHO AGREE.
AND I DO HAVE A LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME
DIRECTLY FROM HOW WORKS
PARTICIPANTS THAT I WILL BE
SENDING TO THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
AFTER THIS HEARING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT INFORMATION NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM MIKE HERALD WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. PEOPLE. HE SAID. WHERE
I AM ABLE HEAR YOU MIGHT IF-
YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE ABOUT NOW
CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS YEAR WE
HEAR YOU ALLOW AND CLEAR GO
AHEAD. VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR
ALERTING ME- SEASONAL I'M SAYING
- WE ARE EXTREME EXCITED TO HEAR
. THE SPEECH IS THAT WHEN YOU
SELECT COMMITTEE ON POVERTY.
FUNDING WHILE THIS CAN BE HAS
DONE- GREAT. OVER YEARS AND
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE. I HIGHER.
YOUR THE ISSUE IS. AND WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD. TO PROTECT. WITH
THE- INNOCENT APPLE- I'VE BEEN
OUT TO ANSWER- SOME. TO BEFORE I
DO THAT I JUST WANT TO SAY. THAT
WE WILL WANT TO SAY. ARE ALSO
WITH THE- OF. THE STAFF CAN. AND
MUST- HAVE WORKED WITH THE TO
WORK. FOR SOMETIME NOW. AND WE
SHARE COMMON CONCERN AND IS AND
FIRST. ON HOURS PROGRAM ON THE
ISSUE OF POP MONTROSE AND CAL-
AND WE THINK THERE'S- THAT CAN
BE DONE- TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
MAKE THINK SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY OUTLINE. IN THEIR ARE
MORE ARE THINGS THAT THE
COMMITTEE. SAID TAKE A VERY LOOK
AT. I WANT TO DRESS OF THE THAT
YOU CAN EARLY IN YOUR CASE IN
YOUR QUESTION FROM PARK. MISTER
CHAIR. AND THAT WAS- ABOUT THE
SITE. ABOUT IT SOME APPLIES FOR
SAY THE MEDICAL PROGRAM. SHOULD
WE NOT BE REFERRED THEM WATER.
TO OTHER. THAT IF YOU'RE THAT
THEY WERE BE IN. TO FOR OF THE
LIGHT BULBS BUT WORK. I THINK
THIS IS THE ISN'T POSTED OVER-
AND I THINK- SEE THIS- BUT SHE-
OF ARC. APPROACH IN THE NUMBER
OF- OKAY JUST RATES BY MINUTES
FOR EXAMPLE ON. THIS PLEDGE. AND
MANY GOVERNOR HAVE WORKED. TO
MEDIC. OF RATE. I'M MORE OF.
RECENT YEARS ESPECIALLY WITH THE
EXPANSION OF CALPERS STUDENT. AT
THE SITE WHICH BAND. AND BUT
WHEN WE COME TO CAL WORKS. I
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
RECENT DATA FROM EIGHTY UP ON
THIS ISSUE- BUT THE- PUT THERE'S
REASON TO THINK THAT ARE THAT
ARE PERFORMANCE ISSUES DROPPING
. WE WERE. ADELINE 6% OF THE- OF
THE- OF THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE- AND WE WANT TO
TALK STATES IN THE COUNTRY AND
THAT WE'VE MAINTAINED OUR OUR
PERSPIRATION RATE STRONGLY. BUT
WITH THIS RECENT DROP IN THE
CASE OF THE WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. WE HAVE
REASON TO THINK ABOUT NUMBERS
NOW DROP. PUBLISHED BELOW 50%
THE AMERICAN AREA THAT WE THINK
THE WORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE BE
THANK A VERY STRONG LOOK AT I
THINK THIS IDEA OF AN SO CALLED
NO WAY POLICY FOR GETTING PEOPLE
IN THE TOWERS IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE OUGHT TO BE THINKING
SERIOUSLY ABOUT DOING. BUT
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE COULD BE DOING THAT- TO
ADDRESS OTHER BARRIERS TO
GETTING ON TO CHALLENGE THAT I'M
MORE PREFIX SIMPLY BY HAVING YOU
KNOW ONE MORE POLICY SO YOU'VE
HEARD ME SAY SOME OF THESE
BEFORE BUT I WILL TAKE THEIR
REPEATED I BELIEVE SOME WE
SHOULD A WOMAN THE CALLED THE IN
THE FACT THAT THE MEN WILL BE
STANDARDS ADEQUATE. WHICH IS A-
ALL MEDICATIONS HOW MUCH INCOME
PEOPLE CAN HAPPEN A FIVE FOR THE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY A FAMILY CAN
ONLY MAKE A FAMILY 310-005-0030
NINE DOLLARS A MONTH IN ORDER TO
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM
THAT'S ABOUT 80% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL RIGHT. NOW SO
WE'RE LEAVING. SIGNIFICANT NOT
OF PEOPLE IN POVERTY UNABLE TO
ACT IS FOR. BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
ARE. AMONGST WE GET RID OF THE
OF A CATS. ON THEIR A BILL ON
THE LINE. NOW TO DO THAT ON THE
TABLE. OF ONE HUNDRED HOUR WAR.
KNOWN AGAIN THIS IS A THIS IS
JUST A ARTIST BARRIER THAT WE
CREATED. THAT MAKES IT REALLY
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO GET ON OUR
PROGRAM- IT AT. WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT- ALL MOVING AWAY
AS FROM WORK REQUIREMENTS AND
RICHARD REPORTING REQUIREMENTS-
MAYOR TOM JOHNSON EARLIER THAT
THIS MIGHT SOUND A LITTLE
RADICAL- WE DON'T THINK IT'S
REALLY THAT RADICAL AT ALL- WE
THINK THAT THE DAYS WHERE WE
HAVE THE ONE THAT'S VERY STRICT
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM IS JUST NOT-
IT COMPORTS WITH THE REALITY OF
CURRENT LIGHT PEOPLE HAVE MANY
OPTIONS THEY DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE
PEOPLE CAN GET A DRY A JOB-
DELIVERED COMMUTER WORKING FOR
UBER THEY CAN MAKE MONEY THEY
DON'T NEED TO JUMP THROUGH ALL
THESE HOOPS THAT WE CREATED AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THAT MAKE IT SO
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO STAY ON THE
BOOKS AND- PEOPLE. ARE WILLING
TO DO THAT AS MUCH ANYMORE THE
WORK REQUIREMENT COMMITTEE AND
STRICT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ARE ARE I THINK A MAJOR BARRIER
PEOPLE JUST AREN'T WILLING TO
DEAL WITH ALL THIS ANYMORE- BUT
ADDITIONALLY- ALL. WE ALSO THINK
THAT WE TO GET RID OF SOME OF
THE VERY. WORK IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DATA ABOUT THE RE WHY T. ARE
DOING HER EIGHT- SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE MONTH THERE. A WATER
SO PROCEDURAL THE NILE. B. FOR
WILL YOU SPELL IN THE THAT ONE
TALK TO. ABOUT WHAT MEANS. IT
MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE. GAVE UP
DURING PLAYOFFS. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO PROVIDE SOME OF YOUR
PARKING AND FOR AND DATA ABOUT
PAP COMPLY. OF THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT YOU SIMPLY
DIDN'T WORKING HAVE A CLUE TO
TRACK DOWN THE PEOPLE INTO WALK
WITH THEIR- DROPPED OUT DON'T.
TO THAT WE SHOULD BE MORE INTO
LAW OF THESE VERIFICATION
REQUIRED. AND STREAMED AND
REALLY CUTTING THE BACK TO IS
GOING TRUE NOTHING. SO WHAT
HAPPENED I WILL JUST MEANT USE
THAT THAT- IS UP THERE WITH
THERE ARE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WE CAN BEGIN ALSO TO MAKE. SO
FOR ALL BETTER NOW BUT WE'VE
WORKED WITH THE PASCO TRYING TO
SPEND OUT SEVERAL OF THE-
RELAXING. OF BOYS THAT BIG.
ORDER AND FOR TWENTY GOVERNMENT
. WATER PROVIDE. THAT HELLO MY
NAME SANCTIONS FOR. PROVIDED
BLANCA GOOD CALL YOU'RE- IN THE
PROBE. REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
TIMES OF PEOPLE TO MAKE OFF WITH
THE KEEPING DOWN TO THE WILD
OFFICE- THANKFULLY LAST MUCH.
DOOR ELECTRIC SIGNATURES AND
THAT PERHAPS THAT WAS OF THE-
AND WE SHOULD BE LOOKING MORE
THINGS LIKE THAT TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM WORK THAT. THE PEOPLE
GET THE FULL BENEFIT BUT THE
NEED. A NEW ONE AFTER EVERY JUST
SAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN BE GET SCHOOL. THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW FAMILY. AND FAMILIES.
AND HER FAMILY COULD TRYING TO
OFFICE SYSTEM. PETER ARTICLE
BERRY WE CAN A LET ME THEM
PROVIDE THE ONLY THING THAT. AND
WE SHOULD DO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THAT OUR
PROGRAMS- AND THE RULES THAT ARE
PROGRAMS CAN PLAY. IN HELPING
TO- I IMPROVE AND REDUCE
POVERTY- LET'S SEE LET ME GET MY
NOTE- OVER HERE TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW- CONTINUE ON- WE WILL
HAVE TERRORISTS. AND THINK
ABOUT- WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE
GROUND AND I WANT TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT ALSO KIND OF PIGGY BACK I
THINK ON SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHER CHANNELS
. FIRST AS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
ARE SO UP IN BOTH. AND THEN TAKE
THE- AS A RESULT OF THIS
APPLICATION. I THINK- AND
LOOKING AT THE DATA WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THESE BONDS THAN VOLUME.
BEGINNING IT AT THAT YOU KNOW
VERY BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
WE ALSO SAW THE PHONES AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH OF
COURSE- THAT- CDSS
REPRESENTATIVE MENTIONED WAS
WHAT AND- THE U. Y. EXTENSION
THE BOMBS FOR A- TO TEMPORARILY
LAPSED. IN THE STATE- WORKED
WITH EDT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE KNEW THAT THEY HAD OTHER
PLACES TO GO. WE THOUGHT VERY
QUICK BONTA N. OUR CASELOAD- OUR
OUR APPLICATIONS A RESULT OF
THAT. AND THEN AGAIN A MUCH
LARGER INCREASE AT THE- END OF
THE YEAR Y. EXTENSIONS AND
INCREASES THAT HAPPENED. NEAR
THE END OF LAST YEAR WE IN FACT
WENT FROM AN AVERAGE OF AROUND
EIGHT THOUSAND APPLICATIONS PER
WEEK. AT THE BEGINNING A LITTLE
BIT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WHICH
HAD BEEN DECREASING AS MR HURLED
NOTED. TO AN AVERAGE OF AROUND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOR A WEEK AT
THE TIME THAT YOU AYE LAPSED- AT
THE END OF I'M TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- YOU WHY IN PARTICULAR HAS
BEEN A DRIVER I THINK TO KEEP.
THE APPLICATION AND CAPABLE BUT
LOWER. DURING MUCH OF THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THE U. Y. WAS.
INCREASED SO MUCH OF EXTENDED
FOR SO LONG. THAT FAMILIES WERE
. AN ELIGIBLE. FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT COUNTIES RUNNING. HOW SO
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL TO SEE. A
UPTICK IN THE CASESONE THAT WAS. IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK TO
UNDER. THAT- STATES LARGELY LEFT
TO THE TERM OF THE OWN. FOR
ALLEGED AND GRANT WHILE. IN THE
CAL WORKS OR NATIONAL THAT AFTER
ONE OF CALLED. AND HELLO. SIR
THE- PERCENTAGE OF THE- WHO ARE
I PART IF ANY STATE OTHER THAN
VERMONT. FOR EVERYONE HUNDRED
FAMILY WHO LIVE IN POVERTY HELLO
. AT SERVES THAT ONE OF THE
FAMILIES ARE PROGRAM. AND IN
FACT. STATE SERVICE. ONE IN TEN
. OF THE FAILED AND- ADVERSITY
AND STUFF. I IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER TO THE- DIED SHE THE
MIGHT MAY. IN OUR- AND SOME OF
THEM WERE MENTIONED THE SCRAP
INVESTOR HERALD. THINGS SUCH AS
- STREAMLINING FRONT END IN SOME
OF THE ARE CHANGE THAT WE'VE TO
SOME TO GET WITH YOUR- MISTER
CHAIR AN- THAT INDIVIDUALS TO
GET ON- THROUGH. INCREASED THEIR
ACT- INCOME DISREGARD AND THAT
STATE ON THE PROGRAM WE THEY DO
BECAUSE TO WORK IN IN. THEIR WAY
. BY INCREASING THE STEP IN-
GIVE ARE. THOSE CHOICES THAT
HELP CAN HIM SO WE CAN CAN. TO
MAKE SOME OF THE ADDITION CHANGE
. THAT OR- THAT MR AND- WHICH
ALSO THINK WE THINK ABOUT
SOMEBODY OVER OR- THAT ARE
CURRENT SOME THAT FAMILIES HAVE
FILL IN. EVERY SIX. AND IF THEY
THAT THEY IN THE CAN BE THE
FIFTEEN FROM THE PRO- WE'RE- OF
WHAT IT'S A AREN'T. IT'S MORE OF
A THIS PAPERWORK FOR. SIMILAR TO
THE VERY. REQUIRED. TO FIND TO
THE LONGER REQUIRE THOSE. ONE OF
THE THING I THINK WE WANT TO
ABOUT THAT IS THAT THERE ARE A
PRO THAT OF OUR- ARE L. FOR.
CALFRESH AND CAL AND THOSE DO
YOU HAVE YOU GET VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS SO WANT TO ABOUT.
ARE WE ABLE TO MAKE. IN THOSE
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY HEALTH
RIGHTS WHICH HAS BEEN PRETTY
STRINGENT FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
AND I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT ON THE CALFRESH PANEL
IN A WHILE SOME IDEAS THAT WE
HAVE- THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE WORK GROUP TO
THINK ABOUT. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
SOME FEDERAL CHANGES IN THE
CALFRESH PROGRAM HEALTHWORKS WE
COULD MAKE THOSE CHANGES. AND
THEN WE'D BE OPERATING TWO
DIFFERENT SETS OF RULES AND WE
JUST HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITIES THAT THAT MIGHT
INTRODUCED FOR FAMILIES. OR FOR
OUR WORKERS. HISTORICALLY I
THINK OF THIS BOILS DOWN TO OUR
PRO. IS PRETTY TOGETHER HALF-
BEFORE THE NIGHT NINETIES- ONE
REFORM STAFF. WERE ENACTED THE
THING EVEN. YOU KNOW IT WOULD
NOW THAT WE GOT POWER. WITH A
STARK HAD A VERY. OR SISTER. AND
WE KNOW THAT THAT IS. IN CLASSES
FACT THIS AND RACIST- RULES OF-
YOU KNOW COUNTY THE NUMBER OF.
IN THE- AND- VIEWING PARENTS WHO
LIVING POVERTY AS SOME. I'M NOT
ABLE TO CARE FOR THEIR- THESE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE ECHOES FACT
YOU SEE. OUR AND I HELLO WE BEEN
A TO MAKE THE- STRIDES. THERE'S
MORE TO IT MORNING. AS WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO. AGAIN YOUR
STUFF. ON AS WELL. THAT AND HAVE
A KID. TO REALLY BUILD OUT AND
THINK ABOUT HOW TO EMPLOY. THE
TYPE OF TRAINING. AND
INITIATIVES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
LAST YEAR AND THAT ARE NOW UNDER
WAY AS. WE THINK ABOUT CHANGES
TO THE PROGRAM. ON THE OTHER
QUESTION I WOULD ASK TO ADDRESS
IS- RELATED TO THE HI- AND I
KNOW- THE- RECORD. TALK TO
BENEFIT AND WHY WILL BE THE
RESULT OF THAT ELIGIBLE HOPPER.
KIND OF IT KIND THE PAST. WE DO
ON. HOW THESE MINUTES.
TECHNICALLY CALCULATED THE
AMOUNT OF THE COPPER THE HOME
SIXTEEN DOLLAR- ABOUT NINE. OF
OUR- CURRENT ELIGIBILITY
OPERATIONS BUDGET. THAT PROPOSED
CUT IS SO SIGNIFICANT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN CASES. IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE AND WE DON'T THINK
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT.
OF THE METHODOLOGY THAT WE RATE
WE DID JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO WHAT THE STATE WAS TOTALLY
EITHER NARROW THE SWINGS.
BETWEEN UP TURNS AND DOWNTURNS
AND IN CASELOADS AND THE ECONOMY
WHAT WE WERE SAYING IS THAT
COUNTIES WERE GETTING. VERY
LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY WHEN THE
ECONOMY WAS GOING DOWN AND.
CASELOADS WERE- WE'RE GOING- BUT
STILL WE WERE CAN THAT ON SO THE
IDEA WAS TO OF NAY THAT KIND OF-
YOU KNOW KIND OF MINIMIZE THE
SWINGS AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
THINK AND NINE PERCENT. CUT OF
THAT MAGNITUDE AND WHAT IT TAKES
OF THIS GOING UP IS JUST-
CERTAINLY NOT MINIMIZING THE
SWING I GUESS I'D SAY- THE
EFFECTS OF SUCH A CUT IS THAT
COUNTY. HOW TO KEEP THE DOOR
OPEN YEAH WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
EXTRA ACCEPT AND PROCESS
APPLICATIONS THAT'S EXTREMELY
CRITICAL AND AS YOU HEARD WHEN
THAT BREAKS DOWN AND PEOPLE
DON'T GET THEIR BENEFITS. IT
LEADS TO MORE HUNGER MORE
HOMELESSNESS AND JUST GREATER
POVERTY AND GREATER INEQUALITY-
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE BUDGET
INCLUDED A LOT OF NEW RESOURCES
FOR INCREASED CASE MANAGEMENT.
FOR FAMILIES WHO HAVE MORE
COMPLEX SITUATIONS AND TO HELP
US REALLY START TO MOVE TOWARD
THE CAL WORKS TWO POINT OH
PRINCIPLES THE FEW WTA HOPE TO
DEVELOP AND CHAMPION- OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SHIFTED.
AWAY FROM EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
AND FOR ITS ELIGIBILITY
OPERATIONS EVEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR COUNTY OVERSPEND OUR
ELIGIBILITY BUDGET BY ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS I THINK
IT WAS ABOUT A 103% OF THAT
AMOUNT SO 3% OR ABOUT EIGHTEEN.
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE SHIFTED
THAT PROBLEM EITHER CHILD CARE
OR EMPLOYMENT SERVICES DEPENDING
ON THE COUNTY. NOW THE CHILD
CARE IS NO LONGER IN THAT SINGLE
APPLICATION AND TO WHERE THAT
MONEY'S GOING TO COME FROM THE
FROM PLANET SERVICES AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED. WHEN YOU PUT THAT
MONEY AND IT'S NOT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDED LAST
YEAR WITH THAT BUDGET WITH FINE
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT WHAT WE
WANT TO DO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. AND
PROVIDE THAT EXCELLENT SERVICE
BUT- IF WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN BE FOUND
ELIGIBLE IF THEY NEED THESE
BENEFITS THAT'S WHAT COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO. AND IT
JUST- IT JUST MAKES THE WHOLE
PROGRAM OPERATE LESS EFFECTIVELY
IF WE'RE SHIFTING FUNDS. AROUND
WE THINK THE FUNDING SHOULD BE
AFTER AND- STEP THAT BEAT THAT.
HAPPY TO HEAR ANY. THANK YOU
MUCH WITH I WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DRIVE TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBER OF. SEEN NINE. KEEP IT
HERE AT THE- I WILL BY ECHOING
WHAT JENNA GRATZ SAID ABOUT THE
NEED FOR US TO OUR ARMS AROUND
THE PARENTS WHO ARE. BEING BRAVE
ENOUGH AND SECURE ENOUGH TO ASK
FOR HELP. INSTEAD OF FORCING
THEM TO WAIT MONTHS ON A
CENTRALIZED PHONE SYSTEM. I
WOULD AGREE WITH THE CONCLUSION
THAT IT WAS NOT VALERIE WHO
FAILED BUT THE SYSTEM ITSELF
THAT NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED. AND
SO WILL LOOK TOWARDS MANY OF
THESE COMPLIANCE ORIENTED
SYSTEMS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
TROUBLED BY THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE CURRENT UP TO. THE
DAY UP TO THE MINUTE ATA ON
TAKE A BREAK. AND SO I KIND OF
WANT TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION IF I CAN AS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE L. E. O.
CAME OUT WITH INFORMATION IN
FEBRUARY OF. TWENTY ONE AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE-
FURTHER INFORMATION UNTIL EARLY
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE THEY'RE
REALLY CREATES A GAP IN DATA FOR
US RIGHT. NOW AT WHAT IS AN
INFLECTION POINT. WHAT WAS
REFERENCE WITHIN THE AGENDA WAS
THE U. Y. WHICH RELAPSED ON
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR WAS THAT
INFLECTION POINTS THAT I'M-
REALLY WANTING TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WE CAN.
MAKE SURE WE ARE COLLECTING THAT
DATA GOING FORWARD SO WE CAN
MAKE APPROPRIATE RESPONSES IN
REAL TIME AND HOPING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. CAN COMMENT ON
THAT BECAUSE WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THE ALLEY- WAS A SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASED AMOUNT OF CASES PER
MONTH VERSUS WHAT WAS PREDICTED.
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION FOR US AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE AS WE WERE
MAKING BUDGET DECISIONS THIS
YEAR. AND I'M WONDERING WHY THAT
INFORMATION. IS NOT MORE READILY
AVAILABLE TO US. THANK YOU KAREN
I CAN GET STARTED ON THE
RESPONSE TO THIS QUESTION SO IN
TERMS OF THE TAKE UP WITH THE L.
A. ANALYSIS RELIED HEAVILY ON
THE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU DATA. AT
THAT IS THE DATA WERE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A SIGNIFICANT WAGON
UPDATED INFORMATION DUE TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
THE ABILITY TO COLLECT A CENSUS
LEVEL DATA. WE DO HAVE SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS AND
OTHER DATA AVAILABLE TRUST THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WERE- WORKING TO
EXPLORE WE DO NOT HAVE A DEEP
JUST YET ON WHEN WE CAN. PRODUCE
THAT ANALYSIS BUT GIVEN SOME OF
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD
TODAY TODAY. HAPPY TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK A AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS THAT FOLKS WANT
TO SEE IS THAT- ANALYSIS AT THE
DATA IS AVAILABLE. I THINK THE
OTHER PIECE ON A TAKE THAT TAKE
UP RATE AT THE SIXTY. RATE-
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE FOLKS OF
CRAPPIE IS FOLKS EXPERIENCE.
BENEFIT CLAPPED WELL ABOUT FOUR
MILLION. CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IN SEPTEMBER
AND THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
TRICKLE THE FACTOR. FOR WIND.
ANY TIME AND WHEN FOLKS ACTUALLY
LOST CERTAIN AND BENEFITS. SO
WHILE FOLKS STARTED TO ABOUT AND
TO LATE. THAT MAY NOT HAVE
IMPROPER SOME. SOME FAMILY INTO
A- NO TWO DEPENDING ON A RECEIPT
OF BENEFITS- IN SO. WE DO NOT
HAVE A- ED THAT THE KEY SLOW
DATA. I'M THE WHAT TURNED IN
FROM WHAT TURNED FROM AN APPLE
CANNOT EASE UP THE LATER MONTHS
OF YEAR THE NEW ABOUT A MONTH
LAG IN KEY DATE AND SO WE HOPE
TO HAVE THAT I AT READY TO. YOUR
SOON. IT I WOULD COST. MAKE SURE
WE ARE LOOK AT THE- SCOPE WE ARE
TALK ABOUT MILLION OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO. LOST
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWO THOUSAND.
PEOPLE PER MONTH TWO. NOW ARE
BEING ENROLLED INTO CAL WORKS
AND I'M STILL WONDERING. WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S ANOTHER METRIC WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT RATHER
THAN- US CENSUS INFORMATION
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A STATE
RUN METRIC THAT WE MAY WANT TO
BE LOOKING OUT AND TRACKING AS
WELL. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THIS
INFORMATION IN REAL TIME IN THE
MIDST OF. THIS PANDEMIC OF THE
CENTURY WOULD HAVE BEEN HELPFUL
TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
MAXIMIZING AS MANY FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE BENEFITS. THAT I'D I'D
LIKE TO JUST FOLLOW UP AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION. I'D I'D LIKE
TO THE TRANSITION AND I WILL
PULL AND WHAT A DATA POINT FROM
THE ENDING POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE SAW THAT.
PIANOS DISPROPORTIONATELY WERE
IN POVERTY COMPARED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THAT I'D LIKE TO
GET INTO A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
USE SIZE AND THE EXCLUSION OF
ARE UNDOCUMENTED. POPULATION AS
I BELIEVE THAT MAYBE. GETTING TO
THAT. OF POVERTY RATE THAT WE'RE
WE LEARNED FROM THE FIRST PANEL
THE IMPORTANCE FOR US TO.
SUPPORT OVERLOOKED POPULATIONS
THAT I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND FROM
THE- AND- WHETHER THIS IS A
TOPIC OF CONVERSATION WE- CAN
BEGIN TO HAVE AS I THINK IT WILL
BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO ADDRESS.
THE COMPLEXITIES THAT MANY OF
OUR FAMILIES ARE FACING IN OUR
STATE. SO IN REQUEST THE DATA ON
THE IMPACT OF UNDOCUMENTED- AT
THAT POINT OUT THINGS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING POVERTY I KNOW IT
CAN HI I DIRECTOR JOHNSON HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE
PRESIDENT THAT WHILE CAO WORKS
DOES HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SERVE
CHILD ONLY CASES. THAT INCLUDES
FAMILIES THAT HAVE MIXED STATUS
WE CAN- TAKE THAT QUESTION BACK
TO EXPLORE WHAT DATA WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AND TO SEE IF WE CAN
USE THAT TO ALSO INFORM THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE MENTIONED
EARLIER AROUND PROGRAM REACH.
BUT I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE AGAIN
IF THE PARENTSWERE COUNTED INTO
THE A YOU SIZE THEY WOULD
RECEIVE A LARGER BENEFIT. THUS
ALLOWING US TO ADDRESS THE
POVERTY FR MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES. AND BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO COUNT ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
FAMILIES WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND- WOULD
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FOLLOW
UP. ON THAT CONVERSATION AS WE
GO FORWARD. THERE WILL BE MUCH
MORE FOR US TO AS WE GET INTO
ISSUES FIVE LATER ON TODAY BUT I
DO HAVE A FEW REQUESTS FROM THE
CHAIR. BEFORE WE MOVE ON FROM
TODAY. AND THERE ARE A SERIES OF
REQUESTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
WITHIN THE AGENDA THAT I WANT TO
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. OF
THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY LISTED ON PAGE TWENTY
FOUR. I'D LIKE TO KINDLY ASK DSS
TO PLEASE PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST THE ESTIMATES TO BRING ALL
GRANTS FROM DEEP POVERTY FOR IN
A U. PLUS ONE UP TO FIFTY
PERCENT. SECOND THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKE UP RATES FOR
CAL WORK SO THAT WE CAN TRACK
THIS OVER TIME AS A STATE
GOVERNMENT. THIRD TO REPORT BACK
FROM DSS AT FUTURE HEARINGS ON
THESE REQUESTS AND ON THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIEDWITHIN THIS AGENDA.
AND FINALLY THE ANALYSIS
REGARDING THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
REDUCTION FOR ELIGIBILITY
SERVICES. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE WORK WITH MY SUB
COMMITTEE ON MY STAFF TO ENSURE
THE RESPONSIVENESS TO THESE
REQUESTS. AND QUESTIONS AND DO
WANNA SAY THANK YOU IN ADVANCE
BUT MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE
WILLING AND AMENABLE TO
ANSWERING THOSE QUESTIONS GOING
FORWARD. DEPARTMENT. YESTERDAY I
JUST WOULD ALSO LIKE TO FLAG I
THINK YOU CHAIR FOR THAT FOR
THAT QUESTION WE WERE ABLE TO
CONDUCT AN INITIAL ANALYSIS OF
THE COST OF THE AT BEING ABLE TO
BRING A CALL WORKS FAMILIES AND
THAT EIGHT YOU PLUS ONE CATEGORY
UP 23% OF THE F. P. AND BASED ON
THE INITIAL PRODUCTION
CONSIDERING THAT THE SEVEN POINT
1% INCREASE PROPOSAL DOES MOVE
ONE BILLION- AND SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT ADJUSTMENT TO BRING-
ALL THAT THAT YOU THAT THE
FAMILIES PLUS ONE. UP 250% NPL
THRESHOLD. FOR THE OTHER GROUP.
AS A MAN WE ARE WERE INTO TO IN
A RIGHT NOW THIS IS BASED ON OF
A CRITERIA SHARED AS WELL AS
SOME OTHER FEEDBACK- AND WE- SO
MORE TO COME ON THE- ANALYST.
AROUND UP RIGHT. WE WILL NOW
TURN TO ASSEMBLY RUBIO FOR QUEST
. NO IT JUST THE AND TERMS OF A
LINE DO YOU HAVE A FRAME AS TO A
WE CAN GET SIM FROM. TO CLARIFY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO THE DATA
ANALYSIS HE SAYS THAT IT WILL
PICK UP THE PIECES THAT WE JUST
THAT AND WHY WAS WOULD LIKE
CLARIFICATION BUT- THE CHAIR ASK
YOU KNOW FOR ALL THESE QUESTIONS
TO BE ANSWERED AND I. YOU KNOW I
NEED A SPECIFIC TIMELINE SO THAT
I KNOW- WENT TO- YOU KNOW ASK
AGAIN- JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
ON THIS. WHICH FOR THE DAY TO
TAKE A BREAK DATA NOW. I'M DO
NOT A TIMELINE WHERE WE ARE
WORKING IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR INTERNAL RESEARCH
AUTOMATION AND DATA PARTNERS- TO
WORK ON THAT ANALYSIS. A NOW ONE
IN FIVE BY. UP FOR THE DATA AND
INFORMATION AROUND THE COST
ANALYSIS OF BRINGING FAMILIES UP
250% OF THE FPL THAT IS ALREADY
BEEN COMPLETED AND PROVIDED SO
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION. AND
THEN FOR THE ANALYSIS ON THE-
MUNDINE. FOR THE YEAR I'M
ALLOCATION THAT GOES OUT TO
COUNTY IS ON THE ELIGIBILITY.
ADMINISTRATION BUT IT'S ALSO
BEEN COMPLETED AND WE'LL MAKE
SURE THE ACCESS THAT INFORMATION
AS WELL. THANK YOU AND WHEN YOU
MEAN OUR FOLKS HAVE ACCESS WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IS IT ON A-
WEBSITE SOMEWHERE ARE YOU GOING
TO SEND US THE INFORMATION
DIRECTLY. WE WILL. SEND THE
INFORMATION TO YOU DIRECTLY
THANK YOU. WITHOUT AYE- AS WE
ARE CLOSING ISSUE TOO WIDE I DO
WANT TO DRAW A PARALLEL TO ISSUE
ONE WHERE WE SPOKE ABOUT MANY OF
THE INSTITUTIONS WHICH- CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THE POVERTY THAT
WE HAVE DOWNSTREAM. AND THE
ABILITY FOR US TO PREVENT AND
GET UPSTREAM AYE I BELIEVE THAT
CAL WORKS IS EXACTLY ONE OF
THOSE PROGRAMS THEREFORE ABLE TO
IMPROVE AND- BETTER INCREASE
ACCESS WERE SIMILARLY ABLE TO
THEN PREVENT MANY PEOPLE FROM
ENTERING INTO POVERTY. AND THUS
CREATING BETTER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM GOING FORWARD I BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO GET THIS DONE RIGHT WHILE
LISTENING TO THOSE WHO ARE USING
THE SYSTEMS AND THE STRUGGLES
THERE HAVE IN ACCESSING THE
PROGRAMS. I THINK THERE'S A LOTS
OF IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS THE YEAR
PROGRESSES. WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE TO OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE THREE PER CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND AN OVERSIGHT OVER
THE KEY PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS I'D
LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH THE
PANELISTS FOR ISSUE TO AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE.
WE WILL HAVE THREE EXCUSE ME
EIGHT PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
WE WILL BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
DAVID KILGOUR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. FOLLOWED BY
KRISTEN DONNA D. CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CHILD
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. BY FOLLOWED
JALIL BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE JACQUI BUT OSSEO WITH
L. A. L. MIKE HERALD WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER. ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE SERVER FLORI
PARENTS LEADER WITH STUDENTS
PARENTS WHO ARE REIMAGINING CAL
WORKS. FOLLOWED BY KAREN ROY
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SHARON MARDALE TRAY
HO DIRECTOR OF THE MERCED
MARIPOSA REGIONAL DEPARTMENT. OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES DIRECTOR
KILGORE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND SEVEN MEMBERS I
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM IN SOME OF THE
ADVANCEMENTS THAT ARE OCCURRING
IN OUR SYSTEMS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND THIS IS A
CONTINUATION AND I'M PLAN-
PLEASED TO BRING THIS IN FRONT
OF YOU OF A SERIES OF EFFORTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN MOVING TOWARDS
TO PRIORITIZE FAMILIES- AND THE
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM THE
COLLECTIONS WE RECEIVED AN
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE GOT THE FAMILIES FIRST
BEFORE. ANY GOVERNMENT- DEBT
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE HERE-
COMES AFTER A CHANGE TO OUR
DEFICIT REDUCTION ACT
DISTRIBUTION POLICIES WHICH
PRIORITIZES FAMILIES FIRST SO
RESOURCES COMING IN FROM THE IRS
AND OTHERS LIKE THAT GO TO
FAMILY DEBT FOR IT AND- I RECOUP
GOVERNMENT AFTERWARDS. WITHIN
WORKED WITH DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES TO INCREASE THE PASSED
THROUGH FOR FIFTY DOLLARS TO ONE
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT
TOOK EFFECT JANUARY FIRST. WE'VE
GOT NOW ONE MONTH UNDER OUR BELT
TO START TO EXPLORE AND ANALYZE
THE RESULTS OF THAT IMPACT THIS
PIECE BEFORE YOU TODAY IS ABOUT
PASSING THROUGH- ALL THE
COLLECTIONS RECEIVE UP FORMALLY
ASSISTED CASES- IT COMES WITH AN
IMPACT TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OF ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS- BUT- OF A-
LITTLE LESS THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THE IMPACT
OF THE FAMILIES IS AN INCREASE
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GOING OUT.
FAMILIES IN IT DIDN'T IT RESULTS
IN ALL COLLECTIONS THAT ARE
RECEIVED ON PAST DUE CHILD
SUPPORT PASSING TO THE FAMILY'S
IN WE WOULD. NO LONGER CLICK
THAT AND CURRENT SUPPORT. ONE OF
THE- IN HERE ABOUT WHY THE
MINISTRY CHOSE TO ONLY- PAST-
MAY THIS CHANGE THE FORMALLY. IT
AND ARE SEVERAL. OF INTO THAT.
WE HAD A PRETTY. CONVERSE OF
CALL. ONE THIS. THAT MOVED
FORWARD PASSING THROUGH-
COLLECTIONS ON CURRENT SUPPORT
CASES CASES WITH AN OBLIGATION
DURING THE CURRENT MONTH- AND
THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS AND
THEY ARE PASSING THAT THROUGH
THEIR SEEING GREAT RESULTS FROM
THAT. WHAT THEY DIDN'T DO IS
PASSED THROUGH THE FORMALLY
ASSISTED SIDE OF THE HOUSE SO
THAT THEY- THAT THE CHILD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CURRENT
MONTH. IT ROLLS OVER BECOMES
ARREARS A PAST DUE CHILD SUPPORT
WHEN THAT IS COLLECTED ITS
RECOUP TO RETAIN IN ITS ENTIRETY
TO THE GOVERNMENT- IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM THEY'VE
SUGGESTED THAT HAVING TO DO IT
OVER AGAIN. THEY WOULD HAVE
STARTED WITH THE REAR. OF THE
HOUSE AND. THEN MOVED TO CURRENT
SUPPORT AFTERWARDS. SECONDLY A
WE HAVE. TO OUR FEDERAL. SO ON
THE PASTOR AND DISREGARD. AND
ONE HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
ON CURRENT SUPPORT IS THE
FEDERAL MAXIMUMS AT THIS POINT
IN TIME. IF WE WERE TO GO ABOVE
THAT. WE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOLE FOR ANY
SORT OF PASSED THROUGH-
RECRUITMENT THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
RETAINED BUT DIDN'T. IN IN FAVOR
OF PASSING UP WITH FAMILIES. THE
THIRD PIECES ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE OF THINGS- WE JUST BARELY-
IMPLEMENTED TO INCREASE TO ONE
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND WE
REALLY THANK OUR PARTNERS AND
FORMER SOCIAL SERVICES LIKE FOR.
HELPING US GET THAT DONE WE
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO ANALYZE
THE IMPACTS OF THAT. WERE WE TO
THEN GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH FULL PASSED AT THIS POINT
TIME. OUR IMPLEMENTATION
SCHEDULE WOULD BE QUITE A WAYS
OUT AND GIVEN- AND SYSTEM
CHANGES AND- THE CENTRALIZATION
SYSTEM. OUR SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE
. THE WAS ABOUT THE- OF PASS
THROUGH. SUPPORT AND THAT'S A
PRESS TAG OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS TO THE STATE AND AS
SUCH AS KEEPING THAT IN MIND IT
WAS ONE THE QUESTIONS I WAS
ASKED. UNDER THE IMAGE EXPECT
LECTIONS- THE NUMBER PAYING. TO
INCREASE- IN OUR BUT WE WENT TO.
SEEING THEIR FOR THE- FEW THE
IMPACT TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OF ABOUT. A LITTLE LESS THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. BUT IF
TRAINS FOLLOW SIMILAR TO WHAT
COLORADANS EXPERIENCED OUR
COLLECTIONS WOULD GO UP KNOWING
THAT WHEN FAMILIES ARE PAYING
THE CHILD BUT THEY KNOW THAT
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO GO OVER
TO THE OTHER FAMILY INSTEAD OF
RECOUP BY GOVERNMENT- I THINK
THERE'S THIS AMERICAN HERITAGE-
APPRECIATION OF THE FACT THAT
THEY- FAMILY MEMBERS GOING TO
GET THIS MONEY AND SO. FOLKS ARE
MORE INCLINED TO PAY THE CHILD
SUPPORT. THE SECOND BULLET I'M
HERE IS REALLY ABOUT THE
DECREASE OF A HUNDRED AND-
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSISTANCE COLLECTIONS AND THE
DECREASE OF FOURTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS A NON SYSTEMS-
WHETHER. YOU'LL SEE IN THE
BUDGET THERE'S A DECREASE ON THE
US RECOUP INSIDE THERE ISN'T-
THAT IS THEN SHIFTED OVER TO THE
TO THE PAINTER TO THE FAMILY
SIR. THAT KIND OF OFFSETS BUT
THERE IS A DECLINE IN OVERALL
FOR COLLECTIONS FOR THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM. THIS IS
DISTANCE WHAT BECAUSE OF- THE
PANDEMIC AND THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WERE PUT OUT TO
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT EMPLOYMENT.
DOES HAVE TAPERED OFF OR OR
INDEED AND SO THOSE COLLECTION
AVENUES ARE NO LONGER THERE.
THAT CREATED A SPIKE IN
COLLECTIONS- WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW IS A RETURNS TO WHAT WE
WOULD MORE CONSISTENTLY EXPECT
TO SEE FROM CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM. HAVE BEEN OUR PREVIOUS
TRANSMIT BUT STILL SEE A
CONTINUED OR A STEADY INCREASE
OCTOBER COLLECTIONS AND SAID THE
SPIKE IN THE DROP BACK. DOWN TO
INCREASES THEIR- I CAN. QUESTION
THREE PER SECOND AND JUST JUMP
TO. NUMBER ON THE L. C. AND USED
TO THE- CRIME. FOR THE CHILD'S
FOR THE FOR THE RED ACT WE-
RETURN. OR RE IMPLEMENTED THE
FIFTH SIX NINE DOLLARS THAT
PULLED. IN AN EFFORT TO BALANCE
OUT THE LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
MONEY IS SUPPOSED TO BE AND IS
BEING UTILIZED FOR INCREASES IN
STAFFING RESOURCES TO BRING ALL
OF OUR LOCAL CHANNELS FOR
AGENCIES. UP TO AN EVEN PLAYING
FILD WHEN IT RATE WHEN IT COMES
TO PAYING FOR OR PROVIDING CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. ASSEMBLY LOCAL
CHALFORDAGENCIES ARE WORKING ON
THIS THOUGH I WILL ADMIT THERE
AND THEY WILL ADMIT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT STRUGGLES RIGHT NOW
COMING OUT OF PANDEMIC. I'M
TRYING TO GET. ADDITIONAL WORK
FOR SOME BOARD AND AS BEEN A
CHALLENGE NOT JUST FOR CHILD
SUPPORT FOR GOVERNMENT IN
GENERAL- MANY EVEN IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SO. THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING THE GROWING PAINS
WITH RETIREMENTS AND-
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS THAT UTILIZE
THAT BUT- IT IS NOT BEING
IMPLEMENTED USED IMPLEMENT NEW
PROGRAMS IT IS SPECIFICALLY FOR.
THE INCREASE HIRED. HIRING
STAFF. PERSON. YOU WANT TO COVER
THREE AND FIVE FROM. THANK YOU
KILGORE. I FIND NUMBER. FOUR
WITH. THE CLUB. OF OUR STATE. SO
WE HAVE A ADDITIONAL PIECE OF
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- WHICH IS
TIED COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL. TAX ABILITY EFFICIENCY
AND MODERNIZATION AND CHILD
SUPPORT I DON'T RULE. I
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
COMPLIANCE DEADLINE FOR COMING
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAST
ASPECTS OF THIS FEDERAL
REGULATION. SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. WE HAVE OUT PLAYED
OUT. A CHANGES TO STATUTES. OF
MANY OF WHICH ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE TO BRING US INTO. LINE
WITH THOSE. FOR EXAMPLE
CODIFYING AND- ASPECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
LONGSTANDING CASE LAW. THERE IS
SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE SB TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REPORT ON THE REVIEW AT THAT GUY
NINE. WHAT YOU COURAGE'S. THE
STATE TO CODIFY THESE MATTERS TO
KIND OF COMPLIANCE. FINAL. THE
FUND RULE DOES NOT A FOLK ON
APPEARANCE THE BILL TO HEY AT
BOTH. ABILITY TO PAY WHEN ESTADO
AN- AND ALSO LOOK TO HEY YOU.
THE ORDER SO SOME OF THE OUR OF
ARE A- THE PLACE FOR. BURKE
CHANGE TO EAST OF SEVERAL- IT
TURNS OUT THAT IT TO. WE NEED TO
CLOSE. WHEN IT IS HER BEST TO
UTILIZE IN EACH. OR IN. FOR
PARENTS ATKINS GOALS. FORCED SO
THIS DESPERATE SOME CHECK J.
THAT ARE GENERALLY AGAIN THAT
ARE PART OF LAW CALIFORNIA. IN
MANY CPAS CHANGE TO. THAT ARE
YOU BY ROCK CHILDS HE- RELATED
TO APRIL. NO WAY REGARD TO THIS
WEEK UNDER TO. A STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGE ROP- THIS DECEMBER. WE
ENGAGE WITH A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE. BUDGET AND REYES
POLICY COMMITTEE INVITED THE TO
A- VARIOUS. WE ALSO IN ALL LIKE
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY. AND
A LARGE GROUP OF ADVOCATES. WORK
IN THE INCLUDING EXAMPLE
BACKGROUND THE WESTMINSTER AMMAN
FIVE. AS PART OF IT EACH WEEK
AND JUSTICE TALK WISH PUBLISHING
EIGHT MARCH OF FIFTY. I'M HOSTED
THREE MEETING WHERE WE WALKED
THROUGH OUR- VARIOUS. IN THE
REGULATION AND COMPARED TO OUR-
CURRENT STATUTORY AND LAW SHOW
WHERE WE WOULD NEED TO MAKE
CHANGE. WE ARE FOR. AND INPUT AB
RIGHT NOW COMMENTS. AND THEN THE
FINAL BILL USED AND DRAFT ON
THAT OF FINANCE WEBSITE
CORPORATE THOSE. I REQUEST THAT
THOSE THAT CASE IS ALWAYS GO TO
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
OPERATES THAT HE GOT FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. WE ALSO
RECEIVED RECEIVED FEEDBACK
MEMBERS OF THAT COALITION IN
TERMS THAT THE ASPECTS THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN SETTING UP
PERCEPTION OF SUPPORT. INCLUDING
PHYSICAL AND OR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT WOULD MAKE THEM
REPORTS TWENTY CHANGES BASED ON
THOSE COMMENTS- THE LAST
QUESTION HERE WAS REGARDING
COLLECTOR. STUDY THAT WAS PASSED
AS PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT. UNLESS I PUT THE
BILL HE STUDIED WAS AUTHORIZED
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT. I CHANGED
YOUR LOG THAT WOULD PERMIT US TO
CATEGORIZE CERTAIN READERS THE
GOVERNMENT AS BEING ENTIRELY
UNCOLLECTIBLE. THIS IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO ADD PROVISION
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT WHAT
ALLOWS US TO COMPROMISE OR
REPAIRS WHICH ARE- CHECKED
APARTMENT SO IT'S ACCEPTANCE OF
A SMALLER AMOUNT IN ORDER TO
BRAVE THE LARGER AMOUNTS FOR
REPAIRS. AND IT'S AGAIN
COMPLEMENT YOUR TO THE CHANGE
FOR THIS YEAR I IN ORDER TO. THE
SELECT ACTUALLY NEED TO THE
FAMILY RATHER THAN. THEM FOR THE
GOVERNMENT'S. WE HAVE STARTED
WORK ON THE AND TRY TO CHECK AND
- OF THIS WITH SEARCH FOR
ASPECTS ABOUT OUR STATE MY OF
WORK. AND WE HAVEN'T WITH THAT
YOU CAL ANALYTICS PANEL OFFICE.
AS LITTLE SERVER SHOPS WERE IS
TO ASK OUR- THINGS THAT WHICH-
BESIDES THE FACT THAT WERE
ACTORS DID NOT STATURE. I WE ARE
YOU TO. OUR YOU. ONE OF OUR KEY
UNIVERSAL. THERE ARE MANY
EXCELLENT OPTIONS IN THIS AND WE
ARE TO WITH DIFFERENT UNIVERSITY
TO DO THAT WORK FOR US.
IMPLEMENTS THE FLEXIBLE THAT
PROVISIONS RIGHT JANUARY AT ONE
TWENTY TWENTY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR JULIA BAKER
WITH THE OF. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBER TO THE BACK WITH A OF NO
ADDITIONAL AT THE TIME THANK YOU
. NEXT WE WILL FROM JACKIE ARE
STILL WITH THE HELLO. THANK YOU
THIS IS JACKET HERE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE I'M
YEAR AGENDA MENTIONS THREE KEEP
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT ARE
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND I'LL
JUST GO THROUGH EACH OF THEM AND
HIGHLIGHT DARK MAJOR TAKE AWAYS.
THE FIRST ONE BEING- ADOPTING A
FULL PASS THROUGH POLICY FOR
PAYMENTS COLLECTED FOR FORMER
CAL WORKS FAMILIES AND WHAT THIS
MEANS ESSENTIALLY IS. WHEN EIGHT
PM WE SIGNED UP FOR CAO WORKS-
WE REQUIRED THEM TO SIGN OVER A
PORTION OF THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
TO THE STATE SO THAT WE CAN
ESSENTIALLY REIMBURSE OURSELVES
FOR THE CARROTS CACHET THAT
FAMILIES RECEIVING- AND WE-
COLLECT COLLECT THAT WHILE
THEY'RE RECEIVING CAL WORKS
HOWEVER- IF THERE'S A MISSED
PAYMENT AND WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
REIMBURSE OURSELVES FOR THAT
MONTH. WE KEEP TRACK OF THAT
AMOUNT WHICH THEN GOES TO
GOVERNMENT- THAT SO EVEN ONCE
THE FAMILY LEAVES CAL WORKS OR
THE CHILD I'M REACHES ADULTHOOD
WE STILL SEEK PAYMENT ON THAT
PASS DO GOVERNMENT BOWED- DEBT
ARREARS. I'M SO BUT THEY'VE GOT
BURKE IS ANY PAIN THAT ARE
COLLECTED. FOR THAT PAST DUE
GOVERNMENT. DECK INSTEAD OF THE
GOVERNMENT RETAINING IT WE'RE
JUST GONNA LET FORMER QARAX
FAMILY KEEP THAT MONEY- AS
MENTIONED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THIS MAXIMIZES FEDERAL
FLEXIBILITIES THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD ALLOW US TO DO
THIS WITHOUT HAVING TO REIMBURSE
THEM. FOR THEIR SHARE OF- CAL
WORKS RECOUP MEANT- HOWEVER IN
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE PROPOSAL WE
DO NOTE THAT THIS STILL
MAINTAINS A DIFFERENCE AND THE
PASTOR OF BROWN'S. RETWEET
CURRENT AND FORMER CAL LOOKS
FAMILIES SPECIFICALLY THE STATE
THE GOVERNMENT WOULD STILL BE
EIGHT WOULD STILL BE RETAINING A
PERSON AT A PORTION OF COUNT OF
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS MADE FOR
CURRENT POWER XPM LEASE TO
REIMBURSE ITSELF BACK FOR
CALVERT'S CASH AID. OVERALL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PASSED THROUGH
FRAMEWORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ULTIMATELY DECIDES TO ADOPTION
REALLY REFLECTS THAT IT'S
PROGRAM GOALS. I'M FOR EXAMPLE
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THAT THE
INTENT IS TO STABILIZE THE
FINANCIAL POSITION OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES- BUT SPECIFICALLY IT'S
ONLY LIMITED TO FORMER CAT WORKS
FAMILIES BUT WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT CURRENT COVERAGE FAMILIES.
ALSO EXPERIENCE- ALSO HAVE
REPORTED INCOME OUTLOOK HAVE
ALSO HAVE REPORTED INCOME LEVELS
THAT ARE VERY VERY WELL SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANTED TO MINIMIZE THE PAST YOUR
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN CURRENT AND
FORMER CAL WORKS FAMILIES. AND
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THAT ARE RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS. IT COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING A FULL PASSED HROUGH
FOR BOTH FORMER AND CURRENT
COLLEAGUES FAMILIES. OVERALL THE
THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE WE
NEED TO CONSIDER WHEN I'M
THINKING ABOUT WHAT PASSED
THROUGH REMARK- IT WOULD WANT TO
ADOPT INCLUDE PROPERLY TO EACH
CHANGE BE IMPLEMENTED AS AS WAS
REFERENCE BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
ANY PASTOR CHANGES FOR CURRENT
CAO WORKS FAMILIES LIKELY COULD
NOT BE IMPLEMENTED UNTIL
SOMETIME IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE JUST DUE TO ACT YOU
AUTOMATION CHALLENGES. ANOTHER
THING THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
WANT TO CONSIDER THOUGH IS
WHETHER ANY AUTOMATION PLANNING
ACTIVITIES COULD BEGIN NOW- IN
ORDER TO BETTER ENSURE THE
EARLIEST IMPLEMENTATION DATE. OF
ANY PASTOR CHANGES IT WOULD WANT
TO ADOPT A CART CAL WORKS
FAMILIES. AND OF COURSE
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DOES DECIDE
TO SUPPLEMENT OR ADD ON I'M TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO DO A
FULL PASSED THROUGH. FOR FORMER
CAL WORKS FAMILIES. LASTLY WE DO
NOTE THAT- IN INCREASING THE
PASTOR AMOUNTS FOR CURRENT AND
FORMER CAL WORKS FAMILIES THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WHETHER THAT WOULD
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY. FOR THAT FAMILY
WHEN IT COMES TO. OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND HOW WOULD
WANT TO DEAL WITH THAT. THE
SECOND A BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT'S
LAID OUT IN THE AGENDA- REFERS
TO A REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES- THIS
ESSENTIALLY IT BUILDS UPON A MAP
AT ALL A FUNDING METHODOLOGY
THAT WAS CONSTRUCTED BACK IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE L. C. SA FUNDING METHODOLOGY
AND THAT IT DOES NOT INCENTIVIZE
THE ADOPTION OF PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES- THAT COULD ALSO
HAVE THE EFFECT OF REDUCING COST
PRESSURES AND FREE OF EXISTING
FUNDS- BUT ALSO WHAT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE LCC FUNDING
METHODOLOGY. DOES NOT REFLECT
ACTUAL FUNDING NEEDS I'M GIVEN
THAT IT IS BASED OFF OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OPERATION LEVELS.
HOWEVER SINCE THEN SO MUCH HAS
CHANGED BUT THE PROGRAM
OPERATIONS IN LIGHT OF COVIC BUT
ALSO- WE ANTICIPATE EVEN FUTURE
CHANGES TO OPERATIONS LEVELS AS
WE SEEK TO COMPLY WITH THE
RECENT FEDERAL WORK
REQUIREMENTS- BASED OFF OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INTRODUCED. SO
WITH THAT SAID WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NOT PROVIDING
YOU FUTURE- FUNDING INCREASES
UNTIL THE ADMINISTRATION. SAYS
IT'S FUNDING METHODOLOGY TO
ADDRESS THOSE IDENTIFIED
SHORTCOMINGS SOME OF THE CHANGES
ARE PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
COULD BE ADDED TO THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
LIKE LIMITING THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS ADJUSTMENTS- TO A FIXED
RATE DOOR ADDING AN ON GOING
PROCESS IN WHICH BUDGETS FOR
OVER FUNDED L. CSAS. ARE
INCREMENTALLY REDUCED OVER A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN
THOSE EXCESS FUNDS ARE
REDISTRIBUTED. TO UNDERFUNDED
ALSO USING. OTHER POSSIBLE
CHANGES INCLUDE USING ANY
ADDITIONAL FUTURE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT STAFFING MODELS ARE
SERVICE MODELS THAT SPECIFICALLY
ALIGNED. WITH LEGISLATIVE
PROGRAM GOALS. THE LAST
PROPOSALS IN AT PROPOSAL THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO. I'M TO
CHANGE ROLE IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH THE I'VE RESET FEDERAL. WE
ARE STILL COMPLETING OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BUT TWO THINGS THAT I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT IN TERMS OF
THINGS THAT WERE CONSIDERING
INCLUDE. ONE WHETHER IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT MORE DETAILED LANGUAGE AND
DEFINITIONS AROUND ANY NEW
CRITERIA THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED WHEN ESTABLISHING A
CHILD SUPPORT ORDER OR
DETERMINING IF PARENTS ABILITY
TO PAY. IN ORDER TO ENSURE A
STANDARDIZED APPROACH WHEN IT
COMES TO IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW
CRITERIA AND EQUITABLE TREATMENT
FOR ALL FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY SIMILAR TO
THE QUESTION THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA- WE ALSO RAISE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER TO WHAT EXTENT ARE THE
PROPOSED CHANGES BETTER SUITED
TO BE CONSIDERED THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS RELATIVE TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM MIKE
HERALD WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. EXCUSE ME MR
JERRY BEFORE WE CONTINUE ON IN
THE AGENDA ETCETERA IF- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE-
DEPARTMENT HAS A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO THE LATEST
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT WOULD BE
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADD TO THE
BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE L. A. AS RECOMMENDATION TO
WITHHOLD FUNDING TO LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES- THERE MANY
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
THAT REMAIN UNDERFUNDED. AND OUR
GOAL WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
FIRST ADDRESS THE DISPARITY OF
FUNDING AND TO THE IDENTIFIED
COUNTIES AND BRING THEM TO
PARITY I'M BEFORE WE REVISIT THE
FUNDING CALCULATOR FOR ON GOING
FUNDING PURPOSES. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THE DEPARTMENT CAN
PROVIDE ANY FURTHER INFORMATION.
ON WHAT THIS FUNDING IS STILL
NEEDED. THAT'S OKAY AT THIS
POINT WE WILL CONTINUE THE PANEL
AND THEN TAKE ANY MEMBER
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE. WE
WILL NOW HEAR FROM MIKE HERALD
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. THINK ABOUT OUR
STATE. THINK ABOUT OUR STATE'S
CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM- THANK YOU
THEY ASSUME THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A SYSTEM LIKE THIS IN PLACE
SO THAT THE CHILDREN OF THESE IN
SITUATIONS ARE GETTING ENOUGH
CASH ASSISTANCE ENOUGH MONEY IN
THEIR LIVES SO THAT YOU KNOW
THEY CAN HAVE THE BASIC
NECESSITIES OF LIFE- THAT- YOU
KNOW WE PUT WE YOU KNOW WE WERE
VERY DEMANDING OF NONCUSTODIAL
PARENTS WE THOUGHT WE WOULD PUT
A GREATER BURDEN ON THEM TO- TO
PROVIDE THEIR- COULD CHUCK OF
THEIR RESOURCES THIS WHOLE
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW LARGE
AWARDS TO BE. IT'S A BIT OF A
MAJOR POLICY DISCUSSION THAT WE
SHOULD BE HAVING- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU WHEN I TELL PEOPLE THAT YOU
KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE THAT THE CHILDREN
NEVER ARE GETTING VERY LITTLE OF
THE CHILD SUPPORT IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY GO TO THE KIDS. PEOPLE
LOOK AT ME LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT CAN'T BE AND
I GO NO ACTUALLY THE WAY OUR
SYSTEM WORKS IS THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TAKE THE
MONEY. END USER TO RE IN THEM
FOR THE CLOCK PROVIDE WELFARE
BENEFITS. ANIMO CASES ONLY A
PORTION IN THE BACK CASE ONLY A
PORSCHE OF THE CHILD. HEY
ACTUALLY GO THE PAN. THAT THE
CHILDREN WHO NEED- THIS. IS
REALLY CAL INTUITIVE I THINK
MOST PEOPLE THE RELEASE TO LEARN
WE ALL THE THIS TO- MAKE NOCTIS
A REAL. MEET THEIR OBLIGATION.
AND THE OTHER THING OF THE DAY
THE MONEY REALLY DOES NOT GO TO
THE CHILDREN THEMSELVES OF STATE
. I'M SO I THINK THE OUT OF THE
BACK. I WANTED ACKNOWLEDGE START
OFF LIKE KNOWLEDGE GENE. THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PUT FORTH HERE- NEED
MINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING. THEY ARE
PROPOSING THE IN THIS POLICY AND
ACTUALLY PASS THROUGH THE CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS THAT PARENTS
MADE. TO THE CHILDREN
THEMSELVES. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE WALL
ALL THE WAY ALONG. AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP THAT WE ALL NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THIS MONTH I
NEED OF THE KIDS. AND AFTER
WORLD TRYING TO DO HERE RIGHT
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE. THE KIDS
DON'T LIVE IN POVERTY AND
DESTITUTION AND YET OUR POLICY
YOUR TO FOR HAS BEEN. PRIORITIZE
THANK. NEEDS OVER THE NEEDS THE
CHILD. SO YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT
WHAT THE GUY HAS PROPOSED HERE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT WHAT THE A.
OWNERS JUST READ HOWEVER WHICH
IS THAT WE SHOULD ALSO PROVIDE A
FULL PASS THROUGH. FOR THE
CURRENT CALLOUS CASES- AS THE L.
A. L. NOTED IN MOST CASES. BUT
THE FAMILY DOG HOW WORKS ARE.
BENEFIT WHO ARE OPPENHEIMER CASE
THE FAMILY OF FORMER KING. TO
THE NEEDS OF EACH ARE GROWN.
THEY NEED MONEY NOW. NOT IN THE
- NOT TO BE DELAY AGAIN WE HAVE
THE ALL FIRST TWENTY YEARS THE
TIME FOR CONTINUING TO DELAY
THAT. IS COMMANDANT WE NEED TO
EXPAND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO INCLUDE ALL THE CURRENT CAL
WORST CASE. SO THAT THOSE
FAMILIES ALSO GET THE ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY NEED. NOW COLORADO HAS
ALREADY DONE THAT. AND I THINK
EVEN OUR DIRECTOR KILGORE MAY
MENTION THIS IN HIS REMARKS AND
CRESCENTA COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE ABOUT WORKING WITH OUR
COALITION ON THESE EFFORTS AND
REDUCE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER BOB
I THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT THE
COLORADO PILOT THAT WOULD POP
RATED IS SHOWING REMARKABLE
RESULTS. AND ENSURE. PRETTY
SIMPLE- WHEN NON CRYPTO PARENTS
. NO THAT THE MONEY IS GOING TO
THE RICH. AND NOT TO THE
GOVERNMENT. THE PARENTS PAY MORE
AND THEY PAY MORE OFTEN. SO WE
IN COLORADO WE'VE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES BUT
BELIEVE ONE STUDY CITED THAT
THERE WAS 76% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PARENTS WHO PAY AND
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND OF THOSE WHO
PAID THE FAMILY GOT OUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS
MORE A MONTH IN INCOME. THAT'S A
LOT OF MONEY FOR A VERY VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND THE FAMILIES
WHO ARE CURRENTLY LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY CALIFORNIA. PROGRAM'S
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE- AND SO
WE WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
FIND A WAY TO PASS THROUGH ALL
THE CHILD SUPPORT FOR THE
CURRENT CASES WE ALSO WOULD
ENCOURAGE. YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. IT YOU'RE
UNFORTUNATE HAVE TO CHOOSE BASED
ON THE BUDGET CONCERN. YOU KNOW
WE WOULD PRIORITIZE THE CURRENT
CASES FIRST BECAUSE WE THINK THE
NEEDS OF THOSE FAMILIES ARE
GREATER. BUT WE'RE REALLY HOPING
THAT WE CAN BE ABLE. AND ONE
LAST THING WE WOULD JUST SAY
ABOUT CHILD SUPPORT. IF WE WANT
NON PARENTS TO PAY WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT OF
WORK AND GENERATE INCOME. WE
SPEND A LOT OF DRIVERS LICENSES
OF NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS TO RENT
ARREARS RIGHT NOW. AND MANY OF
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
POOR. SO TAKING AWAY THEIR
LICENSE MEANS THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO WORK THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO LOSE THEIR JOBS. WE
SHOULD BE VERY NARROWLY APPLYING
THIS LICENSE SUSPENSION
REQUIREMENTS ONLY ON PARENTS
WHOSE INCOME WE KNOW. AB
DEVELOPMENT THE PAYMENT WE'RE
NOT MAKING. GOING AFTER LOW LOW
IN- INTO. THAT'S A SPENDING BILL
AND JUST MAKES WORSE. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM ANY SIX AND
THE SOFT LAURIE PARENT LEADER
WITH THE STUDENT'S PARENTS WHO
ARE REIMAGINING CAL WORKS ALSO
KNOWN AS S. P. R. A C. PLEASE
BEGIN. HELLO MY NAME IS DENISE
THE FLOORING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M SUPER
NERVOUS- BUT HERE WE GO- AND
NAME'S NEEDS THE FLORIDA M. MY
THERE'D THE A FOUR YEAR OLD BOY
WHO IS FULLY CONVINCED THAT HERE
TO READ. OR INTENT- I ALSO
STUDENT. CAL WORKS RECIPE- AND
I'M CURRENTLY PREPARING TO
TRANSFER TO CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
IN SAN MARCOS TO COMPLETE MY BA
IN SOCIOLOGY. IN ADDITION TO
THAT I'M A PROUD SPARK LEADER
I'M FOR PARKS STANDS STUDENT AND
WHO ARE REIMAGINING WORKS
SPARKING THE MOVEMENT WHERE WE
CAN- AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE RESEARCHING
RELIGION FOR BOTH MEDIA COVERAGE
. WITH THE SYSTEM ASSEMBLY. I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHARE WITH YOU MY
WITH HAVING MATCH THAN THE IN A
BY THE STATE AND HOW THAT HAS
IMPACTED MY FAMILY. WHEN I
APPLIED FOR CAO WORKS HAVING AN
OPEN HOUSE SUPPORT AS WITH NON
NEGOTIABLE IF I WERE TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE. THIS
CALL BY MY COUNTY WORKER YOU
OPEN IT OR WE WILL PURSUE IT ON
YOUR BEHALF. I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE IN HELP- UNLESS THERE
WAS. OPEN TALK TO FOR ORDER WHEN
ASKED WHY THE COUNTY WORKER
REPLIED WE WILL HELP YOU BUT.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO GET BACK.
REALLY I BOUGHT. SAYS MY
HESITATION ME WITH FEAR I'M HERE
ON HOW MY COPING WOULD REALLY IN
ANY BACKLASH THAT I MIGHT
RECEIVE FROM THIS ORDER IN THERE
HAD BEEN A HIT OF THEM VIOLENCE
BETWEEN A AND FINANCES AND HIS
COUNTRY TO MY- SIR AS A POINT OF
BETWEEN A- HM CONSIDERING
ASSISTANCE WE- AN AGREEMENT. GET
ON HOW HE WOULD. AN ANSWER.
EVERY WAS COOKED WITH A THE OR
WITH BY STATE NEEDLESS TO SAY.
I'M THIS BECAUSE MORE HARM TO ME
THANK. SAID HELLO MESSAGE. THE
NATIONAL IMPACT FOR THIS- OF MY
CO PARENTS REACT GLADE ESCALATED
TENSIONS AND BRUTALIZED OUR
IMMEDIATE SAY IN IT. ONCE SON'S
REALIZED HE WOULD MAKING HELP TO
RE MIKE A BACK THE STATE- AND
THAT HE HAS THE CHILD SUPPORT
WOULDN'T EVEN BE GO TO HIS SON
HE PAYMENTS BECAME. SO AS WITH
THAT BE- BY MY CARE WHEN. THEY
CAN THE PAYMENTS WERE CAN TO ME
AND TO CHILD WHEN HE KNEW THAT
MY SO WAS GETTING THE MONEY TO
WAS GOING TO HIM- DOES ALL THAT
HURT THE MOST. I READ RANGER MY
SON- IT'S HE'S BEEN COMING FOR.
ME NEEDING HELP. AND LIKE THE
STATE PRIORITIZE IS PRIORITIZE
THEIR NEED FOR RE AND- OR THE
NEEDS OF OUR- THE SECOND
QUESTION. YOU DON'T KNOW WAS
WHAT WITH STATE. HEALTH SUPPORT
SYSTEM WORKS- BETTER FOR YOUR
CHILD KNOWS ABOUT AS. ALL YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE CHILD PAYMENTS GO
TO. I BELIEVE THAT EVERY IS A
FINANCE SECURE IN CONCERT TO
ENSURE THE THERE IS THE OUT OF
RESOURCES EACH AND EVERY MONTH
IN ADDITION TO THAT A I BELIEVE
THAT THIS SHOULD. THEM OF CHAO
SUPPORT THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
PAID TO CHILDREN REGARDLESS IF
THE PAIR CAMPAIGN NOT 80% OF
CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING NO CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS I MEAN 80% OF
OUR CHILDREN ARE NOT RECEIVING
ADEQUATE ADEQUATE RESOURCES THEY
NEED EVERY SINGLE MONTH- STATE.
ARE TOUCHED. NEED BEFORE THEIR
NEED FOR REIMBURSEMENT. I
UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR'S THINGS
ALLOW. FORMER HOWARD CASES TO
RECEIVE ALL THE CHILD SUPPORT
BUT CURRENT WORK. AND REYES. YOU
KNOW I THINK BACKWARD BECAUSE
IT'S IF I'M OFF OF THIS IS. MY
NEED AND AS- WHEN I WHEN I'M
HONEST THIS I NEED IT NOW I KNOW
TO HELP THEM- SO WHAT I'M ASKING
. IS THAT. AND LONG. IT'S YOU
EXPAND OUR CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS BE PASS TO ONLY FORMER
WORKS. BUT FAMILIES. ALL THANK
YOU AND YOU DID GREAT. NEXT
WE'LL HEAR KAREN REUTER OF THE
CENTER TO OF TO SERVICES. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHARITY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO BE APPOINTED
DIRECTOR OF THE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCY. IN CALIFORNIA
AND A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I AM TRULY GRATEFUL
. IN THE CONVERSATION TODAY AND
I WILL ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMUNITY IN MY COMMENTS. WE
HAVE A COMMON PROBLEMS AND I AM
COMMITTED TO THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ERADICATE
POVERTY. AND ADDRESS INTRUSIVE
POLICIES THAT CREATE AN
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. AND I AM NOT
ALONE. THE PEOPLE THAT IT IS TO
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM CHAIR
ABOUT THE FAMILIES WE SERVE
EVERY DAY WE STRIVE TO HONOR THE
MISSION TO FIGHT POVERTY AND
INEQUALITY. I EMPOWERING PARENTS
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
REMAIN SIGNIFICANT HOW WE
DELIVER THOSE SERVICES NEEDS TO
KEEP PACE WITH FAMILIES TODAY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS HAS SET
THE RIGHT TONE. OR IMPLEMENTING
THE CHANGES GUIDED BY THE
FEDERAL LAW AND I AM EXCITED TO
IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES. WITH YOUR
HELP AND LEADERSHIP THE ABILITY
TO HAVE A MORE OPEN AND
RECEPTIVE PROGRAMS THAT IS
FLEXIBLE. FAMILY FOCUSED
APPROACHABLE TO PARENTS PAYING
SUPPORT AND OFFERS CUSTOMIZED
INTERVENTIONS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE. LIKE THE LEGISLATURE
I'VE BEEN LISTENING TO PARENTS
STORIES AND I AM COMMITTED TO
GETTING AS MUCH MONEY TO
FAMILIES LIKE. 101% CONCERT TO
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. REMOTES RACIAL EQUITY
AND IS TRANSFORMATIVE FOR
CHILDREN. BUT IF YOU ASKED ME
TODAY IF MY AGENCY HAS THE
RESOURCES IT NEEDS TO DO THE
WORK NECESSARY TO TRANSFORM
OUTCOMES FOR FAMILIES I HAVE TO
SAY NO. THE FEDERAL LAW HAS
CHANGED AND EVERY COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCY NEEDS TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION TOGETHER. THE
FACT EVERY COUNTY IS NOT
FINANCIALLY ABLE TO MAKE THIS
MOMENT WE NEED YOUR HELP. RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES ACROSS OUR
STATE ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN AND
CONTINUE BASS LINE SERVICES AS
WE EMERGE FROM THE CULVERT CARE
ACT. INDIVIDUALIZED PARENT LED
CASE MANAGEMENT WITH HOLISTIC
REMEDIES TO BARRIERS THAT
REFLECT OUR CLIENT DEMOGRAPHICS
IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING. TO
GET FROM WHERE WE ARE NOW TO
WHERE WE ALL AGREE WE OUGHT TO
BE. WE WILL NEED ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE PROMISES
MADE PROMISES KEPT. THIS IS A
LEADING PROGRAM. THE STATE
INVESTMENT TRIGGERS A MATCHING
INVESTMENT I ARTWORK FEDERAL
PARTNERS SO WE CAN GET THE
PROGRAM WE ALL ONCE AND FAMILIES
EXPECT. TO GET FROM A TRIP SIX
TRANSACTIONAL SYSTEM. TO A
TRANSFORMATIONAL FAMILY CENTER
PROGRAM IT WILL TAKE A VILLAGE.
WE WILL WE WILL NEED LAWS
REGULATIONS AUTOMATED SYSTEM
CHANGES EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
AND STAFF DEVELOPMENT BUT
SUPPORTS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE WHICH-
THE TABLE MUST BE SET WITH
STRATEGIC PARTNERS THAT INCLUDE
COUNTY DIRECTORS THE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
RULE. SURE EIGHT BEST PRACTICES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
WE NEED PARENTS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE AT THE TABLE TO TELL
US IF WE ARE GETTING IT RIGHT.%
WE ALL WANT MEANINGFUL CHANGE AS
A DIRECTOR. I'M WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. I DON'T WANT TO
FLEX MUSCLE MEMORY BACK TO THE
SAME SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR THIRTY YEARS. I NEED THE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSFORMATION FROM THE TOP OF
OUR ORGANIZATION TOWARDS IRAQ
SERVICE WORKERS. WE MUST DO THIS
WORK INTENTIONALLY. AND
THOUGHTFULLY IN A WAY THAT DOES
NOT HAVE UNINTENDED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THE VERY
FAMILIES WE ARE TRYING TO HELP.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S HOW WE
TOGETHER CAN GET SYSTEMIC CHANGE
. FINALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PROMOTING SYSTEMIC RACIAL EQUITY
DOES NOT REST SOLELY WITHTHE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF BAD ACTORS BUT
WITH A CRITICAL REVIEW OF THE
COLLECTIVE SYSTEM OF POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES I PROGRAM
LEADERSHIP. WHEREVER WE SET. WE
NEED TO DO THIS WORK IN BOLD AND
COURAGEOUS WAYS TO UNDO
INSTITUTIONAL. AND STRUCTURAL
RACISM. TO MAKE A PARADIGM SHIFT
. WE CAN INCLUDE INNOVATIVE
SERVICES SUCH AS GREATER
LANGUAGE AND PROGRAM ACCESS SO
PARENTS FEEL TRULY HEARD AND
INCARCERATED PARENTS RECEIVE THE
SAME LEVEL OF SERVICE AS SOMEONE
WALKING INTO OUR OFFICE.
EXPANSION OF OUR SERVICES TO
INCLUDE NON MONETARY ORDERS.
BROADENING THE REACH OF ACCESS
OR VISITATION BASED ON ITS VALUE
TO INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES AND
LEARNING FROM CALIFORNIA'S
TRIBAL NATIONS TO PROVIDE
PARENTS. WITH THE OPTION TO
DEVELOPING HIGH ORDERS THAT OUR
PARENTS. I'LL TRULY VALUABLE
HONORS EXTENDED FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS. AND BUILDING ON
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS TO PROMOTE
POSITIVE CO PARENTING
RELATIONSHIPS. THROUGH PARENTING
TIME ORDERS. WE NEED THE FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE TRANSFORMATION
FROM THE TOP OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS TO OUR DIRECT
SERVICE WORKERS. AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE I BELIEVE THAT'S HOW WE
EAT TOGETHER GET TO A REAL
CHANGE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM SHARON MARDALE TRAY HO
THE DIRECTOR. FOR THE MERCED
MARIPOSA REGIONAL DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AN HONOR TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M I'M SHARON
WARDELL TRAY HO THE DIRECTOR OF
THE MERCED MARIPOSA REGIONAL
TRANSPORT AGENCY AND I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY AS A DIRECTOR OF
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY.
OFFERS A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ABOUT MY ORGANIZATION
MY DEPARTMENT ASSIST OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND CASES IN BOTH
RURAL AND MOUNTAIN REGIONS WITH
HIGH POVERTY LEVELS AND PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE CASELOADS 21% OF OUR
CASELOAD IS CURRENTLY ASSISTED
AND 66% BEING FORMALLY ASSISTED.
THIS PAST YEAR WE COLLECTED OVER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WITH
NEARLY 70% OF THOSE COLLECTIONS
GOING DIRECTLY TO THE FAMILIES
WE SERVE WE SERVE IN OUR CURRENT
COMMUNITIES ABOUT ONE IN SEVEN
FAMILIES WITH A NATIONAL RATIO
ABOUT ONE IN FIVE BEING SERVED
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO PROVIDING
OUR SERVICES TO A GREATER
COMMUNITY THAT IS IN NEED. LIKE
MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FOR SAN
FRANCISCO I THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR THESE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
ST FOR THE PROPOSED BUDGET TO
GIVE OUR LOCAL AGENCIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
MAXIMIZE THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE TO OUR CUSTOMERS IN A
TIME WHEN SERVICES WITH GOALS OF
REDUCING POVERTY AND CREATING
STABILITY ARE SO VERY ESSENTIAL
. ONE QUESTION THE AGENDAS HOW
WILL THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RECOMMENDING FULL PASSER OF
COLLECTIONS ON FORMALLY ASSISTED
CHILD SUPPORT ARREARS. PROMOTE
CHILD AND FAMILY STABILIZATION.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFIC TO FULL PASSER OF
ARREARS COLLECTION ON FORMALLY
ASSISTED CASES BUILDS UPON AS-
DIRECTED KILGORE DIMENSIONED
BUILDS UPON PRIOR LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF FAMILIES
AS THEY ARE LESS RELIANT ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE. THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS A STARK THIRD
LARGEST POVERTY PREVENTION
PROGRAM IN THE STATE AND PASSING
THE ARREARS COLLECTIONS THREE TO
FAMILIES WILL HELP THEM CREATE
GREATER STABILITY. REPRESENTING
TO COUNTIES BOTH RURAL AMOUNT
COMMUNITIES WITH HIGH PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE CASELOADS THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HAVE A MEANINGFUL
AND POSITIVE IMPACT ON OUR
IMMEDIATE COMMUNITIES. IN MERCED
COUNTY OF THE ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS DISTRIBUTED LAST
YEAR IS A REARS OR PAST DUE
CHILD SUPPORT. EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION OR ABOUT 73% WAS
DISTRIBUTED TO FORMERLY ASSISTED
CASES. BASED UPON CURRENT
DISTRIBUTION HIERARCHY ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT WENT TO FORMALLY
ASSISTED FAMILIES SKEWS ME ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT WAS COLLECTED WENT
DIRECTLY TO FORMALLY ASSISTED
FAMILIES. WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALL
OF THOSE DOLLARS WOULD GO TO THE
FAMILIES STRENGTHENING THEIR
FINANCIAL SECURITY AND MINIMAP
MINIMIZING THAT RISK OF LIVING
IN POVERTY. WHILE INCREASING
MONEY TO FAMILIES AS NOTED BY
ADMINISTRATION THIS PROPOSAL IS
WITHIN ALLOWABLE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES SO LOW OR MINIMAL
COST TO THE STATE. THOUGH THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
CAN BENEFIT FAMILIES IT'S ALSO
COMPLICATED AND STARTING WITH
THE FORMERLY ASSISTED ARREARS IS
A GOOD PLAC TO START. MANY OF
THESE FAMILIES MAY BE RECEIVING
A VARIETY OF NEEDS BASED
SERVICES FROM FEDERAL AND STATE
PROGRAMS. EVALUATING IT FOR
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OR
IMPACTS THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY
MAY HAVE ON THE FAMILIES
ELIGIBILITY FOR OTHER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS WILL BE NECESSARY.
ANOTHER QUESTION IN THE AGENDA
WAS HOW DOES FINALIZATION OF THE
MANDATES OF THE FEDERAL FINAL
ROLE IMPACT LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
OPERATIONAL PROGRAMS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE
FOR FEDERAL FINAL RULE WILL
ENABLE LOCAL AGENCIES TO CREATE
ORDERS THAT ACCURATELY REFLECT
AN INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES
WHICH CAN MINIMIZE ARREARS DEBT
AND THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH
ALLOWING PAST DUE CHILD SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD SUPPORT
PROGRAM ALREADY CONSIDERS A
PARENT'S ABILITY TO PAY AN
ACTUAL EARNINGS WHEN
ESTABLISHING A CHILD SUPPORT
ORDER THE FEDERAL FINAL RULES
FOCUS TO MINIMIZE THE USE OF A
STANDARD PRESUMED INCOME ABOUT.
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ENHANCE THEIR ESTABLISHMENT
PROCESS AND CONSIDER OTHER
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS A
PARENTS LOCATION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HISTORY AND LANGUAGE
BARRIERS TO NAME A FEW. THESE
MANDATES WILL CREATE CONSISTENCY
AND SERVICES PROVIDED ACROSS THE
STRAIT THE STATE AND CREATE
GREATER SYSTEMIC EQUITY TO THOSE
WE SERVE. IMPLEMENTING THE
MANDATES OF THE FEDERAL FINAL
RULE WILL GIVE LOCA AGENCIES
FURTHER OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
WITH BOTH PARENTS TOGETHER THAT
SPECIFIC INFORMATION. CHILDREN
IN OUR PROGRAM WILL ALSO BENEFIT
FROM THESE NEW ESTABLISHMENT
PROCESSES. THE OBJECTIVE OF THE
ESTABLISH OF ESTABLISHING ORDERS
THAT ARE BASED UPON INDIVIDUAL
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES INCREASES
THE LIKELIHOOD OF PAYMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT. CONSISTENT CHARGE
PER PAYMENTS WILL BE SOMETHING
THE FAMILY CAN RELY UPON EACH
MONTH HELPING TO CREATE A STABLE
HOUSEHOLD AND THEN THERE IS THE
POSITIVE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT
THE CHILD. KNOWING THAT THEIR
PARENT IS PAYING TO SUPPORT
THEIR FINANCIAL AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THEM. AS CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM IS
PROGRESSIVE HAVING ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED SOME OF THE MANDATES
OF THE FEDERAL FINAL RULE MOVING
FORWARD I BELIEVE AS A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM WE WILL BE ABLE TO FOCUS
NECESSARY ATTENTION. TO THE
TOPIC OF SYSTEMIC EQUITY AND
SEEK SOLUTIONS FOR POTENTIAL
INEQUITIES. OPERATIONALLY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
FINAL RULE- A SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD FOR EVERY
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY
STATEWIDE. TO PROPERLY IMPLEMENT
THESE NEW MANDATES WILL REQUIRE
CHANGING OUR BUSINESS PRACTICES
AND MORE RESOURCES WILL BE
NECESSARY. WHAT IMPACT WILL THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAVE ON CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM ABILITY TO
PROMOTE CHILD AND FAMILY
STABILIZATION. AT THE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY THAT HAS
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED AND IS
ANTICIPATING RECEIVING INCREASED
FUNDS I AM GRATEFUL AND
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR AND
DEPARTMENTS EFFORTS IN PREVIOUS
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET SEEKS
A TWENTY POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS STATES GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTION TO ASSIST THE UNDER
FUNDED LOCAL AGENCIES. THESE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE FUNDING DISPARITY
BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCIES WITHOUT
THESE FUNDS LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
ABLE TO ENSURE PARITY OF CURRENT
SERVICES TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
HAVING SAID THAT. THE CURRENT
FUNDING METHODOLOGY WAS BASED
UPON HOW WE OPERATED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WITH THE FEDERAL FINAL
RULE MANDATES EVERY LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCY REGARDLESS OF
ADEQUATE ADEQUACY OF FUNDING
WILL BE REQUIRED TO DO MORE
COMPREHENSIVE ACTIVITIES AND
THIS WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
STAFF AND TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO
GATHER AND EVALUATE NEW
INFORMATION NOT PREVIOUSLY
CONSIDERED. WHEN ESTABLISHING OR
MODIFYING A CHILD SUPPORT ORDER.
AN INVESTMENT OF MORE FUNDS WILL
BE NECESSARY TO HELP ALL LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES TO
ACHIEVE THIS. AS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC RECRUITMENT
AND HIRING PROCESS AS OF ARE
TAKING LONGER AND AGENCIES
STRUGGLE TO FIT FILL VACANCIES.
THE FEDERAL FINAL RULE MANDATES
WILL NOT BE IMPLEMENTED UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. DUE TO THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROGRAM AND
TIME IT TAKES TO SUPPORT THE
STEEP LEARNING CURVE FOR NEW
EMPLOYEES IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
EACH LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY
START HIRING TRAINING AND
PREPARING FOR THE NEW WAY OF
BUSINESS NOW. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH THAT I WILL BRING
IT BACK UP TO THE DÍAS TO SEE IF
ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS SEEM
NON I WILL. KEEP IT HERE WITH
THE CHAIR. I WILL BEGIN. AGAIN
BY JUST WANTING TO MAKE SURE TO
COMPLEMENT A NIECE OF FLORIDA
THE PARENT LEADER WHO WE- HEARD
EARLIER TODAY WHO WAS SPEAKING
ABOUT HER FOUR YEAR OLD SON WHO
WANTED TO BE A- RED. POWER
RANGER I BELIEVE THAT WAS JASON
AND I'M SHOWING TOO MUCH THAT I
KNOW ABOUT THE POWER RANGERS.
BUT BUT IT HELLO. IT ALLOWED ME
TO REALLY CONTEXTUALIZE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WERE PLACING THE
FAMILIES AT THE CENTER. AND HER
SUGGESTION HERE TODAY WAS WHY WE
AREN'T HELPING CURRENT FAMILIES
AND INSTEAD ARE FOCUSING ON THE
FORMER. CASES OF THOSE WHO ARE
IN THE SYSTEM AND I'M HOPING TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON WHY WE WOULD
CHOOSE THAT AS WE HEARD FROM.
MIKE HERALD IT IS OFTENTIMES
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED. WHO HAVE THE GREATEST
NEED. I'M WONDERING WHY WE
AREN'T PROVIDING THAT SIMILAR
PASSED THROUGH FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ENROLLED. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION DAVID
OVERCORRECTED THE DEPARTMENT- IT
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF MERIT
TO THE IDEA THE CONCEPT OF FULL
PAST YOU AND I THINK IDEALLY THE
PROGRAM DETAILS FOR PROGRAM
WOULD LIKE TO BE THERE AT SOME
POINT IN TIME- THIS TOPIC A FULL
PASSWORD CURRENT SUPPORT WAS
BROUGHT UP TWO YEARS AGO. AND
THROUGH THE TEACHER THE
DISCUSSION NEGOTIATION WITH
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATION- IT WAS AGREED TO
MOVE THE DISREGARD FROM FIFTY
DOLLARS TO ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS INSTEAD OF GOING
TO THE FULL PAST YEAR. PART OF
THAT PROJECT THAT ISSUE WAS THE
PRICE TAG PART OF IT WAS WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITY TO GO ABOUT THAT WE
CAN'T DO FULL PASSED THE WE JUST
HAVE TO MAKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOLE ON THEIR PIECE
IF WE WERE TO DO THAT BECAUSE-
AT THIS POINT IN TIME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IS NOT GOING
TO WAIT THEIR PORTION OF
RECRUITMENT IF WE CHOOSE TO PASS
THROUGH THE FUNDS- THROUGH THE
WHOLE- THREE ANALYSTS SO ACTING
ON A PREVIOUS LEGISLATION WE
DIDN'T MAKE THAT MOVE TO ONE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED AND JUST
IMPLEMENT THAT IN JANUARY. I
THINK WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EVALUATE HOW MUCH OF THAT THE
PAYMENTS IS PASSED TO THE FAMILY
AND HW MUCH IS RETAIN OFF OF
THIS NEW INCREASE THRESHOLD- AND
WE HAVE SOME TIME TO DO THAT
BECAUSE- THROUGH OUR ANALYSIS
OF. OF SYSTEMS WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE CAN REACH THIS OR GET TO
THIS- SYSTEM CHANGE BECAUSE THIS
IS A PRETTY MASSIVE ON THE
CURRENT SUPPORT SYSTEMS SIDE OF
THINGS AS OPPOSED TO THE- FORMER
SIDE. WE DON'T THINK WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE
IMPLEMENTATIONS IN THE SYSTEMS
OF TOP TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SO I THINK THIS TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION CAN CONTINUE- AND
WITH MORE DATA AS WE START TO
SEE THE IMPACT OF. THE INCREASE
PASTOR TO ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THERE'S
NECESSARILY ANY EIGHTY. ISSUE
FROM THE S. SO FROM DAY- THE
GOVERNOR'S SIDE THAT THAT THIS
IS THE WRONG WAY TO GO WE'RE
JUST NOT SURE THAT WE CAN TACKLE
THIS RIGHT NOW AND WE HAVE SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THAT AS
WITH FOR. I WOULD APPRECIATE A
CHANCE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PORTION IS STATE RECRUITMENT
VERSUS FEDERAL RECRUITMENT TO
GET A. BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW WE I. EVENTUALLY ARE MAKING
SURE WERE TAKING CARE OF. NEEDS-
OVER COVER. NEEDS BUT NOW WOULD
TO TRANSIT IF I COULD TO SPEAK
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. AND ON TWENTY
EIGHT OF THE AGENDA THERE'S A
TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN POINT ONE
BILLION AND CHILD SUPPORT
ARREARS AS OF DECEMBER FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND IT
REFERENCES THAT SIX POINT SIX
BILLION WAS OWED TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND I'M HOPING TO GET A
BIT MORE CLARITY ABOUT WHICH
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. TO
UNDERSTAND. RESPONSIBILITIES
ABOUT WHO'S OWED WHAT
ULTIMATELY- I BELIEVE THAT AS WE
ARE HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS
FROM THE COLLECTABILITY STUDY WE
WILL GET TO A POINT WHERE WERE
REALLY STARTING TO UNDERSTAND
THOSE ARREARS WHICH ARE EITHER
COMPROMISED OR DEEMED
UNCOLLECTIBLE AND I'M WONDERING
HOW WE CAN EFFECTIVELY.
TRANSITION OR MOVE FORWARD TO
TAKE THESE OFF OF OUR BALANCE
SHEET IF THEY ARE DEEMED
UNCOLLECTIBLE PER THE
COLLECTABILITY STUDY AND I'M
WONDERING HOW WE CAN DO THAT IN
LIGHT OF WHAT IS CURRENTLY.
BEING UNDER DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
GAMBLING AND SO IF I CAN I
ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE L. A. O. TO SEE IF WE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT WOULD OCCUR
TO THE GAM LIMIT IF WE WERE TO.
HELP TO RECTIFY THESE ARREARS
THAT CURRENTLY ON OUR BALANCE
SHEET AND WOULD APPRECIATE A
CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT. AS WE'RE GOING FORWARD
. WITH THAT I WILL MAKE SOME
REQUESTS FROM THE CHAIR AND
THERE ARE TWO SPECIFIC REQUEST
ON THE AGENDA I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE OF THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
ARE ON PAGE THIRTY OF OUR
AGENDA. I'D LIKE TO KINDLY ASK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES TO PLEASE
PROVIDE FIRST AN ESTIMATE OF
THAT FULL PASS THROUGH OF CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS TO CURRENTLY
ASSISTING CASES WITH THE L. L.
ASSISTING US. WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS THE FULL PORTRAIT OF
COST CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE POLL
FULL PASSED THROUGH ALSO WITH
THINKING ABOUT OPTIONS FOR A
POTENTIAL PHASE AND RELATIVE TO
WHAT DIRECTOR KILGORE TO SAID.
ABOUT INFORMATION IN TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY FIVE. SECONDS I WOULD
LIKE A NARROWER ANALYSIS OF THE
STATUTORY CHANGES NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THE FINAL RULE WITH A
MEETING WITH KEY LEGISLATIVE
STAFF REQUESTED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO DISCUSS THIS. WITH
THATI'D LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ISSUE FOR WHICH IS ON
CALFRESH AND THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND
EMERGENCY FOOD THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE KEY PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS. WILL HAVE SEVEN
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL WILL
BEGIN WITH JENNIFER HERNANDEZ
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND
EMPOWERMENT DIVISION DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. FOLLOWED BY
TYLER WOODS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE RYAN ANDERSON WITH
THE L. A. O. KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. SHANTI PRASAD
SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. BUT SOBRE EL ESTUDIO
SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR NOURISHED
CALIFORNIA AND JAKE BRYMER
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AND
EXTERNAL RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AIDES
COMMISSION. LET'S BEGIN WITH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR HERNANDEZ WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA I
WILL BEGIN- FIRST WITH THE
QUESTION REGARDING- CAL FIRST
ADMINISTRATION AND SO- WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO START WITH AN
UPDATE IN TERMS OF THE STATUS OF
WHERE WE ARE- THE STATE AND
COUNTY YOUTH WILL BE ABLE TO
RESUME OUR ADMIN RE BASING
CONVERSATIONS. TO DEVELOP A NEW
METHODOLOGY ONCE WE ARE FURTHER
PASSED IN THE PANDEMIC AND
ELIGIBILITY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES HAVE STABILIZED AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE- THERE HAS BEEN
A LOT OF READING AND HAVING TO
FOCUS ON THE REAL TIME
CHALLENGES AND SO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE FURTHER. DOWN THE
LINE BEFORE WE ENGAGE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- HOWEVER THE
CALFRESH ADMINISTRATION REBATES
WILL BE ABLE TO RIGHT SIZE THE
CALPERS COUNTY PROPHECIES WHILE
WE ALSO DEVELOP A MULTI YEAR
PLAN TO BRING EFFICIENCIES AND
TO THE PROGRAM. I'M NEXT ITEM
THAT IS ON THE AGENDA IS IN
REGARDS TO THE- PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
FOOD BANK FUNDING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET.
AND SO I'M CDSS IS CURRENTLY
PROVIDING TEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
FOOD BOXES PER MONTH. TO OUR
FOOD BANKS UTILIZING OUR COOPER
NINETEEN GOOD BANKS THE PORT
FUNDING. AND THIS FUNDING WOULD
CONTINUE TO ALLOW US TO BE ABLE
TO DISTRIBUTE AT THIS LEVEL
THROUGH JUNE OF THIS YEAR. THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF FIFTY
MILLION IS AN AUGMENTATION TO
THE CALVET PROGRAM- AND IS
PROPOSED TO ALLOW THE EMERGENCY
FOOD BOX PROGRAM TO AND- WHILE
PROVIDING FOOD BANKS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO. TO MAKE
FOR A SMOOTH THE RAMP DOWN
EFFORT RATE AS FEDERAL AND STATE
EMERGENCY FOOD ALLOCATIONS BEGAN
TO- TO TAPER OFF. THE THIRD ITEM
IS RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
EXPANSION- ANY PARTICULAR
ADDRESS SCENE- THE TARGETED
POPULATION- IN TERMS OF OUR
STATUS RELATED TO THE PLANNING-
WE HAVE ALREADY KICKED OFF OR
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
IN FACT IT BEGUN ABOUT OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY SCHEDULED QUARTERLY
MEETINGS WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE ARE FOCUSING
RIGHT NOW ON IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGIES AND SORT OF.
DEVELOPING OUR TIMELINES. AS WE
GET CLOSER TO- SORT OF RAMPING
UP WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
INCREASE OUR OUR OUR MEETINGS.
TO A BI MONTHLY CADENCE- IN
PARTICULAR AS WE GET CLOSER TO
ANTICIPATED IMPLEMENTATION DATE
RIGHT- IN TERMS OF THE
AUTOMATION. CONVERSATION THAT IS
A LARGE PART OF THE DISCUSSION
AND THOSE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
BEEN GOING ON GOING ON A MONTHLY
BASIS BETWEEN. THE DEPARTMENT
KELSALL AS- AND- CWPA- THOSE
HAVE BEEN REGULAR WEEK TAKING
PLACE. IN TERMS OF WHO IS GOING
TO BE TARGETED BY THIS EXPANSION
OF THE PROGRAM. THE FIFTY FIVE
YEAR AND OLDER- POPULATION IS
WHO WE ARE PROPOSING- FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS- BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THERE ARE
THERE TEND TO BE FEWER SUPPORTS
FOR THIS POPULATION- AND IN LIFE
ALTERNATIVES FOR OLDER ADULTS
YOU KNOW THEY THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO LEVERAGE SCHOOL
BASED MEALS OR OR OTHER PROGRAMS
RIGHT. AND SO THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE- PERHAPS- GO WITHOUT
IT'S AND SO THAT IS ONE. REASON
ON THE OTHER THAT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT IT DONE IN THE- HE NEEDS
AND SUPPORTS FOR THIS OLDER- OUR
POPULATION IT'S ALSO A KEY
PRIORITY AND GOAL OF THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING FOR TRUSTEES HI
THIS POPULATION AND THIS
PARTICULAR NEED. AND LASTLY THE
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
IDENTIFICATION OF FILLING KEY
GAPS IN THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. SUCH AS-
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE WITH THE
MEDICAID EXPANSION- TO ALL
PERSONS REGARDLESS OF OUR
DOCUMENT KITS DOT. THE NEXT ITEM
IS RELATED TO THE SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION FOR- TO LOOK OLDER
ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. I THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALREADY BEGUN THE PROCESS-
INTERNALLY WE ARE ENGAGING WITH
OUR PARTNERS WITHIN THE RESEARCH
AUTOMATION AND DATA DIVISION.
THEY HAVE A HUMAN CENTERED
DESIGN UNIT THAT HELPS TO
FACILITATE- THE PLANNING PROCESS
AND DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND SO
WE ARE ENGAGING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DEVELOPING A
PLAN. ON HOW WE WOULD ROLL OUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW
APPLICATION. THERE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN A SERIES OF INTERNAL
MEETINGS AND WE PLAN ON CONTINUE
TO CONTINUING TO COORDINATE AND
DEVELOP A PROCESS. TO ENGAGE OUR
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS AND SO WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BEGIN CONVENING- WITH EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO OBTAIN THEIR
INPUT INTO THE SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION PROCESS AND WE DO
FEEL WE ARE ON TARGET TO-
RELEASE I IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE NEXT ITEM IS
RELATED TO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR A STATE WIDE TELEPHONE BASED
SERVICE MODEL. AND SO- WE WERE
REQUIRED TO- TO PRESENT TO YOU A
SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT
RESULTED IN A PROCESS KICKED OFF
BY- SECTION SEVENTY B. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FIVE.
AND SO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN COORDINATION
AND CONSULTATION WITH CHINESE.
FOOD ADVOCATES- THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
THE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
THAWS I WAS ABLE TO ENGAGE IN A
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO IMPLEMENT A FULLY
TELEPHONE BASED SERVICE MODEL
STATEWIDE. AND SO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CONTAINED
CONTAINED. WITHIN THE SUMMARY
THAT I WILL PROVIDE TO YOU TODAY
REALLY ARE- PURSUANT TO THAT
CONVERTS THE CONVERSATIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS REFLECTED OF
THOSE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROCESS. IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS THAT WE
LEVERAGED WE DID OUR LEVERAGE
SURVEYS TO COLLECT INPUT FROM
OUR COUNTY CALFRESH. ELIGIBILITY
REPRESENTATIVES ALONG WITH FOOD
ADVOCATES N. OR A CA YOU LABOR
PARTNERS- IN ADDITION WE WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE AND CALL OUT THAT
MANY COUNTIES ARE ALREADY DOING-
MUCH OF THIS. AND SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THEIR CURRENT
TELEPHONE BASED BUSINESS
OPERATION PRACTICES AND
PROCESSING. AND SO THAT WAS VERY
USEFUL TO HELP INFORM THAT THE
CONVERSATION WE ALSO GATHERED
FEEDBACK FROM THE SIZE AND
INCORPORATED THAT INTO THE
SUGGESTIONS- AND THAT THE FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THE SURVEYS ARE WE DID ALSO
COORDINATE AND WORK WITH OUR
PART NURSE. THE SPONSOR THIS
SECTION OF THE BILL AND HOSTED A
LISTENING SESSION TO GATHER
FEEDBACK FROM EXPERTS WITH
EXPERIENCE IN TELEPHONE BASED
SERVICE MODELS- AND THEN LASTLY
THE LISTENING SESSION I DID
INCLUDE. OUR COUNTY CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY REPRESENTATIVES-
ALONG WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER FOOD
ADVOCATES. AND SO GENERALLY
SPEAKING IN THE RECORD DIDN'T
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT- ARE
IDENTIFIED AGAIN REFLECTING- THE
- PARTICIPATED IN THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS- INCLUDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ESTABLISH
TELEPHONIC BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M THAT WOULD
ENHANCE CALL CENTER FEATURES
THAT WOULD EXPLORE ITS POTENTIAL
OF INTERACTIVE VOICE RESPONSE OR
OTHERWISE KNOWNAS IVR SYSTEMS.
AND EXPLORE IMPROVEMENTS IN HOW
THE COUNTY IS- ARE IDENTIFIED AS
COLORS IN OUTBOUND CALLS AND SO
THAT'S AN INTERESTING ONE IT'S
WHERE. I COUNTY CALLS AN
INDIVIDUAL AND PERHAPS IT SHOWS
UP AS A BLOCK CALLED RIGHT- WE
WOULD WANT TO EXPONENTIALLY
EXPLORE WAYS TO IDENTIFY IT AS
COUNTY TAX RATES SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS. ARE MORE LIKELY TO
PICK UP THE CALL. I'M THE NEXT I
THAT- I'D LIKE TO RAISE UP IN
THE STAR OF AB SEVENTY NINE. THE
SEMI ANNUAL REPORT- THAT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE STAR OF
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
SO WITH THE AB SEVENTY NINE P.
POPULATE IT'S OUR WORK GROUP
BEGAN MEETING LAST YEAR IN JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND HAVE
BEEN MEETING REGULARLY ON A
MONTHLY BASIS- THE WORKGROUP HAS
BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
DROPPED TO BETTER PEOPLE RELATED
STAR SEVEN AND START SEVEN EIGHT
FORMS. AND IS THOSE FORMS ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER FINAL REVIEW I'M
AND WE DO EXPECT TO FINALIZE
THOSE WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK OR
SO. AND THEN ONCE WE'VE-
FINALIZE THAT REVIEW- WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
INCLUDE THE WORKGROUP- IN
CONSULTING WITH THE VENDOR TO
HELP US INFORM HIM AND THEN-
CENTER DESIGN ASPECTS AND USER
TESTING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT REAL. LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE- ACTUALLY A PART OF OUR
PROGRAM- HELP OFFER FEEDBACK
RIGHT AND SO THAT'S THAT'S GOING
TO BE A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
THE EFFORT. AND THEN- THE
DEPARTMENT IS ON TRACK TO BE
ABLE TO RELEASE A LETTER BY
APRIL OF THIS YEAR TO INFORM
COUNTY IS THAT AND THE
CONSORTIA. ABOUT THE FORTHCOMING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR PRE
POPULATED STAR SEVEN AND- FROM
THEN WE WOULD BE IN THE DESIGN
AND USER. TESTING PHASE WHICH WE
WOULD EXPECT TO THE BEGIN
BETWEEN MARCH AND JUNE OF THIS
YEAR. AND SO ALL OF THIS WOULD
CULMINATE IN A LETTER SORT OF A
HIGHLIGHTING THESE TIME LINES-
AND THAT WOULD BE SCHEDULED FOR
RELEASE IN NOVEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. WITH THE TARGETED-
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF THE
ACTUAL FORMS IN THE SYSTEM BY
JANUARY. OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
NO WE DID NOT. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR TYLER WOODS WITH THE
TO OF FINANCE. I WAS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD AT THIS TIME. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE
L. A. O.'S OFFICE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN BRIAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT KNOWN AS-
WAS REFERENCED BY THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
ADDRESS ON C. FIVE IT EXPANSION-
WE DO THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AN IMPORTANT DECISION LAID
OUT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
EXPRESSED A- DESIRE TO
EVENTUALLY EXPAND THIS
ASSISTANCE WHICH RIGHT NOW
SERVES A VERY NARROW- POPULATION
OF IMMIGRANTS. BASICALLY A LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE COUNTRY OF US IN
FIVE YEARS. THIS IS ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXPRESSED A
DESIRE TO EVENTUALLY EXPAND
THOSE FOOD BENEFITS THE TOTAL
POPULATION THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
ELIGIBLE FOR. FOOD ASSISTANCE DO
ENTIRELY TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS THIS IS SEVERAL HUNDRED
THOUSAND- SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WITH SEVEN- FOLKS USING
AN AGE BASED APPROACH BUT DID
NOT SPECIFY WHICH AGE RANGES
WOULD BENEFIT FIRST NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED WE
START WITH AGES FIFTY FIVE AND
OLDER AND THEY'VE GIVEN YOU SOME
ARGUMENTS FOR WHY. BUT THERE ARE
OTHER POPULATIONS ARE NEEDING-
WE THINK LOOKING AT THE DATA OUT
THERE ARE OTHER POPULATIONS THAT
ARE BOTH LARGER AMONGST THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND MORE LIKELY TO
BE. INCOME ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND THESE ARE JUST
FACTORS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD KEEP IN MIND IN DECIDING
HOW EXACTLY THIS THIS ROLLOUTS
WOULD BE TARGETED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. GREAT
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KATHY SANDERLING FEET OF
PTA THE QUESTIONS THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO ADDRESS- TALK ABOUT
COUNTIES EXPERIENCE WITH
CALFRESH AND WHAT'S BEEN GOING
ON DURING THE PANDEMIC WHAT WE
NEED TO SUCCESSFULLY CONDUCT THE
WORK AND SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT MUST HERNANDEZ TALKED ABOUT
AS WELL AS THE REPORT. SO FIRST
OFF WHAT WE'VE SEEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC IS- INCREASES AND CAN
EXPLODE AND APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN LARGELY SUSTAINED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PANDEMIC
PERIOD. CALFRESH IS. USUALLY A
LEADING INDICATOR OF ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP. BOB GRAHAM THAT
HISTORICALLY HAS GROWN FIRST
DURING AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OR
RECESSION WITH THE PANDEMIC
HOWEVER WE THOUGHT- IN ADDITION
TO THAT INITIAL INCREASE THE
SAME KINDS OF BUMPS THAT I HAD
TALKED ABOUT IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM PANEL. HOWEVER THE
NUMBERS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
AT EVERY POINT OF THE PANDEMIC
THAN THE RAWNUMBERS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT HOW. WE WENT FROM AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS FOR A WEEK BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. BUT DURING THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE REACHED AN
AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS PER WEEK FOR A
SHORT PERIOD SO THAT HAS BALLOT
PAPER OFF THE BAT IT STILL
REMAINS HIGH AND ABOVE THE FORTY
THOUSAND NUMBER MORE LIKE. SIXTY
THOUSAND. I WILL HONESTLY THAT
MANY COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING AND
THAT THE BUYER BUT THE SUSTAIN
INCREASES HAVE REALLY
EXACERBATED A SITUATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN FACING FOR YEARS NOW
IN WHICH COUNTIES ARE SEVERELY
UNDERFUNDED FOR THE WORK THAT WE
DO COULD MINISTER CAL CALFRESH
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE'VE NOT
RECEIVED A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS INCREASE FOR CALFRESH
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND ONE SO
THIS MEANS WERE BEING FUNDED AS
A WORKER SALARIES BENEFIT COSTS
THE COST OF OFFICE SPACE IN
OFFICE SUPPLIES EVERYTHING THAT
WE NEED TO GO INTO OPERATING
THAT OFFICE AND STAFFING AT-
IT'S STILL THE SAME COST AS OF
ONE TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO. THAT
IF THE STATE HAD PER. IN THE
WILL AND PLAY AND JOB TO ITS
SHARE OF CALFRESH ADMINISTRATION
COSTS DURING THIS TIME. STATE
GENERAL FUND THE COUNTIES WOULD
BE HIGHER BY ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
STATUTORY FEDERAL AND COUNTY
MATCHING FUNDS THE TOTAL AMOUNT
WHEN YOU TAKE THOSE INTO ACCOUNT
AS WELL AS ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. HIGHER AT THAT
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE FUNDED THAN
IT IS TODAY. THAT THE QUAKE TO
ABOUT SIXTY FOUR HUNDRED WORKERS
MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND WORKERS
THAT WE WOULD HAVE ON THE JOB ON
THOSE FRONT LINES. THAT WE'VE
BEEN UNABLE TO HIGHER BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF THE SPOT. THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS THAT HAPPEN WHEN
WE'RE UNDER FIVE. THE TWO MAIN
THINGS YOU THINK ABOUT WITH
CALFRESH OUR TIMELINESS AND
ACCURACY YOU WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE
HUNGRY TO GET THEIR BENEFITS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE YEAH WHEN
SOMEONE IS ELIGIBLE YOU WANT TO
FIND THEM ELIGIBLE IF THEY'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE WE SHOULD FIND THEM
NOT ELIGIBLE YEAH WE ALSO NEED
TO CALCULATE THE APPROPRIATE
BENEFIT AMOUNT. FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY. IN
ADDITION SHIHO- THE CALCULATION
COUNTIES HAVE GENERALLY THIRTY
DAYS TO PROFIT A CALFRESH
APPLICATION BUT SOMEONE WHO
COMES IN AND HAS A CERTAIN. OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT SUCH AS A VERY
LOW AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE BANK
HAVE THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE NEED
REQUIREMENT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
PROCESS THOSE WITHIN THREE DAYS.
AND COUNTY STRUGGLED WITH THAT'S
QUITE FRANKLY AND IT'S LARGELY
BECAUSE OF THE VOLUME THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AND THE LACK OF
STAFFING. ACCURACY IS REALLY
CRITICAL AS WELL- THERE ARE
FEDERAL REVIEWS OF OUR ACCURACY
BOTH THAT ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION AT TRIAL AS WELL
AS THE BENEFIT AMOUNT AND
GETTING THAT WRONG IN EITHER
DIRECTION A LOWER OR HIGHER
BENEFIT. THAT SOMEONE IS A
LEGIBLE FOR FINDING SOMEONE
INELIGIBLE WHEN THEY'RE REALLY
ELIGIBLE OR VICE VERSA CAN
ULTIMATELY RESULT IN PENALTIES
FOR THE STATE. THE COUNTIES ALSO
SHARING THESE PENALTIES IF I
COUNTY CONTRIBUTED TO THAT
OVERALL. THE ISSUE THAT RESULTED
IN THE PENALTY. THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS AND- THAT
IT COULD. TO THE R. FUNDING WE
HAVE NOT ALWAYS RECEIVE FULL
FUNDING FOR K. FOR INCREASED.
THE AFTER FIVE I HAVE. OUT OF
THE MEDICATION THAT BROUGHT IN
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF SS I RECIPIENTS I WE WERE NOT
FULLY FUNDED FOR THAT USE THAT
INCREASE EVEN AT THAT TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE LEVEL. AND
THERE HAS BEEN RECENT
LEGISLATION PASSED IN PARTICULAR
A BILL THAT REQUIRES COMPANIES
TO HAVE A PERSON IDENTIFIED TO
WORK WITH THE COLLEGE SYSTEM. TO
ENSURE THAT BENEFITS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE WHICH WE TOTALLY AGREE
THERE'S A FUNDING FOR THAT THE
BUDGET WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT ISSUE AND
HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE ADDRESSED
AND NAY. BUT TYPICALLY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION GAP WE ARE
REQUESTING SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AS A BRIDGE TO THE
NEW BUDGETING METHODOLOGY THAT
MUST HERNANDEZ MATCH AND- WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT METHODOLOGY TO BE
USED IN TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR IF WE STAY ON
TRACK SO WOULD BE SOMETHING
YOU'D BE DISCUSSING NEXT YEAR
WITH ALL OF US DURING THAT I
JUST YES SORT OF DISCUSSION OVER
BUDGET CLASS ONE. SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND CAN BE SEEN
AS A BRANCH THAT HOPEFULLY WILL
ONLY LAST ONE YEAR TO US GETTING
TO THAT METHODOLOGY. I WILL SAY
THAT THAT- INTENDED DID ASK WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING YOU KNOW KIND
OF WHAT WE THINK ABOUT THAT
ADDITIONAL DELAY AND THE
METHODOLOGY. IT MADE SENSE WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC NOTHING IS A STEADY
STATE RIGHT NOW AND SO DELAYING
IT A COUPLE OF YEARS MAKES SENSE
BUT WE ARE IT WORK HURTING
COUNTIES ARE REALLY HURTING IN
THIS PROGRAM AND- SO WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT. OF THAT
AT THE BRANCH. COUPLE MORE
COMMON HERE- ARE MOVING NEEDLE
AS FAR TAKE. AND RETAINING OF
THE- WE THINK THAT WERE. MANY I
THINK MOST. FOR CDS AFTER
SHOPPING EXPLAINING THAT CHANGES
. IN AB SEVENTY NINE THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TRAILER BILL
THAT INCORPORATED MOST ASPECTS
OF THE BILL BY CHAIR TANK. THAT
WE SPONSORED AT CEDAR BDA IT
REALLY PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENTS NOT
JUST YOU. I'M GETTING PEOPLE ON
TO THE PROGRAM BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE RETAIN. OF THE PRE
POPULATED FORM IN THIS HERNANDEZ
MENTIONS REALLY EXCITING. I
THINK- AS I ALLUDED TO IN THE
POWER SECTOR MONEY- IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO GO FURTHER.
THANK ELIPORT IN POLICY LAB
RECENTLY DID SOME ANALYSIS OF
CALFRESH DATA. AND THEY FOUND
NOT A SURPRISE PEOPLE TEND TO
DROP OFF AT RENEWAL OR WHEN
THEY'RE FILLING IN THAT SEMI
ANNUAL REPORT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE YEAR. BASICALLY WHEN THERE'S
A PAPERWORK REQUIREMENT SOMEONE
HAVE TO MAKE THAT REPORT. IT CAN
RESULT IN A DROP BOX OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO.
OTHERWISE ARE ELIGIBLE BUT THEY
JUST DIDN'T GET THE FORM ACT.
AND SO THE BEST WAY TO STOP THIS
IS JACK MINIMIZE OR ELIMINATE
THE REPORTING IN. THE SEMI
ANNUAL REPORT- AS I KIND OF
AGAIN ALLUDED TO IN THE PRIOR
PANEL WOULD REQUIRE FEDERAL
ADVOCACY TO BE ABLE TO ELIMINATE
THAT FOR CALFRESH- IT MAY BE
WORTH PURSUING WE THINK WE'RE
NOT THE ONLY STATE. THAT WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN THAT I COULD
MAKE A CASE THAT WOULD BENEFIT.
HUNGRY PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM-
OBVIOUSLY THOUGH WE. COULD WE
CAN'T JUST DOTHAT ON OUR OWN.
AND THEN FINALLY REGARD TO THE
CLASS RELATED TO THE STATE
HEALTH. REPORT WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE STATE THE FINAL REPORT
REALLY TARGETED IN ON A FEW KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS. WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE. HOW
AND WHEN AND THE IDEAS COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED AND WE THINK SOME OF
THE IDEAS KIND OF PIGGYBACK ON
EXISTING WORK IN AFRICA. SO THEY
MIGHT BE EASIER TO GET. AS I
WRAP UP I DO JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO COMMENT ON THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION REPORT. THAT YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT IN JUST A FEW MINUTES
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH
ARE INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA.
WE'VE PROVIDED SOME INPUT TO THE
COMMISSION LATE LAST YEAR ON A
DRAFT OF THE REPORT. AND HAD
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT WE
SHARE WITH THE COMMISSION AT
THAT TIME WE HAD A ANTICIPATED
THING REVISED VERSION OF THE
REPORT. PRIOR TO ITS RELEASE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY APPEARS
REPORTED BEEN PRESENTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND HAVE NOT TAKEN
PWBA CONCERNS INTO ACCOUNT. WE
ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO GETTING
MORE BENEFITS TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN OF
PROGRAM CHANGES THAT WILL ENABLE
THAT'S- BUT A NUMBER OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
COMMISSION REPORTER QUITE
FRANKLY UNWORKABLE. GIVEN THE
TIME THAT WERE UNDER HERE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND WRITING. TO FURTHER DETAIL
THE ISSUES WE HAVE WITH THAT THE
FACT REPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND OF COURSE THE BILL THE
ANSWER QUESTIONS AFTER THE
PANEL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM SHANTI PRASAD
SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. THANK YOU CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE- CITY. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT FOOD SECURITY AND
THE CURRENT IMPACT ON HUNGER AND
FUTURE IMPACTS ABOUT THE LOOMING
WITH THE LOOMING FOOD CLIFF WHEN
THE FEDERAL PUBLIC EMERGENCY
OPERATION COMES TO AN END. THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
CURRENTLY EXPIRES ON APRIL
SIXTEENTH BUT COULD BE EXTENDED
IT PROVIDES SEVERAL TEMPORARY
HELP US IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE
HELPED TO MITIGATE HUNGER
CONFERENCE IS CURRENTLY BEING
EXPANDED TO MORE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND THERE'S A
SUSPENSION OF THE AVON TIME
LIMIT. WHEN WE LOSE THE PHEV THE
STATE COULD LOSE THESE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES WHICH WOULD BE A
MAJOR AND- ON HUNGER AT THE SAME
TIME ADMINISTRATORS COULD LOSE
FLEXIBILITY AS THEY'RE USING
CREATING INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR
COUNTIES. BUT PERHAPS THE MOST
DAMAGING LOSS WILL BE THE END OF
THE EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS FOR
CALFRESH WHICH IS CURRENTLY
BEING AND OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH IN FOOD
PURCHASING POWER. DESPITE THESE
ANOTHER PANDEMIC RELATED
SUPPORTS FOOD INSECURITY RATES
IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN VERY HIGH
RATES DECREASED SOMEWHAT OVER
THE LAST YEAR BUT AS OF OCTOBER
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ACCORDING TO THE CENSUS
HOUSEHOLD PULSE SURVEY THE FOOD
INSECURITY RATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO PERCENT. THE
RATE FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN IS TWENTY FOUR POINT 9%
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES ARE WORSE
THE LATIN NEXT POPULATION HAS
TWENTY SIX POINT 1% FOOD
INSECURITY. AND LATIN X.
HOUSEHOLDS THE CHILDREN ARE AT
THIRD B. FOUR POINT 7% AND THERE
ARE SIMILARLY HIGH RATES OF
HUNGER FOR ALL COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THESE ARE SHOCKING TREATS
AND FOOD BANKS ARE REPORTING
THAT DEMAND HAS SPIKED IN TWO
THOUSAND- IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO DUE TO THE HIGHEST INFLATION
RATES IN FORTY YEARS AND THE-
MAKRAN VARIANT AND THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO SEE CLIENTS. WHO ARE
ACCESSING A FOOD BANK FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE LONG TERM
REPERCUSSIONS OF THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC AND ENSUING ECONOMIC
CRISIS. CANNOT BE UNDERESTIMATED
. WE KNOW MUCH OF BEING DONE
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO CDSS FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK TO ENSURE
COVERAGE ACCESS AND IT'S A BIG
INCREASE IN CASELOAD. AND FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW PANDEMIC AB
T. PROGRAM AND WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE THAT AS MANY KIDS AS
POSSIBLE RECEIVE THIS
ASSISTANCE. AND THANKS TO THAT
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS FOR
PROVIDING CRITICAL ACCESS TO
SOCIAL SERVICES WE SUPPORT THE
REQUEST FOR ADEQUATE COUNTY
FUNDING TO ADMINISTER CALFRESH
ESPECIALLY AS DEMAND FOR THE
PROGRAM CONTINUES TO RISE. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR DEVELOPING THE
SIMPLIFIED CALFRESH APPLICATION
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND HERE
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS AND ITEMS WE
SUPPORT. AS WE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM COVERT RELATED EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND PROGRAMS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE WE DO
SO WITH THE PHASE OUT APPROACH.
THAT PREVENTS SHOCKS TO PEOPLE'S
BUDGETS AND THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS PEOPLE ARE STILL
RELYING ON THEM TO PREVENT
HUNGER. ESPECIALLY THE CALFRESH
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS AS AN
EXAMPLE A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL ON
SSI WHO IS CURRENTLY RECEIVING
THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS WILL
RECEIVE ONLY TWENTY DOLLARS A
MONTH AFTER THE EA'S AND- LET'S
LEARN FROM THE GREAT RECESSION'S
RECOVERY IT TOOK TEN YEARS JUST
TO REDUCE HUNGER TO PRE
RECESSION LEVELS. OF 10% WHICH
IS STILL UNACCEPTABLE AT FOUR
MILLION FOOD INSECURE
CALIFORNIANS FOOD BANKS TO
CONTINUE TO BE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE PANDEMIC ARE
ANTICIPATING AT LEAST TO THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME TO RECOVER
FROM THIS PANDEMIC. AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS AND THEY NEED TO BE
PREPARED. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S ADDITION A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME IN HIS
JANUARY BUDGET FOR COFFEE TO
PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROUND FOOD.
AND WE REQUEST AN INCREASE TO
THE ONGOING AMOUNT FROM EIGHT
MILLION TO SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL BECAUSE FOODBANK DEMAND
DOUBLED IT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND THE STATE IS PROVIDING AT
LEAST A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EMERGENCY FOOD BOXES
THE LAST TWO YEARS WHICH ENDS IN
JUNE. SO THE BASE PRE PANDEMIC
NEED WAS REALLY SIXTY MILLION
AND WE NEED AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY
MILLION ONE TIME. TO MITIGATE
THE PANDEMIC RECOVERY FOR A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION FOR HEALTHY. WE LEARN
FROM OUR NETWORK SURVEY IN
DECEMBER THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CLIMATE RESILIENT EQUIPMENT
NEEDS FOR FOOD BANKS AND THEIR
FIVE THOUSAND PLUS AGENCY
NETWORK HAVE INCREASED. BECAUSE
OF THE ENORMOUS INCREASE IN FOOD
THEY ARE DISTRIBUTING AND IT
EXCEEDS SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THIS NEED. TO STORE
AND TRANSPORT FOOD MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND SUPPORT CLIMATE
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE. ANDWE
REQUEST IMPROVEMENTS IN
ACCESSING THE STATE DISASTER
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. CAFB
ALSO SUPPORTS SEE FAST FOOD FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. INCREASING
THE SNB AND TNB PROGRAMS TO
ACHIEVE PARITY WITH THE RECENT
CALFRESH INCREASE. AND CAFB
SUPPORTS CACHET PROGRAMS LIKE
CAL WORKS TAX CREDITS GUARANTEED
INCOME AND SSI SAID THAT
CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAVE POVERTY.
PERMANENTLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM FED SOBRE EL ESTUDIO
SENIOR ADVOCATE FROM NOURISH
CALIFORNIA. EVERY GIRL GOT
TENURE MYSELF BUT AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BY THE
TIME TO SPEAK TODAY- MY NAME IS
THAT THE VIOLENCE WILL BE YOU'LL
AND I'M A SENIOR ADVOCATE WITH
MARRIAGE CALIFORNIA- I JUST WANT
TO START BY THINKING CHAIRPERSON
ARAMBULA AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR SUPPORT. AND
SECURING FUNDING LAST YEAR TO
BEGIN THE IMPLEMENTATION
APPROVED FOR ALL BY INSURING
SEPTEMBER SECOND READING AT THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. ALSO KNOWN AS THE- THIS
FINDING IS LAYING THE IMPACT.
PARKS BY AND BENEFITS AND MANY
CAL EVER. WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM CAL YOU DID IT.
STATUS WE ARE ALSO PLEASED WITH
THE I'D LIKE TO PROPOSE OF THAT
BEEN FOR. FIFTY FIVE AND OVER.
FIFTY FIVE IS AN AND STEP
TOWARDS AND- EVERY CAL. ACCESS
IN ADDITION THE- REGARDLESS OF
THAT IMMIGRATION STATUS. WELL
PROPOSED. ALL OF THIS INITIAL
FUNDING BY EXPANDING BENEFITS
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS OF ALL
AGES. IT WILL ENSURE AN
EQUITABLE STATE INTERESTS AND I
THINK THIS SYSTEM THAT HELPS
MITIGATE HUNGER AND POVERTY THAT
HAVE BEEN BOTH EXACERBATED BY
THE PEN THAT MAKE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT EVEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC IMMIGRANTS
WERE ALREADY EXPERIENCING HIGH
LEVELS OF FOOD INSECURITY AS A
RESULT OF LOW WAGES. INCREASING
HOUSING COSTS AND DESTRUCTIVE
PICKING UP PROGRAMS ANTI
IMMIGRANT POLICIES AND RHETORIC
. AS WE HEAD INTO THE THIRTY
YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT'S WORTH PUTTING IN
THE THIRD YEAR- CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO FACE THE PARCHMENT.
AND HIGH LEVELS OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND MAKING
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN HIT
ESPECIALLY HARD. HIGH INFECTION
RATE STOP LOSSES AND LIMITED
ACCESS TO PANDEMIC WRITTEN
AFTERWARDS. IN ADDITION AND
AGAINST EXPERIENCE HIGH LEVELS
OF FOOD INSECURITY AS A RESULT
OF THE FACIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES AND BEING A PUBLIC
NUISANCE WITHIN OUR STATE SAFETY
NET PROGRAM. IMMIGRANTS ARE
ACTUALLY MORE LIKELY TO LIVE IN
POVERTY AND CHILDREN IN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE RITA FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO STRUGGLE TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. THE WILD
HOW FAST AND THE CALIFORNIA FOR
THE SYSTEM PROGRAM PROVIDES A
CRITICAL LIFELINE FOR MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW INCOME.
PROGRAM EXCLUDE MANY AND AGAIN
ON THE BASIS OF THE IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THIS INCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. ARE
DACA RECIPIENTS. TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS AND MIGRANTS
NON AT EBS IMMIGRATION. AND SOME
VISA HOLDERS. AND THIS IS THE
FOR HER MEAN FOR IF I. SOMEONE
THAT I'VE GOT CONSOLE THE YEARS
AND WHAT TESTIFIED IN THE POP UP
BOOK FOR ALL. THIRTY MINUTES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND SHE'S A
MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
MEGHAN INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE. ALLEN HAD TO YOU
AT THAT THE DAUGHTERS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH. IF YOU'RE
A HUSBAND I'M NOT ELIGIBLE. I
HARDLY KNOW HER FOR HAVE. WITH
BACK. THROUGH BEFORE AND DURING
THE PANDEMIC. BUT HER SITUATION
HAS WORKED AS A FAMILY
REPUBLICAN CALLED IT. AND REDUCE
INCOME. DUE TO JOB LOSS- WHY I'M
HERE BECAUSE WE NEED A PERMANENT
EQUITABLE SOLUTION THAT
ADDRESSES THE LONGSTANDING ISSUE
UP WOULDN'T THE CURING OF MY
COMMUNITY. AND THIS IS WHY WE
NEED TO LOOK FOR ALL. AND
INVESTMENT TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO ALL IMMIGRANTS HELP ALL
COMMUNITY SIDE IMPROVED OUR
ECONOMY AND HELP THE WEATHER
CRISIS AND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN BUT
BY ONE WORD WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING. SO WE STRONGLY
URGE THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO GO FURTHER THAN
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS ALLOCATED
AN OLD BUDGET. BY EXPANDING THE
THOUGHT BENEFITS CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL AGES REGARDLESS OF WHAT
IMMIGRATION STATUS NO EXCEPTIONS
MIKE GLEASON. THANK LOADING-
THIS IS THE TIME FOR OUR STATE
THAT CHAMPION EQUITABLE POLICIES
ANDPUT FORTH A DIFFERENT VISION
FOR OUR NATION ONE WHERE ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THE FOOD THEY
NEED. THANK. YOU KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBER FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO J. BURKE.
DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT AND-
RELATIONS FOR THE- STUDENT A-
COMMISSION. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ARAMBULA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY WE KNOW FROM
NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT PUTIN
SECURITY IS A WIDESPREAD AND
GROWING CHALLENGE OUR COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES YOUR STUDENT
SERVICE THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION HAS FOUND THAT ONE
OUT OF THREE STUDENTS REPORT
BEING SECURE AND IT'S DOING
SURVEYS THAT WE CONDUCTED FROM
THE ONSET OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT'S CLEAR THAT THESE
CHALLENGES. I'VE ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED. RELATIVELY FEW
ELIGIBLE COLLEGE STUDENTS
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS FOR
WHICH THEY QUALIFY. WHAT DATA IS
LIMITED IN THIS AREA AND I'LL
COME BACK TO THAT IN A MOMENT
WHEN CDS AS ISSUED A REPORT ON
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS ESTIMATED
TO RECEIVE CALFRESH. THEY FOUND
THAT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE LIKELY
AND ROLLED. HOWEVER THAT'S OUT
OF AS MANY AS FOUR HUNDRED TO
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. THAT ARE ESTIMATED TO
BE ELIGIBLE. MR NEED COMMISSION
CAN BE NO WORKER IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT INCLUDED
STUDENTS CAMPUS BASIC NEEDS
LEADERS RESEARCH EXPERTS AND
STAFF FROM COUNTY AND STATE.
AGENCIES TO HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHY DO ARE NOT BACK.
THE BENEFIT AND I. ME THROUGH
WHICH WE BETTER THEM CALPERS
SUPPORT. OKAY A BRIEF WE SHARE A
FEW OF HIGH LEVEL TAKEAWAY AND
WRECKED. THAT WILL BE INCLUDED
IN OUR THAT THE FACT YOU MAKE
EEK- SO THEY IS A PRE WE'VE GOT
NOT RELEASED THE REPORT AND LOOK
FOR TO JERRY AN ADVANCE CALL OF
THAT. ART INCLUDING PARTNERS AT
COUNTY STATE EIGHT- AND THE
RECOMMENDED. HERE TO WORK-
SIGNIFICANT REVISION THAT WE
MADE AND- IN LIGHT OF. THEIR
FEEDBACK IN RESPONSE AS WE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THEM SINCE
THE CONCLUSION OF THE WORKER
PROCESS ITSELF. SO FIRST I'M TO
START WITH SOME OF THE TAKEAWAYS
AND WHY ARE SO FEW COLLEGE
STUDENTS- COURT ELIGIBLE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING CALFRESH. WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE FIRST THAT
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATIONS HAVE
BEEN SPECIFICALLY STRUCTURED TO
KEEP STUDENTS OUT OF THE SNAP
PROGRAM. STUDENTS MUST QUALIFY
FOR AN EXEMPTION IN ORDER TO
APPLY. FOR YOURS THIS IS PUT AN
EXTRA BURDEN OF PROOF ON
STUDENTS TO NOT ONLY. APPLY AND
MEET FINANCIAL ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ANY OTHER
APPLICANT WOULD. BUT TO ALSO
DEMONSTRATE AND ENSURE THAT THE
COUNTY RECOGNIZES THEIR
EXEMPTION FROM THE STUDENT WILL
. AND OF COURSE THIS MEANS THAT
EACH TIME THERE'S A CHANGE IN
POLICY ON HOW THOSE TWO
APPLICATIONS CAN BE PROCESSED
WATER RESULTING FROM FEDERAL OR
STATE GUIDANCE. THIS MUST BE
COMMUNICATED ACROSS. ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WHICH CAMERAS IN
INCOME AND PUT. OF SUCH. LIKE
ALLOWING STUDENTS STOP THIRD
THEIR. OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND
THE TIMING OF STUDENTS MOVING
INTO NEW COUNTIES ALSO CREATES A
LARGE AND RECURRING SEASONAL
SURGES APPLICATIONS. AT ALL
ACADEMIC TERM BEGINS MANY
COUNTIES WITH LARGE STUDENT
POPULATIONS YOUR WAY OF
APPLICATIONS THAT THAT AT THE
SAME TIME. THIS CREATES REAL
WORKLOAD ISSUES FOR STAFF THAT
RESULT IN LONGER PROCESSING
TIMES FOR STUDENT APPLICANTS. SO
NOW THAT I'VE LAID OUT A FEW OF
THE ISSUES THAT HINDER STEVEN
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED. TO HELP BETTER SERVE
STUDENTS. WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN PILOT NEW
APPROACHES THAT WOULD HELP
SUPPORT STUDENT ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM- ONE OF WHICH BEING-
ESTABLISHING REGIONAL HUBS THE
COUNTIES AS IS CURRENTLY
UTILIZED IN THE CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS. IT WOULD
HAVE A SPECIALLY TRAINED TEAM OF
COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKERS OKAY
FONG PROCESSING STUDENT
APPLICATIONS FROM WITHIN THEIR
CONSORTIUM. AS CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS EXPANDING ACCESS
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANT AND
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES. WE
WOULD ALSO SUGGEST CONSIDERING
THE USE ON A PILOT BASIS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION
JUST URBAN DOCUMENTED STUDENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY PROVIDING THEIR
INFORMATION TO THE STATE FOR
FINANCIALLY PURPOSES. THIS CULD
ULTIMATELY SERVE AS A PILOT FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
CONSIDER MAKING THIS IN
PRACTICE- AVAILABLE WITH THE USE
OF THE FREE APPLICATION FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID. THE PASS
UP. SO THAT THEY ARE ALSO
CONSIDERED FOR SNAP BENEFITS
WITHOUT SUBMITTING AN ADDITIONAL
APPLICATION. WE CAN ALSO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN BETTER LEVERAGE DATA
AND A FEW KEY WAYS. FIRST WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA MUST
START TO TRACK ACTUAL AND NOT
ESTIMATED STUDENT APPLICATIONS
AND ACCEPTANCE INTO THE PROGRAM.
WE CAN ALSO LOOK TO SEE HOW WE
CAN AT A MINIMUM PRE POPULATE
THE CALPERS SHOP LOCATION WITH
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION DATA.
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
REDUNDANT QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE
ASKING STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
UTILIZED FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEAL DATA FROM OUR K. TWELVE
PARTNERS TO IDENTIFY STUDENTS
LIKELY ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH AT
THE MATRICULATION TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND OF COURSE WE MUST
ALSO SUPPORTER COUNTIES IN THE
WORK OF PROCESSING APPLICATIONS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD USE THE
FUNDING FORMULA TO APPROPRIATELY
RECOGNIZE COUNTIES EXISTING
WORKLOADS AND CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR COUNTIES TO GENERATE AND
PROCESS ADDITIONAL CASES. WE
MUST ALSO EXPAND COMMUNICATIONS
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
CONSISTENTLY IMPLEMENTING. NEW
ACCESS POLICIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS ALL OF OUR IT DETECTS.
FINALLY A BENEFITS ARE ONLY
HELPFUL TO STUDENTS TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
UTILIZE THEM. WE SHOULD ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN UTILIZE THEIR
CALPERS BENEFITS ON CAMPUS BY
DIRECTING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO ACCEPT EBT CARDS
CAMPUS BEAUTY DINING FACILITIES.
GROWING NUMBER CAMPUS THAT IS
ALREADY DONE THIS AND R. OR
TAKING STEPS TO DO SO BUT
THERE'S MORE WORK THAT CAN BE
DONE. SO THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS FOR TODAY AND WE OF
COURSE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE OUR
PARTNERS WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION. AT LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO MOVE FORWARD IN
BETTER SERVING OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I'M INTERESTING
INTERESTED IN THE YOU KNOW THERE
IS DEFINITELY A SHORTFALL IN OUR
FOOD BANK- ALLOCATION THIS YEAR
AND I'M WONDERING WHAT WE CAN DO
OR WHAT ARE WE DOING TO. MAKE
SURE THAT THAT GAP IS FILLED- I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE FOOD AND SECURITY WILL
THINK THAT THAT JUST YOU KNOW
FAMILIES GO TO FOOD BANKS AND
THAT ARE ARE DESPERATE BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE. ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
VISITING THE FOOD BANKS AS WELL
AND THEIR FULL FOOD AD SECURE
WE HAVE A LOT OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT ARE PROVIDING.
FOOD FOR THEIR STUDENTS- SOLD SO
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR THE
GAP FUNDING DO YOU HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH AS TO HOW
MUCH THAT IS AND WHAT. ARE YOU
DOING OR WHAT ARE WE DOING I
WOULD WE NEED TO DO TO BE ABLE
TO FIVE FILL THAT GAP I KNOW
ADDING MORE MONEY WOULD BE GREAT
BY TODD HAVE THERE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS TO- BRIDGING
THAT GAP. IT IS A QUESTION. IT
ARE YOU ASKING ME WHAT ELSE WE
CAN DO OTHER THAN FUNDS. YES YES
THANK YOU AT. WELL THERE
CERTAINLY WHERE WE ARE CERTAINLY
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH- WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION- AND ALL OF
THE RELEVANT TAB- BUDGET LEADERS
. HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY KIND OF
RESPONSES AS TO YOU KNOW ARE
THEY OPEN TO THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- YEAH THERE'S CERTAINLY-
THERE IS ROOM IN THERE
CERTAINLY. AMENABLE TO- MORE
FUNDING I MEAN OF COURSE I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE MINIMAL I WANT TO
SAY YES. THAT THEY'RE GOING.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT OF
COURSE- BUT- THAT IS THAT IS NOT
THAT USUALLY NOT HOW NOT THROUGH
THE RESPONSES THAT WE GET RIGHT
AROUND AND THIS TIME IN FEBRUARY
BUT- WE DEFINITELY WANNA AND
WANNA YES ANSWERS WHILE I'M
THERE THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE TO
FUNDING FOOD- SO- YEAH I HOPE I
HOPE I'M ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION
YES YES AND- DO YOU HAVE AN
ESTIMATE AS TO HOW MUCH THE
SHORTFALL IS OR THE- THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT YOU NEED TO CLOSE
THAT GAP. YEAH SO WHAT I WAS AS
I SAID THERE SO RIGHT NOW WE GET
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
IN CALHOUN- AND- THERE IS. WE
ARE ASKING TO INCREASE THAT TO
SIXTY MILLION ON GOINGS ON
INCREASE OF FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT A ONE TIME ASK.
THE GOVERNOR'S ALREADY SUGGEST
THAT PROPOSED A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR. ONE TIME ASK IN JANUARY
AND WE'RE ASKING TO INCREASE
THAT BY TEN MILLION. SO WITH ALL
THE MATH DONE THAT WOULD BE A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION FOR
CALIPHATE FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- AND- OF
COURSE THERE IS THAT BUT THAT'S
NOT THE ONLY THING THT'S GONNA
SOLVE HUNGER AND- TO AND TO THE-
TO MEET THE GAP OF THE EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS ENDING WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHEN THEY'LL AND IT
COULD END IS. AS EARLY AS THE
MID APRIL BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN
RIGHT NOW WHEN THE- FEDERAL A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDS.
BUT WERE WE- THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE- SORT OF A MITIGATION-
THERE TO- KIND OF. HM THAT'S IT
THAT'S IT IT'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE GAP- WHEN THOSE EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS AND WE THINK THAT.
THAT THE STATE SHOULD CONSIDER A
PHASE OUT APPROACH THAT PREVENTS
YOU KNOW THAT THAT SHOCKING
LOSS- JUST TO SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS- BUT- YOU KNOW. AGAIN
WITH IT WE NEED. A VARIETY OF
INPUTS FROM CALFRESH- TO- IN
FOOD BANKS AND- JUST EIGHTY
INCREASES ALL AROUND AND ALL OF
THE CASH AID PROGRAMS FROM TAX
CREDITS- TO- CAL WORKS. RIGHT
WELL JUST TO PUT IT INTO
CONTEXT- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TALKING NUMBERS AND
DOLLARS AND CENTS HEREBY. WHAT
DO YOU KNOW I WANT TO BRING IT
MORE TO THE HUMAN VALUE OF THIS
WHAT HAPPENS ON APRIL. YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST THE NUMBER- YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE YOUR SERVICES LOOK
LIKE AFTER A BILL IF WE DON'T-
STEP UP AND GIVE YOU. YOU KNOW
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. WHAT IS
THE IMPACT ON. YOU KNOW THE. THE
OF COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. WITH THE IN IS
FOR HIM MILLION DOLLARS MONTH.
IN FOOD. OKAY I'M NUMBER OF P.
NUMBER FAMILY THAT YOUR SERVICE.
THERE IS SIR OKAY YOUNG THERE- I
CAN GET THAT NUMBER TO YOU IT'S
ACTUALLY AND I KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE REPORTS IN THE SENATE
BUDGET- REPORT I CAN PULL THAT
UP. AND ANSWER THAT FOR YOU IN A
IN A MATTER OF MOMENTS OR I CAN
GET BACK TO YOU ON THE- I THINK
WHAT MIGHT MY THE OBJECTIVE TO
THE QUESTION IS TO BRING THE
HUMAN VALUE TO THIS AND- YOU
KNOW OUR- TO APPEAL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST A NUMBER ON THE ON
THE- YOU KNOW THE- IT'S NOT JUST
A LINE ITEM ON THE BUDGET- THESE
ARE ACTUAL FOLKS THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED NOT JUST FAMILIES BUT-
YOU KNOW WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
HOW. YOU KNOW WE WANT TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS WE WANT TO SUPPORT.
EVERYONE IN THE FOOD AND
SECURITY EXCEPT WHEN I WORKED.
IN THIS COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NUMBERS AND
SENSE WHICH IS YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING BUT I
THINK THE HUMAN VALUE IS ONE OF
THEM CRITICALLY. IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW IF THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO
END IN APRIL SO THAT'S WHERE I'M
THAT'S MY PURPOSE OF THE- FOR
THE QUESTIONS. YEAH APPRECIATE
THAT AND IT MEAN IT IS IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT- NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS- AND- IF YOU WAIT
TOO. LONG AFTER MOMENT CANCELING
NINE. THAT NUMBER FOR YOU BUT IT
IT WHEN IT WAS OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND IN A REPORT
IT- IT WAS. IT WAS NOTED HOW
APPROXIMATELY HOW MUCH FOR HOW
MANY FAMILIES- INVOLVES AND OR
JUST TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WHILE YOU DO THAT-
YOU KNOW ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN OUR DISTRICTS ARE
DOING FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS- I MEAN
THANKSGIVING WAS. IT FROM MY
DISTRICT WAS THE BIGGEST EVER HE
TO PUT IT INTO CONTEXT I USUALLY
WOULD DO ABOUT- FOUR TO FIVE
HUNDRED- TURKEYS AND FOOD
BASKETS FOR FOLKS THIS LAST YEAR
WE DID THREE THOUSAND. AND SOLD
BACK THAT INCREASE IN IN MY AREA
JUST FOR THE HOLIDAYS WAS SO
SIGNIFICANT THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
THANKFULLY WE WEREN'T- WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO TURN ANYBODY AWAY BUT I
WANT TO. SHOW THE IMPACT- TO
THESE PROGRAMS ENDING IN IN
APRIL AND HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE TURNED AWAY IF YOU
TURN PEOPLE AWAY- YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE- LIKE I
SAID IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
TALK BUT BUDGET IN DOLLARS AND
CENTS BUT- IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE I THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE TALK ABOUT HOW MANY
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED. I AGREE WITH YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOU POINTING THAT OUT
THAT WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT. ABOUT
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF INSTEAD OF
NUMBERS THAT IS- REALLY
IMPORTANT- AND- WE CAN TAKE UPON
HIM AS A SORT OF INCOME AND-
CLOSE TO GETTING THAT. NO I AM
TRYING NOT THE YOU KNOW IT'S NO
PRESSURE AYE AGAIN FOR ME THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO MAKE IT IS THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ACTUAL
IMPACT. I'VE DONE IT FOR YOU
SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY AN
AVERAGE OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE RECEIVED AN AVERAGE OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX DOLLARS PER
MONTH IN EMERGENCY NUTRITION
ALLOTMENTS. SO ONE POINT NINE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS AYE THAT'S
NOT I CAN GIVE YOU THE EXACT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THIS
HOUSEHOLD NOT ENOUGH. MULTIPLY
THAT BY YOU KNOW TWO THREE FOUR
PEOPLE AND IT'S A IT'S A
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU
WHAT I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT QUESTION WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT OCCURS
WHEN THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDS TO THE EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENT WE'VE HEARD THAT
THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PER MONTH WHICH WILL NO
LONGER BE GOING TO CALIFORNIANS
AND I'M WONDERING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION OR
PLAN IF- THEY ARE TO DISCONTINUE
THAT AFTER APRIL SIXTEENTH
HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT.
SURE SO I'M A LOT OF THIS REALLY
IS DRIVEN BY A FEDERAL
DECLARATION OF AN EMERGENCY
RIGHT- BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS. SORT OF
BIG PICTURE IN THE VARIOUS A
SUPPORT THAT HELP PROVIDE ACCESS
TO FOOD SO FOR INSTANCE THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
THAT WE WERE JUST SPEAKING OF IN
TERMS OF- THE- THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THOSE DOLLARS FOR FELT
CALHOUN. IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
LIFT UP BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
GIVES OUR LOCAL FOOD BANKS THE
ABILITY TO PURCHASE FOOD THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
RIGHT WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOODS AND
THIS ACTUALLY HELPS ACCOMPLISH
THAT- AND IT ALSO HELPS TO BOOST
LOCAL ECONOMIES RIGHT WHEN WE'RE
SUPPORTING LOCAL GROWERS AND
SUCH SO IT YES. IT WOULD BE A
GREAT LOSS OF FOR EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS BUT WE ARE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT- OTHER AREAS
WHERE WE CAN ALSO FURTHER
REINFORCE. I WOULD JUST PUT IT
ON THE SCALE OF ITS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PER MONTH THAT'S ALMOST
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
YEAR. AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
INVESTMENT PURSES. FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT OUR FAMILIES ARE
GETTING CURRENTLY AND JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WERE. REACTING TO THE
APPROPRIATE SCALE- FOR WHAT'S ON
THE HORIZON. I WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION NOW TO- KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD'S QUESTION
REGARDING- NOT RECEIVING A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS INCREASE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE. HE WAS HOPING
TO ASK BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
FOR A RESPONSE TO THAT. AS IT
APPEARS FROM WHAT WAS PRESENTED
AS IF. THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
MATCHING FUNDS FOR US IF WE HAS
THE STATE WORK TO INCREASE THAT
CONTRIBUTION- PER THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS GOING UP SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE I'M HOPING. YOU
CAN PROVIDE COMMENTS TO ADDRESS
THAT. TIGER WOODS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN TAKE THE FIRST
PART- I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE
ARE RECOGNIZED THAT THERE IS A
NEED TO RE EVALUATE THAT
EXISTING METHODOLOGY AND THAT
WAS IN PLACE. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AS MY COUNTERPARTS TO
DSS MENTIONED- AMANDA CWDM MATCH
AND THE PANDEMIC. ARE WOMEN IN
OUR ABILITY TO GO AHEAD AND RE
EVALUATE THAT AND HAVE. A
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WHAT THAT UNDERLYING BASIS FOR
THAT METHODOLOGY WOULD BE. AND
WE ARE AT OUR INTENT IS TO
ENGAGE AGAIN AND NOT AS WE START
TO GET OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
AGAIN. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT C.
W. A. R. CAN HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE BASIS FOR THEIR
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST. I
WE WOULD BE OPEN TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION. I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE TO PROVIDE A DSS THE CHANCE
TO COMMENT IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
AS WELL. I THINK FURTHER TO ADD
- WITH THAT I WILL COMMENT-
KATHY SANDERLING DONALD SAID
THIS COULD POTENTIALLY HELP US
TO HIRE SIXTY FOUR HUNDRED
WORKERS AND AS THEY WERE GOING
THROUGH ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS PER WEEK
DURING THE PEAK OF THE PANDEMIC
IT IS APPARENT THAT THERE WILL
BE CONTINUED. NEED FOR US TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE WORKERS TO
EVALUATE WITHIN THIS PROGRAM AND
WILL AND MY QUESTIONS WERE
ACTUALLY FOCUSING HOUSE ON WHAT
JAKE BREMNER SAID WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. EARLIER WE HEARD
ABOUT TO TAKE UP RATES AND WE
HEARD THAT CALFRESH ROUGHLY HAS
A 70% TAKE UP RATE AND YET IF
YOU WOULD DO THE MATH PER WHAT
JAKE PRESENTED TO US THAT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN.
THOUSAND STUDENTS OUT OF-
PROXIMALLY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE. WHERE TO TAKE A BREAK
MUCH CLOSER 225230% AND THAT
REALLY SCREAMS TELL ME ABOUT THE
FOOD INSECURITY THAT SO MANY
STUDENTS. IN HIGHER EDUCATION
MUST BE FACING TODAY AND I WOULD
BRING UP MUCH LIKE WE DO WITH
AND HEALTH CARE AND FOCUSING ON
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE
SIMILARLY SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
EDUCATION AND- THE STUDENTS
HUNGER OFTENTIMES WILL PRECLUDE
THEIR- ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY BE
THE STUDENTS THAT THEY NEED TO
BE. SO I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION HOW IT
RECEIVED THAT STUDENT AID
COMMISSION'S TESTIMONY AND IF
THEY HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT.
SIR THIRD THE DEPARTMENT AND HAS
PARTICIPATED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT LED TO THE
STOCK- REPORT HOWEVER IT'S A
FAIRLY EARLY AND WE HAVE NOT
CONDUCTED A COMPLETE ANALYSIS
BUT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE IN THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH BOTH THE SECOND. THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE INVOLVED
BUT CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE CALLING OUT GERMAN
ARAMBULA IN TERMS OF. THE NEED
TO CONNECT STUDENTS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PUT. THERE THERE
WILL BE MORE TO COME FROM MY
OFFICE ON THE SUBJECT LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD. AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME REQUEST
FROM THE CHAIRMAN THERE ARE TWO
SPECIFIC REQUESTS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE OF THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
ARE LISTED ON PAGE FORTY ONE.
I'D FIRST LIKE TO ASK KINDLY FOR
DSS FOR AN ANALYSIS REGARDING
CURRENT CALFRESH ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. AND IF THERE IS A
QUANTITATIVE SHORTFALL IN WHAT
IS PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. AND WHAT WILL
BE NECESSARY FOR US TO MEET
CASELOAD AND PROGRAMMATIC
DEMANDS. TO ASSURE THAT THE
CURRENT LAW CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
APPROPRIATELY. SECOND I WOULD
LIKE AN ESTIMATE ON ACHIEVING
FOOD FOR ALL AS OUTLINED WITHIN
THE AGENDA. AND THIRD FOR A
DISCUSSION WITH THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO SEE
WHAT MIGHT BE VIABLE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS NEXT. WITH THAT
WE I'D LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
THE PANELISTS FOR ISSUE FOUR WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE
WHERE WE WILL HAVE FOR
PRESENTERS WE WILL BEGIN WITH
JULIE MICK QUIDI. HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ACTING BRANCH CHIEF
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. FOLLOWED BY
ERIN CARSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FLORIDA'S MORE ALICE
WITH THE L. A- AND KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CWD EIGHT. LET'S
BEGIN WITH MISS MCWETHY WHEN
YOU'RE READY. HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. THE
HEARING AGENDA INCLUDES A
COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW OF THESE
PROGRAMS BEGINNING ON PAGE FORTY
THREE SO I'LL TRY TO FOCUS MY
REMARKS SPECIFICALLY ON THE
QUESTIONS ASKED AND LIMIT MY
PRESENTATION TO FINANCE THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PROVIDED A SIGNIFICANT AND
HISTORIC TOTAL OF MORE THAN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE GRANT FUNDS
TO COUNTIES ANDTRIBES TO
ESTABLISH CONTINUE AND EXPAND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
CLIENTS OF LOCAL SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES. INVESTMENTS FOR ME TO
EXPAND MY COWARDS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM HOUSING
AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM
HOME SAFE PROGRAM AND THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY AND WE HOUSING
STRATEGY AS WELL AS TO ESTABLISH
THE. COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. AB ONE THIRTY FIVE
FURTHER EXPANDED THE SCOPE OF
EXISTING PROGRAMSAND THEIR
POTENTIAL REACH IN PARTICULAR
FOR FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING
THOSE NOT IN RECEIPT. OF AN
EVICTION NOTICE IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE BUDGET ENACTMENT
CDSS BEGAN DEVELOPING GUIDANCE
RELATED TO THE STATUTORY CHANGES
MADE BY AB ONE THIRTY FIVE. AND
THROUGH ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT THE DEPARTMENT
EVALUATED LESSONS LEARNED AND
PROMISING PRACTICES WHICH WERE
USED TO STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND
PROGRAM GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES PREPARED TO
SCALE THEIR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE THE
TREMENDOUS FUNDING EXPANSIONS.
THAT WERE MADE THIS BUDGET YEAR
. CDSS HAS ANNOUNCED THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO SUPPORT
AND STABILIZE FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
HOUSING INSTABILITY WHICH ARE
EXPECTED TO SERVE NEARLY TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FAMILIES THROUGH
THE HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM AND
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS IN
ADDITION TO THESE FAMILIES PRO
DECENT FAMILY PROGRAMS CDSS HAS
MADE OVER NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO SERVE
SENIORS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND GRANTEES
EXPECTED SERVE THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SENIORS
AND ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES
THROUGH THE HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM. AND
THE HOME STATE PROGRAMS OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS WITH THESE
HISTORIC FUNDING EXPANSIONS.
CDSS ALSO UTILIZED A PORTION OF
THE FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO
ESTABLISH COMPREHENSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE INITIATIVES
WHICH WE LAUNCHED EARLY IN EARLY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THESE
ARE DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
EXPANSION AND GROWTH OF THE CDSS
FUNDED HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE AND WE'RE
BASED UPON THE NEEDS IDENTIFIED
BY COUNTIES TRIBES AND ALASKA
REYES STAKEHOLDERS- HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS IS INTRINSICALLY
CONNECTED. TO ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
AS MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ACROSS THE HOMELESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM AND IDENTIFIED HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S AN AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE AND FAMILY SEEKING OR IN
RECEIPT OF CAL WORKS BENEFITS
ARE AMONGST THOSE WHO ARE MOST
ACUTELY IMPACTED BY THIS
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
THREATENING THEIR ABILITY TO
SUSTAIN AND RETAIN HOUSING LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS
REQUIRE NOT JUST HOUSING PEOPLE
WHO BECOME HOMELESS BUT ALSO
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS BEFORE
IT OCCURS AND A CONTINUUM OF
SOLUTIONS IS CRITICAL TO MEETING
MEANS. THE MEETING FAMILIES
WHERE THEY ARE ACTING IN THE
INTERSECTION OF BROADER SUPPORT
THROUGH SOCIAL SAFETY NETS
INCLUDING PREVENTION ASSISTANCE
. WHICH IS WHY INCREASE TO SHARE
THE AB ONE THIRTY FIVE EXPANDED
THE SCOPE OF THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS FUNDED BY
CDSS TO INCLUDE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION INCLUDING FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS NOT IN RECEIPT
OF AN EVICTION NOTICE. GRANTEES
ARE BEGINNING TO IMPLEMENT AND
EXPAND PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE THESE
ADDITIONAL HOUSING INTERVENTIONS
AND CDSS LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH COUNTIES
AND TRIBES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
SOLICIT FEEDBACK. AND EVALUATE
THE IMPACT OF THESE RECENT
CHANGES TO CONTINUOUSLY SEEK TO
IMPROVE PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
SHIFTING OVER TO OUR NEWS
PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM. THIS THIS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED BY AB
ONE SEVENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THE STATE BUDGET
APPROPRIATED EIGHT HUNDRED FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION TO PRESERVE AND
EXPAND AND BUILT IN SENIOR CARE
SETTINGS THAT SERVE AS A SITE
AND HAPPY. APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS INCLUDING THOSE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING ARE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS IN JANUARY FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WAS MADE AVAILABLE VIA I
REQUEST FOR APPLICATION OR RFA
FOR CAPITAL EXPANSION PROJECTS.
AN INFORMATIONAL WEBINAR WALKING
THROUGH THE RFA WAS PRESENTED IN
EARLY FEBRUARY AND INCLUDED OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WEAPON ARE
PARTICIPANTS INTAKE DATE OVER
THREE HUNDRED APPLICANTS HAVE
REQUESTED FORMAL CONSULTATIONS
AND ARE WORKING WITH
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIALIST TO
FURTHER DEVELOP THEIR PROJECTS
AND SUBMIT APPLICATIONS. WE ARE
MONITORING THESE CONSULTATIONS
CLOSELY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS AND
APPLICATIONS THAT WILL BE
SUBMITTED AND THE NUMBER OF NEW
BAGS OR UNITS ESTABLISHED BY THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM
ULTIMATELY DEPENDS ON THE TYPES
OF FACILITIES ARE PROJECTS THAT
ARE APPROVED AND FUND AND
HOWEVER EARLY ESTIMATES PROJECT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND BEDS
WILL BE CREATED. AND THREE
THOUSAND THAT'S WILL. BE
PRESERVED THROUGH THESE BONDS.
I'M WITH TO THE PRESERVATION
FUNDS ACROSS THE STATE- CD SEE
THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM INCLUDES A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT A FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE OPERATING
SUBSIDY PAYMENTS TO PRESERVE
BEDS FOR SSI RECIPIENTS. IN
LICENSE ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES AND THREE COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING SURVEY DATA WE
ESTIMATE. THAT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SSI. WHO
WERE LIVING IN EXISTING LICENSED
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES
STILL USING AN ASSUMPTION OF
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS. OF
OPERATING SUBSIDY PAYMENT THE
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS COULD
BE SPREAD OUT IN VARIOUS WAYS
FOR EXAMPLE A PAYMENT COULD BE
MADE TO EVERY FACILITY IN THE
STATE FOR EVERY SSI RECIPIENTS.
THE OPERATING SUBSIDY PAYMENTS
WOULD LAST FOR ABOUT FOUR MONTHS
HOWEVER IF A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
MONTHLY PAYMENT WERE SPREAD OVER
FIVE YEARS THE FUNDING WOULD
SERVE ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS. RECEIVING SSI. AND
FINE- THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
FOR PRESERVATION FUNDS IS STILL
BEING FINALIZED HOWEVER WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT WE WOULD USE
THAT ESTIMATE OF THE PROPORTION
OF THE BEDS AVAILABLE AND
EXISTING LICENSE FACILITIES
CURRENTLY SERVING INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING SSI. NOW CONCLUDE THAT
. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
ERIN CARSON WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HEY ERIN CARSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS MOMENT
THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM LOTUS MORALIS WITH THE
L. A. L. THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS
NUNEZ MORALES WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND YOUR AGENDA INDICATES AND
THAT WE JUST DISCUSSED THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
RECEIVED VERY SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THEIR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. BECAUSE OF THIS WE THINK
YOUR FOCUS TODAY ON OVERSIGHT
AND CONTINUED FOCUS ON OVERSIGHT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING THE
OUTCOMES THEY ARE PRODUCING AND
WHETHER THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
ANY CHALLENGES GETTING THE MONEY
OUT FOR GETTING THE PROGRAM SET
UP. AND THAT THOSE CHALLENGES
CAN BE ADDRESSED QUICKLY. WE
WOULD ALSO MENTION THAT OUR
OFFICE RECENTLY PUBLISHED OUR
INITIAL COMMENTS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PACKAGE OF
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS WHICH AND
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND- PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE. ONE OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS FROM THE REPORT THAT
IS MOST RELEVANT TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY IS THE FOCUS ON
COORDINATION. TO ENSURE THAT THE
ENTIRE PORTFOLIO OF STATE
PROGRAMS RELATED TO HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS WORK EFFECTIVELY
TOGETHER. AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS CLICK INTO THE
OVERALL APPROACH. IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. I'M ON THAT NOTE WE
HAVE REVIEWED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR POSITIONS TO
ASSIST WITH THE HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
WHICH IS NOTED ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. AND WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
AS WE SEE IT AS AN IMPORTANT.
BOTH FOR OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS
COORDINATION EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD'S WITH
CEDAR BDA. FRAN HELLO AGAIN-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY
FROM GOING TO COUNTY WTA. THE
FIRST QUESTION THE INTERNET IS
RELATED TO HOW- COUNTIES ARE
DOING WITH THE FUNDING AND- I
FIRST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
EXPANSION FROM THE CURRENT YEAR
ARE TRULY IMPRESSIVE THAT AND WE
WERE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
RECOGNITION THAT COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES ARE IN A
UNIQUE POSITION UNDERSTAND
HOUSING RELATED NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WE
SERVING HEALTH PRACTICE SORRY. I
IN CAN'T TELL WELFARE CAL WORKS
AND THE BILL PROTECTION AS WELL
AND THAT SIGNIFICANT VALUE THAT
EACH STAFF OFFERS TO SENIORS AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES. AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE DISCUSSED THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE MAKE IT ALL
OF THOSE UNDERLYING PROGRAMS ARE
SIMPLY NOT GOING TO WORK IF
SOMEONE IS ANNOUNCED OR AT RISK
OF ADDICTION. OR HOMELESSNESS
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK AS YOU'VE
HEARD AND NOW ANTICIPATE ALL SAY
THEY COUNTIES ONLY RECENTLY BEEN
ABLE TO BEGIN SPENDING THE
INCREASES BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO
HAVE AN ALLOCATION GRADING. AND
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO SPEND THE
FUNDING AND I ESPECIALLY THE
CHANGES THAT WERE ADOPTED
RELATED TO PREVENTION ESPECIALLY
EVICTION PREVENTION. AND SO- WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE ALL COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS LETTERS FOR
EACH OF THE FUNDING- STREAMS FOR
EACH PROGRAM THEY TOOK TIME FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP AN
ISSUE- AS YOU KNOW AND THE LAST
ONE FOR BRINGING FAMILY'S HOME
IN OUR CHILD WELFARE AREA WAS
POSTED ABOUT A WEEK AND A HALF
AGO ON FEBRUARY A LOT. OF THE
FAMED OUR OUR PARTNERS THE TVS
THAT'S WORK CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT
IN THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET AND
THE HOUSING AREA IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NO WORKS EXCEPTION
EVERYONE OF THE PROGRAM RECEIVED
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE SAYS AND
THIS IS ALSO AN AREA OF
RELATIVELY RECENT EXPANSION FOR
CVS ANYWAY. SO THEY DEFINITELY
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE FUNDING WAS
AVAILABLE AND THAT THE NEW RULES
WERE PROPERLY COMMUNICATED IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE. THAT IT TOOK
AWHILE EVEN THOUGH IT HAD BEEN
FOR A TRADING AT TIMES THINK FOR
ALL OF THAT. I SAY THT THE THAT
YOU MAY RECALL OUR- OF MORE YEAR
PERIOD. WHICH WE APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH OF THE- IN IT TURNS.
WAS A REALLY GOOD BOTH AS WELL
DEFINITELY ROLLING FOR. AND THEM
OVER. YEARS NOW THAT COUNTIES
HAVE THE- ON HOW MUCH THEY'RE
WORTH THE- THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERTAKE THE PROCESS OF
AMENDING CONTRACTS LOCALLY WITH
PROVIDERS. ENTERING INTO NEW
CONTRACTS. IN LIGHT OF THE
SUSPENSE OF DENTAL INCREASE SAYS
AND THEN IMPLEMENTING THE NEW
ABILITY TO USE FUNDS ON.
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. I WAS OFF
LAST COMMENT ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AS WELL FROM THE
FLEXIBILITIES OF THE SELECT FEET
. A MAJOR BARRIER TO BEING ABLE
TO SPEND THE FUNDS- CERTAINLY
QUICKLY AND MAYBE AT ALL IN SOME
CASES THOUGH I THINK- SPEED IS
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST ISSUE. IS
JUST- A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK THAT'S AVAILABLE
WE KNOW THAT WE ARE FACING THAT
ISSUE ACROSS THE STATE IT'S NOT
JUST A LARGER URBAN AREA IS
SMALLER COUNTIES RURAL COUNTIES
IN OUR SUBURBAN COUNTIES ALL
REPORT. THAT IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO FIND AVAILABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND ALL SAY
THAT I THINK DURING THE PANDEMIC
EVEN THOUGH THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM WHICH WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT HAS BEEN A VERY GOOD
THING FOR RENTERS- FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AFFECTED OR
ARE HOMELESS. I MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO FIND A PLACE FOR
THEM IT'S MADE RENTS HIGHER
OVERALL BUT THEY CAN'T FIND A
VACANCY SO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN THE IN THE GENERAL
HOUSING MARKET OR THINGS THAT.
COUNTIES ARE GRAPPLING WITH AS
WELL AS THEY TRY TO FIND A PLACE
FOR SOMEONE TO WHATEVER- I WILL
SAY THAT WE'RE JUST SO GRATEFUL
AS WELL TO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
SECURED. A MAJOR CHANGE TO
ENABLE US TO USE FUNDS PRIOR TO
THE RECEIPT OF AN EVICTION
NOTICE WE KNOW THAT AFFECTION IS
SO DAMAGING TO FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN. IT LEADS TO JOB LOSSES
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND- BUT
THE FICTION ACTUALLY LEAD TO JOB
LOSS FOR PEOPLE. CHILDREN HAVE
TO CHANGE ALL OF OUR STARTERS ON
THE SIDEWALK IN A BAG- HERE TO
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. IT'S JUST
A TREMENDOUSLY BAD FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES SO
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. A
FEW THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT LAST
YEAR BUT THAT WE I DIDN'T GET IT
AND WITH LIKE A LOVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION. ARE
GREATER ASSISTANCE IN OBTAINING
OR MAINTAINING HELPING WHICH-
WOULD INCLUDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST MONTH'S RENT SECURITY
DEPOSIT SHORT AND LONG TERM
RENTAL SUBSIDIES SERVICES TO
HELP CLIENTS TRANSITION. FROM
PERHAPS THE SHELTER OR A CAR
INTO HOUSING. THEY MAY NEED
SUPPLIES AND OTHER THINGS ORDER
TO DO TO MAKE THE TRANSIT. I'M
SECURING TEMPORARY OR- HOUSING-
INCLUDING- AT A INTO LEASE
AGREEMENT ARE FOR TEMPER DWELL
UNITS. AND SECURING OUR PROPERTY
THAT WE CAN YEAR OR MAKE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER. ON SERVICE
PROVIDERS YEARS AS TEMPORARY HER
VERGE OF THE HOUSING. ALSO
SOMEONE THAT OUT IN THEIR ON THE
STREET. I'M WORKING WITH
LANDLORDS TO TRY TO INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF HOUSING UNITS AND-
I'M HELPING AWARE THERE ARE
PERHAPS GAPS IN LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. FOR SOMEONE WHO MAY
BE FACING AFFECTION. THERE'S
ANOTHER ARE PROGRAM SPECIFIC
IDEAS THAT WE HAVE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE HAPPY TO SHARE
THOSE AS WELL AS THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'LL JUST. STOP THERE THANK
EVERYONE AGAIN FOR THE HARD WORK
IN PUTTING THINGS OUT AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IT TO REALLY BE ABLE
TO TAKE AND SPEND THESE FUNDS
AND- ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN STAY
HOUSE AND GET HOUSE. IF THEY ARE
ARE HOMELESS NOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I BRING IT BACK UP TO THE-
AND KEEPING HERE THE CHAIR- I
I'D LIKE TO START WITH MISS
MCWETHY A FIGHT CAN- THE SECOND
QUESTION WE GET ASKED IN THE
AGENDA. REALLY WAS REVOLVING
AROUND HOW DSS HAD REPORTED THAT
AN ESTIMATED 85% OF FAMILIES.
WHO ARE TOUCHING THE HOMELESS
SYSTEM. ARE RECEIVING OR WERE
RECENTLY RECEIVING CAL WORKS.
I'M HOPING YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTARY ON WHAT YOU BELIEVE
THIS TELLS US. ABOUT THE NEEDS
WITH AND CAL WORKS AS A PROGRAM.
THAT'S ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
POVERTY AND SHOULD BE HELPING US
TO REDUCE THE INFLOW INTO
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOPING YOU CAN
PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SOAS
MENTIONED IN MY REMARKS HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS IS INTRINSICALLY
CONNECTED TO ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
SO THIS DATA POINT CAME OUT OF
RESEARCH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY LAB. AND STUDIES THAT
THEY WERE DOING AND LOS ANGELES
AND WHAT WE BELIEVE THIS MEANS
IS THAT BECAUSE THAT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA
ISSUE IS REALLY THE DRIVER OF
HOMELESSNESS FAMILIES THAT ARE
RECEIVING THAT HAVE LOW INCOME
ARE AT GREATER RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS. AND FAMILIES THAT HAVE
SMALL CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCED ANY INCIDENCE
HOMELESSNESS PREVIOUSLY ARE AT
GREATER RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS SO WHAT WE CAN SEE FROM
THAT IS THAT. M. BY EIGHT BY.
CONNECTING FAMILIES DIRECTLY TO
HOUSING SUPPORTS THROUGH THE
HUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAM AS WELL AS UTILIZATION
OF LIKE HOW WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WE CAN
DIRECTLY IMPACT AND SUPPORT
FAMILIES AND HOW WORKS PROGRAM.
WITH HOUSING INSTABILITY. I WILL
WITH YOU- THAT I BELIEVE MUCH OF
THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE IS AN
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE BUT WHAT
DOES IT SAY ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
THE ASSISTANCE WITH WHICH THEY
WERE JUST RECEIVING IF WITHIN A
MONTH OF THEM BEING OFF THE
PROGRAM THERE THEN HOMELESS. ARE
THEY RECEIVING ENOUGH SUPPORT.
OR IS THE SUPPORT MAKING IT ON
AFFORDABLE FOR THEM TO RETAIN
AND KEEP THEIR HOUSING AS I
BELIEVE THAT THE FAMILIES WERE
SEEING WHO ARE BECOMING HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE. EITHER CURRENTLY OR
RIGHT BEFORE THEY BECOME
HOMELESS REALLY SCREAMS TO ME
ABOUT A SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED SO WE CAN ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS BEFORE IT
OCCURS. WE'VE HEARD FROM KATHY
SANDERLING MACDONALD HOW IT'S
TREMENDOUSLY BAD FOR FAMILIES
THAT THE TRANSITION THE CHANGING
OF SCHOOLS THE RISK TOWARDS
EMPLOYMENT THAT I'M REALLY
WANTING US TO DIG IN AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT OTHER TYPES OF SUPPORTS
WE CAN. BE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE INTERACTING
WITH THEIR CAL WORK SYSTEMS ARE
NOT BECOMING HOMELESS THAT DATA
POINT IS PARTICULARLY TROUBLING
FOR ME AND ONE IN WHICH I'M
HOPEFUL TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
- TO THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM WITH AND CAL WORKS I
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN HELP TO
STRENGTHEN. THE PROGRAMS ETHER-
FOR THE EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE OR
FOR THE LONG TERM ASSISTANCE AND
I AND I WILL JUST MORE BROADLY
SAY I BELIEVE THIS IS CONTAINED
WITHIN THE EFFORTS WITHIN CALLIE
IN AS WELL THE EFFORTS WE HAVE
FOR INLAND SERVICES TO LOOK
TOWARDS HOUSING TRANSITION
NAVIGATION AND HOUSING DEPOSIT
SAY I WOULD LIKE TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER WE CAN APPLY THAT FOR
FIRST AND LAST MONTH'S RENT AS
WELL FOR THOSE WITH AND CAL
WORKS AND- WOULD ALSO POINT TO
THE- FIFTY BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
BOLD INITIATIVES- AS I BELIEVE
MANY OF THOSE ISSUES RELATED TO
BOTH CHILD AND MATERNAL
OUTCOMES. THAT ARE BEING PUSHED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION CAN BE
IMPROVED TO FOR STRENGTHENING
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND
PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE SO WOULD APPRECIATE A
CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THOSE PROGRAMS GOING FORWARD I
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOUR MEDICAL
WITH THAT. ONE ONE OTHER THING I
WOULD ADD IS JUST DEAD THEN WORK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
TO BRING ON. MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR FAMILIES AND THE
WORK AT THE DEPARTMENT'S DOING
WITH OTHER HOUSING AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
COORDINATED AND THEIR- FAMILIES
IN THE HOW WORK SYSTEM. HAVE
ACCESS TO PERMANENT HOUSING
THROUGH WHETHER IT BE HUNKY
PROJECTS OR OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
WORKING ON- IN A KNOWLEDGE BEING
WET- MISGENDERING DONALD. NOTED
ABOUT THAT FIRST AND LAST
MONTH'S RENT AND FLEXIBILITIES
AND- DIFFERENT BED THE GUIDANCE
THAT WE DID WORK ON OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS DOES INCLUDE-
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS IN ORDER FOR. ALL
FAMILIES SERVED THROUGH THE CAO
WORKS PROGRAM TO HAVE DIRECT
ACCESS TO- HOUSING ASSISTANCE. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I BELIEVE
ALL WERE TRYING TO ASK FOR IS
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
REALITY. AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
ANALYSIS ON WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING SO WE CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS GOING FORWARD. WITH
THAT I WILL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO- ISSUE SIX WHERE WE WILL HAVE
SIX PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL.
BEGINNING WITH ELIANA HI MORE
IT'S IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION
BRANCH CHIEF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
FOLLOWED BY MAUREEN KEFFER CIVIL
RIGHTS ACCESSIBILITY AND RACIAL
EQUITY OFFICE CHIEF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. FOLLOWED BY A NON NON
NAY BECAUSE HE PRINCIPLE PROGRAM
BUDGET ANALYST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. RYAN
ANDERSON WITH THE L. A. O.
JACKIE GONZALEZ WITH POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR IMMIGRANTS DEFENSE
ADVOCATES AND CYNTHIA CHOI CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND
FOUNDING PARTNERS. OF STOP AP I
HATE LET'S BEGIN WITH MISS COMMA
WHAT'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT I'M GLAD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ADRIANA CAME WHEN I AM
THE IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION BRANCH
CHIEF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY. THE BACKGROUND MATERIALS
FOR THE HEARING TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON THE STATUS OF OUR
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AND INFORMATION
REGARDING THE STAFFING REQUESTS
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS. SO IF IT'S HELPFUL I
AM GOING TO BE MOVING STRAIGHT
INTO ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS
POSED FOR THIS ITEM. FIRST
QUESTION WAS. IN REGARDS THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FACING
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE AT THE
PRESENT MOMENT. AND HOW ARE
FUNDED PROGRAMS ARE OPERATING TO
SERVE THESE NEEDS. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING OUR
REFUGEES OF EXPERIENCE FIVE
YEARS OF CONSTANTLY CHANGING
IMMIGRATION POLICIES THAT HAVE
AFFECTED NOT ONLY THOSE SEEKING
TO ENTER AND RECENT NEWCOMERS
BUT ALSO MANY IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE LIVED IN OUR- COMMUNITIES
FOR DECADES. IN A REPORT ISSUED
THIS MONTH THE NATIONAL
MIGRATION POLICY INSTITUTE HAD A
LOT OF FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHICH
COLLECTIVELY THE REPORT STATES.
AND I QUOTE NARROWED GRANT OF
HUMANITARIAN PROTECTION
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT AND MADE
LEGAL IMMIGRATION MORE
DIFFICULT. AS THE REPORT NOTES
THESE FEDERAL ACTIONS BIG AND
SMALL NOT ONLY DISRUPTED THE
LIVES OF IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY THEY ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
WEAKEN THE ENTIRE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IN SOME OF THESE POLICIES
AND REGULATORY CHANGES MAY TAKE
A LONG TIME TO UNDO. TODAY'S
CALIFORNIA'S TODAY CALIFORNIA'S
IMMIGRANTS BASED LONG BACKLOGS
AND EXTENDED WAIT TIMES WHEN
THEY APPLIED FOR IMMIGRATION
BENEFITS SUCH AS DACA AND GREEN
CARDINALS CITIZENSHIP
APPLICATIONS PETITIONS TO BRING
FAMILY MEMBERS FROM ABROAD. AT
THE US CITIZENSHIP AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES ALSO KNOWN
AS USCIS. THE COOPER NINETEEN
RELATED CLOSURES OF FEDERAL
USCIS OFFICES SOCIAL SECURITY
OFFICES IN IMMIGRATION COURTS
EXACERBATED EXISTING DELAYS IN
PROCESSING DOCUMENTS IMMIGRANTS
NEED IN THEIR DAILY LIVES TO
APPLY FOR JOBS. SEEK PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND DELAYED THE
ADJUDICATION OF IMMIGRATION
REMEDIES IN THE COURTS THAT
MIGHT ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN IN
THE UNITED STATES. MANY OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICIES ALONG WITH
GOVERNOR NUISANCE. IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION INVESTMENTS HAVE
EXPANDED ACCESS TO PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND LESSEN THE FEAR OF
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND
DEPORTATION. HOWEVER THE
WILLINGNESS TO TRUST OF
IMMIGRANTS TO ACCESS GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS MAY TAKE LONGER TO BE
BUILT BACK UP. GIVEN THE CRUCIAL
GROW CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT PLAN
OUR SOCIETY AND OUR COMEDY IN
OUR ECONOMY THE GOVERNMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED STATE BUDGET
INVESTMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN THE SAFETY NET FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES ENSURE ACCESS
TO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE OUT TO ENSURE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE ALONG WITH
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS ARE KEY STEPS IN
BUILDING UP THE TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES SEEK TO
SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
. CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING SUPPORT
OF PRO BONO IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES ALSO DEMONSTRATES THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
IMMIGRANTS ARE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR JOURNEY TOWARD US
CITIZENSHIP AND AUTHORIZED
IMMIGRATION STATUS. ULTIMATELY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS MANY
CALIFORNIANS IMMIGRANTS FACED
WITH THE LACK OF A PATHWAY TO
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENCY AND US
CITIZENSHIP. FROM IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION PERSPECTIVE HAVING A
GREEN CARD AND US CITIZENSHIP IS
A KEY STEP THAT ALLOWS FOREIGN
BORN INDIVIDUALS TO FULLY ACCESS
ALL THE FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND SERVICES
AFFORDED TO OUR RESIDENTS. AS WE
KNOW IMMIGRANTS FOREIGN BORN
CALIFORNIANS CRAP COMPRISE 27%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION AND A
THIRD OF OUR LABOR. FORCE WHAT
HAPPENED WHILE CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA HAVE LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS. AS WE RE
IMAGINE LIFE AFTER THE PANDEMIC
AND ARE RESET WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TO ENSURE THE POISON
INTERESTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
INCLUDED IN ALL OF OUR STATE
POLICY CONVERSATIONS AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY HOUSING
EDUCATION HEALTH CARE SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS FOR ALL OF
OUR GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS. TO
CONTINUE OR BEGIN TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. THE SECOND.
QUESTION PERSON THE AGENDA WITH
WITH REGARDS TO THE WHAT ASPECTS
OF THE COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE
NETWORK IS MOST LIMITED. AND
WHERE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GROWTH AND EXPANSION. LAST
YEAR IS CONGRESS CONSIDERED
SEVERAL LARGE PIECES OF FEDERAL
LEGISLATION SUCH AS THE BUILD
BACK BETTER PROPOSAL THERE WAS
HOPE THAT THERE THAT SOME FORM
OF IMMIGRATION REFORM A
POTENTIAL PATHWAY TO LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENCE. RESIDENCY
OR CITIZENSHIP FOR CERTAIN
GROUPS WOULD BE INCLUDED IT
SIGNED INTO LAW. IN PREPARATION
FOR THIS POSSIBILITY THE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHER FUNDERS
BEGAN TO ASSESS THE ABILITY OF
THE COMMUNITY BASED LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDER NETWORK TO
PROVIDE IMMIGRATION SERVICES ON
A LARGER SCALE IF IMMIGRATION
REFORM BECAME A REALITY. IN OUR
ASSESSMENT WE FOUND THAT MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE DESTRUCTION
WROUGHT BY THE PANDEMIC AND ARE
STILL FINDING WAYS TO DELIVER
SERVICES ONLINE AND IN PERSON ON
A LARGER SCALE. EVEN THE
LIMITATIONS OF EXISTING LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS INCLUDING THE
SMALL NUMBER OF IMMIGRATION
LAWYERS IN CALIFORNIA. COMPARED
TO THE NEED THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND CAPACITY
BY CONSIDERING INCREASED FUNDING
OF ACCREDITED REPRESENTATIVES
WHO COULD HELP IMMIGRANTS
NAVIGATE IMMIGRATION BENEFITS
APPLICATION PROCESS THESE.
THERE'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DEVELOP ADDITIONAL WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR THOSE
SEEKING TO SERVE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS INTERPRETERS
COMMUNITY NAVIGATORS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS. WE WILL LOOK TO
CONTINUE. TO SEEK OPPORTUNITIES. TO BUILD UP COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE NETWORKS AND I TRAIN AND
MY LINK MIGHT MULTI CALLED COP
WHY TO ADVANCE WORK. WE WANT TO
BE OUR EMIGRATE INTO AND- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SHARE
THESE RESPONSE TODAY AND PLEASE
LET ME KNOW IF YOU HAPPEN
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM MAUREEN TOUGHER. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MAUREEN KEPT HER AND I
AM THE CHIEF OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACCESSIBILITY AND RACIAL EQUITY
OFFICE AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
I'LL BE ADDRESSING SPECIFICALLY
THE QUESTION. ON THE AGENDA
AROUND THE HEAT INCIDENTS
SURVIVOR AND PREVENTION SERVICES
PROGRAM BUT THEN IT THE PROGRAM
IS COMPRISED OF A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
OVER THREE YEARS FOR GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF
HATE INCIDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND ENGAGE IN
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. THE
PROGRAM IS BEING ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE COMMISSION ON ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
AFFAIRS CDSS AND THE COMMISSION
HELD A SERIES OF LISTENING
SESSIONS IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH PARTICIPATION
FROM OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS AND STAKEHOLDERS
PROVIDING INPUT ON THAT NEEDS
GAPS AND OPPORTUNITIES IN AREAS
OF ANTI HATE SERVICES AND
PREVENTION. THERE WERE NEEDS
IDENTIFIED IN AREAS OF
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
LEGAL SERVICES NAVIGATION
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
ALTERNATIVES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT SENIOR SAFETY
AND A LARGE NUMBER OF OTHER
AREAS. AS A RESULT OF THIS
INFORMATION GATHERING AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CDSS ISSUED AN RFA
FOR THE STOCK I HATE PROGRAM FOR
UP TO TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
INCORPORATING INPUT FROM THE
COMMISSION AND FROM THESE
LISTENING SESSIONS. APPLICATIONS
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW AND
AWARDS ARE ANTICIPATED IN APRIL
OF THIS YEAR. AT SOME A TRAY.
GRANT AWARDS WILL BE MADE BY
INVITATION TO ORGANIZATIONS WITH
A DEMONSTRATED CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER LARGE SCALE ANTI HATE
SERVICE OF A PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND THESE AWARDS ARE ALSO
EXPECTED THIS SPRING. I AM HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON
NINETY FIVE THE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE L. L. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN RYAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME VEHICLE
FOR QUESTIONS. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM JACKIE GONZALEZ POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES. MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WE JACQUI GONZALEZ
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATE AND DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THIS INVITATION
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IT'S
MADE ON ISSUES OF EQUITY AND
ACCESS TO JUSTICE ESPECIALLY
DURING THAT TIME ONCE WE'VE
HEARD TODAY WE'RE ALL THINKING
ABOUT CHALLENGES RELATED TO
RACIAL JUSTICE AND IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS AND IN PARTICULAR I WANT
TO THANK CDSS- FOR ALWAYS BEING
WILLING TO PARTNER AND ENGAGE
WITH ADVOCATES AND EXPLORING
STICKS SOLUTION TO THESE ISSUES
I CAN SAY I'VE BEEN ADVOCATE-
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW CDSS HAS
CONSISTENTLY MOVED SWIFTLY AND
MAKE STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS WHERE
IT COULD TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. PARTICULARLY UNDER
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION- SOME OF
THE MYRIAD WAYS PROVIDING
SUPPORT AT THE BORDER MIGRANT
SHELTERS DOC ASSISTANCE IN THE
FACE OF CHALLENGES TO THAT
PROGRAM AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
MORE RECENTLY THROUGH TARGETED
INVESTMENTS LIKE THE BLACK
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE EQUITY
PROJECT I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES- AND INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST TO CHECK ON THAT
I'D LIKE TO TOUCH ON TODAY IT'S
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP WHICH LAUNCHED JUST
LAST YEAR. THE FELLOWSHIP IS AN
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION TO A
CHALLENGE THAT HAS EXISTED FOR
DECADES IN OUR STATE AND AS OF
THE ON THAT AS- IT'S KIND OF
IT'S MENTIONED I'M PASSED THE
LACK OF LEGAL RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY DEPORTATION DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS IN UNDERSERVED AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY. ISOLATED REGIONS
OF OUR STATE. ASIAN DEFENSE IS A
THE CENTER TOOL- NEEDED TO FOR.
AND OF THE COMMUNITY MANY OF
WHICH ARE LOCATED IN UNDER.
REGIONS OF OUR STATE- AS THE
CHAIRMAN KNOWS FAR TOO WELL
GIVEN- HIS DISTRICT AND TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER AND FRIDAY
EIGHT. TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE
HEIGHT O THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S AGGRESSIVE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT POLICIES
CALIFORNIA INVESTED IN THIS
PROJECT AS A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR THE
CODE. COULD GAIN ACCESS TO DUE
PROCESS AND QUALITY DEPORTATION
DEFENSE SERVICES. AT A MASS
DEPORTATION AND VIOLATIONS OF
DUE PROCESS CERTAINLY DON'T
DOMINATE OUR HEADLINES BUT THE
NEED HAS NOT ABATED. AND IT
REMAINS AN EVER PRESSING
CHALLENGE FOR CALIFORNIA. IF
INCREDIBLE TO NOTE THAT JUST
THIS PAST WINTER BETWEEN OCTOBER
AND DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE NATIONWIDE IMMIGRATION COURT
BACKLOG THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER SAW THE LARGEST SPIKE IN
HISTORY. WITH A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND NEW CASES ADDED
TO ITS DOCKET AS A ROOT
DIRECTORS ALL OF THE- ARRESTS BY
ICE. AND MOST NOTABLY FOR
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS I LAKE
IMMIGRATION COURT SAW THE
LARGEST INCREASE IN CASES ACROSS
THE NATION. AND SO MANY OF THE
RESIDENTS OF THE RURAL REGIONS
OF OUR STATE. INCLUDING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CENTRAL COAST
ARE AMONG THE THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TO TRAVEL
TO THIS COURT TO APPEAR A LOAN
WITH NO LEGAL ASSISTANCE. SO WE
HAVEN'T WORKED FOR YEARS- TO TRY
TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE AND HAVE I
THINK BECOMING A REALLY GOOD
PLACE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
SOLUTION TO THIS GAP IS A
COLLABORATIVE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM. THAT DEVELOPS A
PIPELINE OF IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS I CAN BE TRAINED AND
MENTORED BY HIGHLY SKILLED
ORGANIZATIONS IN MORE URBAN
AREAS AND IN HOUSE IN BEES- MORE
RURAL AREAS. THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM IS IT ONLY TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES IN THESE REGIONS
HAVE CONTINUED LAWYERS BY THEIR
SIDE BUT THAT WE MAKE SURE WE
PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COMMUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS LONGER TERM
STATE FUNDING OF WHICH WE JUST
HEARD THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT UNDER ONE CALIFORNIA.
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE- THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF THREE YEARS
APPROVAL TO REMOVAL DEFENSE
EXPERIENCE TO ACCESS- THIS
REMATCH FUNDING AND THE
FELLOWSHIP DOES JUST THAT HE
TRAINS THE NEXT GENERATION OF
ATTORNEYS WILL ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GOOD INTENTIONS ARE
ABLE. TO CONTINUE ON TO HOW
THESE COMMUNITY BOYER'S AND BE A
TO PROVIDE THESE CREEK SERVICE.
AND SINCE THE- YOUR TEN- JUST A
YEAR AGO THAT FELLOWS ASSISTED
HUNDRED OF FAN. ACROSS THE
VALLEY AND THE CENTRAL COAST
PROVIDING THEM WITH LEGAL
CONSULTATIONS. AND
REPRESENTATION AND BOND AND
REMOVAL CASES OFTEN INVOLVING
MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS. AND I KNOW
THROUGHOUT THE DIFFERENT PANELS-
THIS AFTERNOON YOU KNOW WE'VE
NOTED HOW IMPORTANT THE ISSUE OF
LEGAL STATUS IS FOR ACCESSING.
YOU KNOW ALL KINDS OF SERVICES.
AND BENEFITS AND IT'S NOT JUST
THE ISSUE OF LEGAL STATUS WHEN
FOLKS ARE FACING DEPORTATION
IT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
STRESSFUL EVENTS IN THEIR LIVES
I'M IT'S NOT ONLY THE ISSUE OF
THE LACK OF THE WILL STATUS.
IT'S REALLY THE THREAT OF BEING
SEPARATED FROM FAMILY MEMBERS-
LOSING A BREADWINNER AND BEING
DEPORTED TO A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
FACE YOU KNOW AND MANY MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES TORTURE OR THE
WORST CASE IS. THAT AND THAT'S
THE REASON THE ADVOCATES AND
LEGISLATORS ARE COMING TOGETHER
IN THIS YEAR TO ASK FOR
CONTINUATION AND EXPANSION OF
THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM TO PROTECT
ON THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. THE
OTHER QUESTION I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO ADDRESS AND I WILL TRY TO
WRAP UP I'M IN STATE WITHIN THE
TIME LIMIT IS- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES SURROUNDING I'M LEGAL
SERVICES AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER CALIFORNIA'S WAIT. FOR
THE GAME WE'RE SO LUCKY TO BE IN
A STATE WHERE BOTH- OUR GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING. AND
PROTECTING OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE CONTINUE
TO FACE IS HOW TO BE EXPAND THE
POOL. OF INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN
ACCESS- THESE SERVICES. AND LIKE
I MENTIONED TRADITIONALLY YOU
HAVE ORGANIZATIONS IN AREAS OF
THE STATE THAT WOULD GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM FUNDING BUT LACKS
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY. TO
QUALIFY FOR THE FUNDING AND
THAT'S WHERE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
FELLOWSHIP PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE. WITHIN THEIR AREAS OF THE LAW
ADVOCATES BELIEVE THERE'S ROOM
TO INVOLVE OUR CURRENT STATUTE
AND ALSO OUR FUNDING MODELS TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. SOME OF
THE IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN TABLED-
ON THESE ISSUES INCLUDING MOVING
FROM WHAT'S CALLED A FEW PER
CASE MODEL- TO A FULL TIME
STAFFING MODEL TO ENABLE
ORGANIZATIONS- TO KEEP STAFF ON
LONGER TERM AS A SPECIALIZED IN
THESE ISSUES AND I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING. ADVOCATES AND CDSS
HAVE BEEN EXPLORING AND ENGAGING
ON. AS WELL AS EXPANDING
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT NO
FAMILIES ARE DEPORTED BASED ON
PRIOR UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CONVICTIONS- AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
THE ISSUE THE FACING DOUBLE
JEOPARDY SOMETIMES. AND SO IN
CLOSING I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK CDSS
ONCE AGAIN- AND YOU KNOW THREE
YEARS AGO I APPEARED BEFORE THE
SAME COMMITTEE CHAMPIONING THIS
FELLOWSHIP- MANY PEOPLE THAT
WILL BE EXPECTING YOU SHOULD
WOULD BE POSSIBLE. AND I'M
REALLY PROUD AND HUMBLED TO
SHARE HOW SUCCESSFUL THE LAUNCH
HAS BEEN AND WE ASK THAT WE HAVE
TODAY THAT THE STATE CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH ADVOCATES DEFINE
THESE KINDS OF SOLUTIONS TO
EQUITY GAPS. THE PROGRAM IN
THESE INVESTMENTS SYMBOLIZE
WATER FLOWING FROM THE LAWS OF
OUR STATE TO BRIDGES THAT I
THINK CAN BEEN TRULY DESERT'S
WHEN IT CAME TO IMMIGRATION
SERVICES. AND HAVING THIS I FIND
CONTINUE TO FLOW TO THESE
REGIONS HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
NOT ONLY IMPACT THOUSANDS. OF
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES IN THE FUTURE
BUT TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
REGIONS REALLY ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS JUSTICE AND EQUITY. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
GO TO CYNTHIA CHOI CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND THE
FOUNDING PARTNER OF. STOP AP I
HATE. THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS.
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS TWO
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. OF
OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ANTI ÁP I
HATE INVESTMENT MADE IN TWENTY
TWO IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. AND WHAT WERE THE
OUTCOMES- THAT WAS THAT FROM
THIS FUNDING. AND SECONDLY WHAT
ARE THE TRENDS YOU'RE SEEING AND
WHAT ARE THE TRENDS THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN OUR DATA. UP WITH
REGARD TO ANTI API HATE
INCIDENTS AND HOW CAN THE
STATE'S RESPONSE BE IMPROVED. A
I WHERE WHERE THE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT I AM THE FINAL
SPEAKER SO ALLOW ME TO START MY
BRIEF REMARKS BY THINKING. OF
YOU FOR THE HISTORIC A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SIX MILLION INVESTMENT
IN WHICH A HUNDRED AND TEN WILL
GO DIRECTLY TOWARDS COMMUNITY
BASED RESPONSES TO HATE. WE KNOW
THIS WORK WILL TAKE TIME. AND
WILL JUST BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
UNDER INVESTMENTS IN CRITICAL
HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MEETS
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE LIMITED ENGLISH-
SPEAKING IMMIGRANTS. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THEN COMMUNITY IN
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY HATE. I'D LIKE TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT WE'RE SEEING
THROUGH OUR DATA AND WHAT ELSE
THE STATE CAN DO TO ADDRESS
HATE. SINCE WE LAUNCHED IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE ESTABLISH
THAT AND TASIA RACISM AND
XENOPHOBIA IS SYSTEMIC AND
PERVASIVE. AND AS WE APPROACH
OUR TWO YEAR ANNIVERSARY IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT WE'VE
DOCUMENTED OVER TEN THOUSAND
INCIDENTS. AND IT CONTINUES
UNABATED. AND WHILE WE RECEIVED
INCIDENTS FROM ALL FIFTY STATES
IN THE NATION. CALIFORNIA HAS
THE DUBIOUS DISTINCTION OF
LEADING IN INCIDENTS REPORTED IN
FACT CALIFORNIA MAKES UP NEARLY
FORTY PERCENT. OF ALL OUR
INCIDENTS. WE HAVE ALSO FOUND
DISTURBING TRENDS WOMEN REPORTED
ALMOST TWICE AS MANY INCIDENTS
AS MEN. MANY OF THE INCIDENTS
ARE IN THE FORM OF RACIALIZED
AND SEXUALIZED VERBAL
HARASSMENT. AND THE MAJORITY ARE
TAKING PLACE IN SPACES THAT ARE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC NAMELY
STREETS SIDEWALKS PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND ON PUBLIC TRANSIT
. AND AS A REMINDER THESE ARE
NOT JUST DATA POINTS BUT REAL
PEOPLE AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU JUST A HANDFUL OF STORIES
WHICH I MUST WARN YOU ARE HARD
TO HEAR BUT CAN GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF THE HARM THIS TYPE OF VERBAL
HARASSMENT CAUSES. EVEN WHEN NOT
DIRECTED. AT YOU. THE DUDE WAS
HARASSING ME ON THE TRAIN
STATION AND CALLED ME A ****
**** ASIAN CORONA. AND GOT ON
THE SAME TRAIN BUT WASN'T
SATISFIED AND FOLLOWED ME CAR TO
CAR SO I GOT UP EARLY AND HOPPED
ON THE TRAIN. FOR MY SAFETY AND
OTHERS. A SECOND INCIDENT I WAS
VERBALLY HARASSED FOR TEN PLUS
MINUTES ON THE MUNY. BUS BY A
MAN CALLING ME A CHINKO
REPEATEDLY YELLING HOW HE'S
HAPPY ASIAN PEOPLE ARE GETTING
BEATEN UP ROBBED AND KILLED- I
DESERVE IT. I'M NOTHING COULD
STOP HIM IF HE WANTED TO STEAL
MY THINGS OR HURT ME. AND THE
FINAL INCIDENT THAT I WANT TO
SHARE AS I WAS SHOPPING AT A
STORE WITH MY MASK ON. AN OLDER
WHITE MAN CAME UP AND STARTED
SCREAMING AT ME. YOU NEED TO
STAY TEN FEET AWAY FROM ME YOU
DISGUSTING BAD EATING **** YOU
NEED TO GO BACK TO WHERE YOU
CAME FROM. WELL OUR DATA CENTERS
ON THE EXPERIENCES OF API WOMEN
STREET HARASSMENT IS A
PERNICIOUS CULTURAL NORMS THAT
EXIST LARGELY UNCHECKED IN
UNITED STATES AND GLOBALLY. AND
AFFECTS ALL WOMEN AND MEMBERS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. STREET
HARASSMENT THREATENS THE SAFETY
OF WOMEN AND OTHER GROUPS AND
RESTRICTS OUR FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FREELY THROUGH PUBLIC SPACES IS
CENTRAL TO OUR ECONOMY WELLBEING
AND ABILITY TO CARE FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR FAMILIES.
DESPITE THE GRAVE CONSEQUENCES
AND DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
ALL WOMEN AND OTHER GROUPS
STREET HARASSMENT IS NOT TAKEN
SERIOUSLY. AND EXIST ON THE
PERIPHERY OF PUBLIC POLICY
SOLUTIONS. MEANWHILE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS PROHIBIT GENDER
BASED HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE AND IN EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS. AS UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION. JUST IMAGINE
THAT OUR BEST SOCIETAL RESPONSE
IS FOR GIRLS WOMEN AND SEXUAL
MINORITIES TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES TO NAVIGATE THE WORLD
ACCEPTING THAT STREET HARASSMENT
IS JUST PART OF OUR DAILY LIVES
AND THAT OUR CHOICES WILL BE
LIMITED IN ORDER TO BE SAFE. FOR
LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT WOMEN WHO
MAKE UP THE MAJORITY OF
ESSENTIAL AND FRONTLINE WORKERS
THE CHOICES ARE EVEN MORE
LIMITED. WE FIND THIS-UNACCEPTABLE AND HAVE SET OUT TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WITH OUR
FIRST EVER POLICY OBJECTIVE
FEATURING THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND HATE AND HARASSMENT.
USING A PUBLIC HEALTH FRAME AND
A GENDER BASED APPROACH. FIRST
WE MUST N. STREET ARREST MEANT
TO EDUCATION BASED INITIATIVES.
SECONDLY WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC TRANSIT RIDERS SAFETY
THROUGHOUT THEIR ENTIRE JOURNEY
. AND FINALLY EXPANDING CIVIL
RIGHTS PROTECTIONS IN LARGE
RETAILERS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF WORKERS AND CUSTOMERS. ALL
THREE BILLS WILL REQUIRE
INVESTMENTS ROUGHLY THIRTY TO
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS EACH. A
SMALL INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT
AFFECTS THE OVERALL WELL BEING
OF WOMEN GIRLS AND OTHERS WHO
ARE BEING DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY STREET HARASSMENT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ADDRESSING GENDER BASED
STREET HARASSMENT WHEREVER IT
OCCURS. BECAUSE THERE IS NO
PLACE FOR HATE. IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND OF I WILL-
FREESHEET ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE THAT IS A GREAT SUMMARY
FOR THIS ENTIRE PANEL WHERE YOU
ENDED PAYER AND- WILL- POINT OUT
FOR- MISS JACKIE GONZALEZ- THAT
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT CALIFORNIA
IS AHEAD OF THE GAME BY THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE AND-
HOW WE THEN BEEN ABLE TO PROTECT
MANY OF. THOSE WHO ARE WITHIN
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
WOULD LIKE TO UPLIFT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THE- IMMIGRANT-
LEGAL JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP PROJECT
AS I DO BELIEVE IT'S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN CREATE
SUSTAINABILITY GOING FORWARD AS
MANY OF OUR CBO LACKED THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY. TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES
FACING OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
US TO WORK ON AND WOULD SIMPLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT WHILE THIS.
FELLOWSHIP PROJECT AND COHORT IS
BASED OUT OF THE NINE. DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEALS THAT THERE MAY
BE A NEED FOR US TO SIMILARLY
LOOK TOWARDS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN LIGHT OF THE LARGEST SPIKE WE
SAW OCCURRING WITHIN THE L. A.
IMMIGRATION COURT. AND SO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP
GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE SIMILARLY PROVIDING THIS
TYPE OF. SUPPORT TO ALL REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA- BUT WILL SAY THAT
I SPOKE WITH THE FELLOWS OF THIS
COHORT AND WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH BOTH THEIR DEDICATION AND-
A WILLINGNESS. TO UNDERTAKE AND
TO PRACTICE AND TO HELP TO
DEFEND OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
IT WAS- IT WAS A GREAT MOMENT
FOR MANY OF US WHO WORK IN THIS
AREA TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
EFFORTS ARE PAYING OFF. AND THAT
THERE ARE REINFORCEMENTS ON THE
HORIZON AND BELIEVE THAT THESE
ARE VERY IMPORTANT INVESTMENT
FOR US TO BE MAKING. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL OF THE PANELISTS AND IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A REMINDER WE
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
ISSUE ON THE AGENDA WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START- WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS A REMINDER
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT
SHOULD BE ON THE WEBSITE. AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THAT NUMBER. IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. WITH THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE OF ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU'RE
ENCOUNTERING ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWENTY NINETY NINE AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN THE COMMENT
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS THE NUMBER
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
TO OUR FIRST QUESTION. LET'S
BEGIN. OUR FIRST COMMENTS COMES
FROM INE NINETEEN ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR GOOD EVENING
JERRY NUMBERS THIS IS JARED CALL
WITH NOURISH CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE NOT ISSUE FOR THAT
CALPERS PEOPLE WHO'S GOING TO
START BY THANKING THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEIR EFFORTS TO IMPLEMENT ALL
OF THE LONG OVERDUE CALFRESH
IMPROVEMENT AND ESPECIALLY THE
EXPANSION OF MY COLLEAGUE-
THAT'S ABOUT THAT'S THE PRIDE WE
ARE COULD SPLIT YOUR TO BUILD ON
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL BY
EXPANDING. ELIGIBILITY TO
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
ON THE TELEPHONE ACCESS
INITIATIVE WE URGE THE
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT THE
PLANNING THAT'S UNDER WAY RESULT
IN A TELEPHONIC PROCESS THAT
AVAILABLE EQUALLY ALL CALPERS
CLIENTS ACROSS THE STATE WE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THE LEVEL OF
ACCESS SHOULDN'T DEPEND ON WHERE
IN THE STATE A QUIET LIVES.
ALTHOUGH OF COURSE UPON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SIMPLIFIED
CALFRESH APPLICATIONS FOR
SENIORS AND FURTHER RECOMMENDED
THE DEPARTMENT CONSIDER ALSO
ALLOWING HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN TO BE INCLUDED IN THAT
INITIATIVE AND THAT BENEFITS
FROM THAT FIGHT APPLICATION AT
SOME OTHER STATE THAT GOT. IN
AND REGARDING THE BENEFITS CLIP
THAT WOULD DISCUSS THAT THE
CALPERS FAMILY THERE ARE FACING
WHEN EMERGENCY ALLOTMENT EXPIRE
I WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR
ARAMBULA FOR CHAMPIONING THE
PROPOSAL SPONSORED BY NURSE
CALIFORNIA BURKE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CALFRESH
BENEFITS TO PARTICIPANTS WHEN
THEY PURCHASED CALIFORNIA GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THE WAY WE
CAN BOOST CALFRESH BENEFITS FOR
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS WILL ALSO
GROWING THE STATE WITH AN
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY. AND
FINALLY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR FOOD
BANK THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE HI
I'M INCLUDED TO CARRY OUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO MINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THAT THESE IMPROVEMENTS
AND FURTHER INVESTMENT AT RESULT
IN A TRULY EQUITABLE NUTRITION
SAFETY. NET FOR OUR STATE THANKS
. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE
. BLAME FOR EIGHT. HI MY NAME
GOT BROKE HAVE THE GOVERNMENT
CENSORSHIP IN POLICY CENTER I'M
HOPING TO COME IN THE KITCHEN
FOR IN ORDER PICK UP YOUR BUDGET
ALLOCATION THE STAFF NUTRITION
BENEFITS FOR FIFTY BUT THE OVER
WE- URGE YOU TO BILL UP ABOUT.
GIVE HER CREDIT. THE FACT FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS THE- WE WILL
BE EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE ACT TO
BENEFITS. REGARDLESS OF THAT HE
OR IN THE STATUS. IF THE
DISCRIMINATION AND BARRIERS THAT
MAY IT THAT THE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND PUT FOOD ON THE-
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT BECAUSE MANY
IN THE BUT UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO ARE THE DROP. CHILDREN WITH
WORKING IN A PARENTS QUITE THE
BECAUSE POVERTY THE WITH
IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND IMPACT
INTO IS NUMBER REALLY
CALIFORNIA'S. ELECTED BUT
RECOVERED HAS THE POWER TO MAKE
THE IT WORK FIFTY POINT. BE A
MODEL THE REST OF THE- NO MARKED
NO MARK. CONTENT THANK YOU.
THANK OPERATOR NEXT COLOR. BLAME
FIFTIES. HELLO NAME IS YOUNG I
WORKED THE FINANCE JUSTICE AND
FABRICS EXPRESSED OFFICE THANK
YOU TO ON FOR ALL OF YOUR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS THAT IT'S
YOUR ON CALL INTO COMMENT ON
ISSUE THREE- I COMMEND
ADMINISTRATION THE TERM CAL
CHILD SUPPORT. THESE ARE
IMPORTANT BUT WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGEND AND THE
GOVERNOR TO GO FURTHER INTO THE
I'M SURE THAT WE HUNDRED OF PARA
CHILD PAYMENT GO THROUGH TO THE
RESULT AND NOT BE INTEREST BY
THE IF INCLUDES KERR RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE FROM POWER MEDICARE
BUT MANY OF OUR BUT MANY OF
TODAY'S PANELISTS THAT PARITY
CHILDREN NEED THESE TOP PAYMENTS
THAN THE DOES WE SHOULD NOT BE
ENTERED THEM WE KNOW THAT
EVERYONE BY. ONE CHILD SUPPORT
MAY GET THE CHILDREN PARENTS
WHATEVER PILAR A 1100% PASSED
ALL CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS TO
TALK TREMENDOUS BENEFITS
ACCORDING TO AN EVALUATION BY
THE URBAN INSTITUTE PARENTS MADE
LARGER AND MORE CONSISTENT
PAYMENTS BECAUSE THEY KNEW ALL
SIX PAYMENTS FOR GOING TOWARDS
OTHER CHILDREN CHILDREN MOTHERS
AND FATHERS ALSO REPORTED
INCREASED WELL BEING IMPROVED
ECONOMIC PROSPECTS WE SHOULD NOT
BE BELT BALANCING OUR BUDGET ON
THE BACKS OF THE POOREST
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE WE KNOW
HOW TO AND THAT AND THE. TIME TO
DO IT IS NOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THEY YOU. OPERATOR CALLER
. COLIJN SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALLED FOR
MEN ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXTENSION OF IF THE PROVIDER
TRAINING RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
THE FUNDS ARE TO RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION ACT AS RISK
FACTORS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE TOXIC STRESS RESPONSE IN A
VARIETY OF WHAT. TRAININGS THOSE
SUPPORTING TO IDENTIFY THEIR
NEEDS SUPPORT THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM OF PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. ADDITIONALLY IF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP THE
COURTS THE EXPANSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIANS AGES
FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER IN ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS INCREASING
FOOD INSECURITY REDUCE POVERTY
AND HOMELESSNESS AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERING FROM THE
IMPACT OF COVERED NINETY. ON
BEHALF OF HIM COUNTY I'M CALLING
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWENTY POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. FOR SUPPORT OF
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES AS
WELL AS THE PURCHASE A FUNDING
AUGMENTATION TO FULLY FUND THE
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE TWENTY EIGHT. I LOVE YOU
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AS
DETAILED IN TODAY'S HEARING. A
KEY ROLE IN ADMINISTERING
PROGRAMS THAT CAN HELP LIFT
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY AND HELP
ENSURE COUNTIES CAN EFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS AND
INDIVIDUALS CAN ACCESS THESE
BENEFITS. WHAT TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION. A SOMEONE TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO INVESTMENT SAPPER
CAL FRENCH. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE HIGHLIGHTING THAT THE
BUDGET METHODOLOGY DEVELOPMENT
DELAYED MENDOCINO RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED. THE FACT IS JOINING WITH
EVERY DAY AND ASK THAT YOU TO
REQUEST A SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR.
GENERAL FUND INCREASE FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION. HELLO COUNTY
RESPOND TO INCREASE CASELOAD
ENSURE THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES CAN QUICKLY GAIN ACCESS
TO THIS VITAL. INTEREST IN
ASSISTANCE BENEFITS. M. AND PER
CHILD SUPPORT WE- THE GOVERNOR'S
. TO PROVIDE TWENTY POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES. AT THE
FACT THAT JOINING WITH CSTA AND
OTHER PARTNERS TASK FOR A
FURTHER INCREASE OF NEARLY
THIRTY MILLION GENERAL FUND.
THIS INCREASE WOULD FULLY MEET
THE NEW FUNDING METHODOLOGY AND
ALLOW COUNTIES TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THE NEW FEDERAL FINAL
WILL. THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE
SUPPORTED IN HAPPEN INTO
RESOURCES TO HELP REDUCE
POVERTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE SIXTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN-
ARAMBULA DIFFICULT MARTINEZ
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
AGGRESSION COLLABORATIVE. I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
ITEMS FORTY SIX THE AGENDA BOOK
CALLED PARTNERS OF MOST
CALIFORNIA AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CALPERS PROGRAM NEEDS FOR
SUPPORT THAT IS A PROPOSED.
RESPECT ITEM NUMBER SIX WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
DEPARTMENT OUR IMMIGRATION
LIMITS THE FIRST ORDER OF THE
FAMILIES TO THE STATE. CANNOT
VERY CRITICAL ARE ALSO WANT
HIGHLIGHT YOU. FOR DOT
IMMIGRATION PUBLISHER PROGRAM
WHAT. ARMED MEN BY JACKIE
GONZALEZ WE HAVE SEEN PROGRAM.
BOB BOB DECIDE AND BE. AND BEAT
THE CRAP. ARE CARRIED OVER THE
PAST YEAR ALSO READ THE FOR
VALLEY THE CENTRAL COAST I CAN
TO THE BALLOT. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS NEEDED IN
THE HUNTER VALLEY THE CENTRAL.
SO ARE WE DO AUTHORITIES FOR
RELIGIOUS. WHAT PART OF FOREIGN
. THANK VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTY. GOOD
EVENING DUGGAR BEHALF OF THE
CHILD'S DIRECT WITH A IN
REFERENCE TO ISSUE WEEKS THE
TWENTY POINT ONE MILLION FUND
PROPOSAL FOR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCY ADMINISTRATION HOWEVER
ACCORDING TO THE AGREED UPON
LEVEL OF EFFORT STUDY
METHODOLOGY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WILL BELIEVE THIRTY
LOCAL AGENCIES UNDER FUNDED TO
THE TUNE OF FOURTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND JUST TO PERFORM THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS OF THE
EXISTING CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE AGENDAS CRIMES
ALL THE NEW REQUIREMENTS OF THE
FEDERAL FINAL RULE WE HAVE TO
MEET LOCAL AGENT PEOPLE NEED AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT THESE
IMPORTANT LAUDABLE PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES OUR LOCAL AGENCIES
ADMINISTER THESE IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT BOUNCE
OF THE BENEFITS OF CHILD SUPPORT
ON FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN NEED
WHAT THE IMPACT COLLECTIONS
HAPPEN PAYING PARENTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE ON HOW WE CAN FULLY
RESOURCE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
CREATE A MORE EQUITABLE CHILD.
SUPPORT SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NOT. PLEASE HI SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CARE NUMBER HAVING
SEVERELY MCDONALD APPEARING
AGAIN THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT UNDER
ISSUE FOR THE C. FLAP EXPANSION
TO INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT REGARD TO
THEIR- STATUS AS WELL AND
SUPPORT FOR THE FOOD AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS PUT
FORTH BY THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS. GIVE
ME IN A DIFFERENT WITH TO ITS
TWO THREE SUPPORT- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION OF
EXPANDING THE CHILD SUPPORT PATH
THE PROPOSAL TO CURRENT SUPPORT
RECIPIENTS- WE WILL ENGAGE WITH
YOUR STAFF ADVOCATES AND THE
DEPARTMENT- TO DISCUSS HOW THIS
CAN BE MOST READILY
ACCOMPLISHED. AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE ITEMS
AS YOU CONSIDER THE BUDGET THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE. HELLO THIS IS HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN AND SCOTT WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL BY
INCREASING CAL WORKS GRANTS 250%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL FOR
ALL FAMILIES ENROLLED INTO THE
PROGRAM AND BY PERMANENTLY
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELL I AM. THIRTY FIVE.
NINE THIRTY FIVE. YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SORRY HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
TEAM THAT I NEED TO LEARN BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES FOCUSED ON ANTI
POVERTY EFFORTS AND THE
EXCELLENT PANELISTS REPRESENTED
TODAY WE WANTED TO TOUCH ON A
FEW ITEMS AROUND FAMILY SUPPORT
TO LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
ATTY CHILD CARE WE AGREE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND ASK
YOUR CHILD CARE AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD. EDUCATION WE NEED
DRAMATIC INVESTMENTS IN
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR
FAMILIES THAT CAN'T GET ACROSS
EARLY CHILDHOOD BY CHILD CARE
WORKERS ARTS CENTER WORKERS WITH
THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK YOU'RE
TREATING OUR YOUNGEST KIDS
DURING A VITAL TIME OF
DEVELOPMENT AND THEY SHOULD NOT
BE LIVING IN POVERTY. IN REGARDS
TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE
CALIFORNIA'S TO FAMILIES FIRST
MIND SHARING THE THAT THE
PORTABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL
TYPES OF FAMILY WE ARE STATE
LEADERS TO EXPAND WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATES PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT
BUDGET TO PROMOTE ECONOMIC AND
HEALTH EQUITY CARD CALIFORNIANS-
I'M AT THE HOME VISITING THE
STATE NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN THE CALYX PROGRAM.
AND CONTINUE TO BOLSTER THE
CALAR COME VISITING PROGRAM THE
TIMING O THE PANDEMIC WITH
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING FOR THE
WRAPPING UP OF HOME VISITING
PROGRAM THEY PIVOTED AND SHIFTED
AT HIGHER RATES OUR RETENTION OF
PARTICIPANTS AND SEEN AND
PROGRAMS PRE PANDEMIC FURTHER
CONSIDERING WHAT THE ACTING
SURGEON GENERAL TOUCHED ON
EARLIER WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE CAL WORK POLICING
PROGRAM REPORTED THAT 91% OF
CHILDREN. IN THE PROGRAM
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE
DEVELOPMENT SCREENING RATES THAT
ARE HIGHER THAN THOSE REPORTED
BY MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
CHILDREN NOW SUPPORTED
MINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO INCREASE THE ONE
TIME AT YOUR LOCAL BUT NOW FOR
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS FINISHES
SEVEN THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
. WELL I'M SEVENTY TWO. THURMOND
OF THE THAT COALITION FOR HIM
AND RIGHT SHE NOT CALLING IN
SUPPORT TWO ITEMS ONE IS ADAM I
FOR THE FACT THAT WE'RE SO
PRETTY TO BE THE GOVERNOR REALLY
INTO EXPANSION PART YOUR COULD
FIVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO FOOD
BENEFITS BUT WE- SUPPORT IN JOIN
THE CALL THAT OF THE- INSANE
BACK NOW IS THE TIME FOR. TO
ACCESS FOOD FOR ALL REGARDLESS
OF STATUS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THAT ON ITEM. I
JUST WANNA KNOW THAT WE ARE
SERVICE PROVIDER UNDER THE ONE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AND WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO SEE EVERY YEAR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THESE
SERVICES AND AGREED THAT- WE
HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO TO GROW
EXPAND ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ONE WAY TO DO
THIS ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT AN
EXPANDED THE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
THAT WAS MENTIONED BY NAME
GONZALEZ EARLIER CHAIRED BY THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM WE SUPPORT THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT. AND CONTINUATION OF
THE PROGRAM AS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO BE OF COURSE THE POSITIVE
IMPACT THAT DISTORTED
DEPORTATION DEFENSE SUPPORT HAS
HAD ON INDIVIDUALS. AND FAMILIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
COLOR PLEASE. ONE FIFTIES. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHIP EVER
ARE ROAD REPAIRS A LOT ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD PROVIDE UNDER ISSUE
NUMBER TWO CAL PROGRAM. JEFF THE
GOVERNOR TO BULLDOG BECAUSE THE
CAL WORKING OKAY TO BE ELIGIBLE
TERM AT THE MINISTRY- AND- WE
ASK THAT YOU REVISIT WHAT THE
ACTUAL CLOSED START- WE ARE URGE
YOU TO. THE TO HER. MILLION THE
CALIBER GRANT- BY SEN ONE SEVEN
POINT ONE PER- UNDER ISSUE FOR-
BECAUSE CALPERS- WE- YOU TO
BECAUSE COUPLE CAL COUNTY
ADMITTED FOR- WE ALSO ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE HELP. FEET THAT
THE CONVENTION- AND ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT WE ALSO- ASK
YOU TO. HELP AND THEY HELP
PROGRAM THE SUPPORT THAT HELP
THE BODY BACK. GREAT ABOUT THE
BAD. ABOUT THIRTY YOUR
POPULATION. UP WE DON'T THE
BOARD COMPANY YOU. THAT **** OUT
. UNDER ISSUE BODY. HERE ALL DAY
PROGRAM REFERENCE- I THINK IN
THE CANADIAN COMMITTEE STAFF AT
THE INFORMATION PRESENTED BUT
AFTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
ON A COUPLE ITEMS. J. DEFINING
FOR BOTH OF THE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES I LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE TODAY AND
ENCOURAGE THE FULL FUNDING FOR
THAT- HEALTHY AT EIGHT THE
BALTIC. AN UPCOMING WORKLOAD AND
BROUGH ANYTHING THE HERALD. AND
DIRECTOR VOICE FOR THEIR COMING
WE OPPOSED BECAUSE AND CAL BURKE
SAID ELIGIBLE OPERATE BUT- A-
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL FIND
CALVERT AND OTHER AREAS. AND
THEN LASTLY THE TO COME WITH
CLIENT AND ARE THE COMMITTEE
THROUGHOUT THE- SIXTY MILLION A
THE VERY. ON TO THE MAIN. THE
NEW- BUDGET MATTER. HELLO
ALLEGED WERE THE ABILITY TO THEM
AT THE END OF THE MATTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOU TIME. THANK
ARE IN MEXICO PLEASE. SEVENTY
GOOD AFTERNOONMY NAME IS
MOHAMMED BADIE AND CALLING
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY AT THE
STATION OF LOS COUNTY REGARDING
ISSUES WE'VE EVERY SIXTY NOT%
CLINIC AND HEALTH CENTER OPERATE
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY.
EMPLOYERS ONE POINT SEVEN LOW
INCOME AND UNDER RESEARCH
PATIENTS EACH YEAR WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR IT BUT OUT OF
FEEDBACK YOU TRASH BENEFIT FOR
IN THE AGES FIFTY FIVE AND OVER
AND WE ARE YOU BUILD ON THE
BALLOT THANKS BEING CHEAPER
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS ARE ALL
EIGHT REGARDLESS IN THE STATUS
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THANK YOU
HARPER NEXT FALL PLEASE. LINE.
SIX SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND CHAIR WE DIFFICULT
AN ESSENTIAL PATROL OUT WITH
NEXT GEN POLICY DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR BECAUSE LIKE TO THANK THE
WORK OF JACKIE GONZALEZ AND IDA
IN THE VISION- ADDED THAT SHE
HAD AND WORKING TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP WE ARE CALLING INTO
SUPPORT- AND IT'S THE FIRST
STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO IMMIGRATION COUNSEL IN
THE MOST UNDERSERVED RURAL
REGIONS OF OUR STATE EVERY DAY
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS RECITE
THAT RESIDING CALIFORNIA
APPEARED WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY IN
IMMIGRATION COURTS. DID YOU
PROCESS THE PROCESS CRISIS
AFFECTS RESIDENTS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE BUT IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
ALREADY DISADVANTAGED AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES THESE COMEDIANS HAVE
HISTORICALLY LACKED PRO BONO
LEGAL SERVICES AN ATTORNEY THAT
CAN HELP KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER
THE MODEL THE PROVIDED BY THE
FELLOWSHIP ALLOWS FOR NEW
ATTORNEY THE HOUSING FOR ALL
REGIONS WILL BE TRAINED IN THE
COLLABORATIVE STRUCTURE BY THE
PASSENGERS IN OUR STATE IT ALSO
PROVIDES A COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTION TO THE CHALLENGE OF
BUILDING LEGAL CAPACITY. AND IS
A CRITICAL INVESTMENT THAT WILL
PAY OFF PROTECT IT'S BECOME NEXT
GEN POLICY URGES YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND EXPANSION OF THIS
CRITICAL CRITICAL PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT THESE REPORTS
HAS REACHED THE HIGHEST AREAS OF
NEED. IN OUR STATE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT COLOR. LINE SIXTY EIGHT. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EDWIN
GOT MONICA COMMUNITY GAUGE MAIN
TRACTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE AMERICAN CHECKED
IT I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES THANK THAT CALIFORNIA
FELLOWSHIP I'M CALLING AGAIN IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FELLOWSHIP- CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER ON MANY ISSUES ACROSS THE
NATION BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF
INVESTMENT IT HAS MADE AT OTHER
CALLERS HAVE EXPRESSED.
INVESTMENTS ARE NOT ALWAYS
IMMEDIATELY SEEN AT THEIR SEEDS
THAT ARE PLANTED IN THE GROW
OVER TIME CALIFORNIA FELLOWSHIP
WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL PRO BONO
LEGAL SERVICES FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES MOST OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC SO I URGE YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND EXPANSION
OF ITS VERY CRITICAL PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
AND I WON IT I THINK JACKIE
GONZALEZ- OR- THE PROGRAM AND
ALL OF THE PARTNER INNOVATIONS
THAT HAVE REALLY MADE A
DIFFERENCE. IN IN MANY FAMILIES-
AND MANY. TO COME SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU OPERATOR
MEXICO PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTEEN A
MANUAL ABOUT THAT WHAT I MANY HI
I'M ONE OF THE TEN REMOTE
DEFENSE SPELLS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
COLLECTION I WANT TO THANK YOU
CHEN ARAMBULA AND ALL THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND JUSTICE FOR YOU
THANK YOU- CHEN ARAMBULA FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR YOUR KIND
WORDS- WE WERE VERY EXCITED TO
SPEAK TO YOU BUT ONE THAT DAY AT
THE KEY WORDS I WAS BORN AND
RAISED WITH CENTRAL VALLEY OF
CALIFORNIA I DECIDED TO GO TO
LAW SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THE GREAT
NEED FOR LEGAL SERVICES LIKE ON
MY COMMUNITY. AND THANKS TO THE
WORK OF MANY ADVOCATE BY JACKIE
GONZALEZ AND THANKS TO THE STATE
I'VE BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE BACK HOME AND HELP
PROVIDE MY COMMUNITY WITHOUT
SUPPORT I WISH I THOUGHT GROWING
UP THAT EXPOSED WITHIN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CLOSER TO THE
CENTRAL COAST WHEN MY COLLEAGUES
AND I LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE
MORE THAN DOUBLED THE AMOUNT OF
ATTORNEY PROVIDING REMOVAL
DEFENSE SERVICES IN THIS LARGE
AREA AN AREA MARKED THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. DETAINED IMMIGRANTS-
LEVIN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO STICK
WITH IT IF THEY HAVE AN ATTORNEY
AND TWICE AS LIKELY TO RECEIVE
THAT REALLY COULD AND COMPARED
THE IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT
REPRESENTATIVE I THINK ABOUT MY
COLLEAGUES BEFORE EVERY DAY
THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS GO
THROUGH REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRATION COURT
NOW CALIFORNIA HAS NO CONTROL
OVER THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW
HOWEVER THE BOARD CAN GIVE SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE A MORE FAIR BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE. SO FOR THESE
REASONS I'D LIKE TO SHARE MY
SUPPORT FOR- MEASURES SIX. YOU
THANK YOU HI NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LINE THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS MY AND I'M WITH AN AFTER
I THINK ADDED ACT I ALSO WANT OF
THE TEN IMMIGRATION FELLOW AND I
AM WANTED TO THINK ON MY PART
ISSUE THANK. THE DALLAS THAT
WITH THE THAT WHAT TOOK ACCESS
AND GREATER COUNCIL THE MOST
UNDER THERE BUT IN THE STATE.
EITHER REGION. MY TOP IN THE
FELLOW THE- RIGHT WE ARE OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE REPRESENT THEM
IN THE BACK IT WILL NOT. HELLO
GRAHAM IT'S AN- THE COMPETITIVE
. BUT PEOPLE TO GET ACCESS TO
SEVEN THAT IS- ALL MY CLIENT I
LOVE MY I. FIVE THINKERS THAT
ARE DYING OF ALL AROUND A
PROGRAM THAT IS LIKE EVENT THANK
CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES AND
EVERYONE AMERICANS. SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL EVERYONE I HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE OUR TO
LET EVERY KNOW THAT IT IS IN THE
GENES LIFE OF OUR CRIME BUT
THAT'S OF US ARE DIFFERENT%
BECAUSE OF IT SO- ON THE BALLOT
TO THINKING YOU AND I AM OF THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
FALL PLEASE. I AM SIXTY TWO.
HELLO MY MOM AND SAM AND- FAMILY
AND AUGMENT CAL I ALSO ONE OF
THE PLAN EACH WALK- LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES CALLING STATING I'M
ON FROM COAST AND I GREW UP HERE
AND I WANT LAW SCHOOL- TO-
BECOMING IMMIGRATION SO THAT I
CAN BETTER MY IN THE COMMUNITY
IN THE CODE. I THINK DAY-
HUNDREDS OF WHO HAVE TO GO TO
IMMIGRATION COURT WITH- IN THE
ATTORNEY AND I FEEL THE NEED OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOCATION WILL
DOUBLE CHECK- AND- ALSO. IN THE
CENTER WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN LOOKING STATES OF
AMERICA CHOSE. REPUBLICAN
IMMIGRATION COURT CALL RD ON
CODE. HM- SO AFTER THAT I THE
POINT IS YOU THINK THAT IT
SHOULD BE EXPANSION OF THE COACH. CALIFORNIA'S TOP MEGAN FOX THE
I LIKE MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR
CRUZ I ALSO SUPPORT THE- I CAN
FIX. OUR CHEF- AND I'M CALLING
TO SHARE AS AND MY CAPACITY THE
MENTOR TRAINING AND FUND THE
HONOR TO WORK. THE FELLOWS THE
PAST YEARS PEOPLE THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR ON AND IF YOU CAN
FROM THEM. THEY'RE ALL ADVOCATE
FOR DEEP ROOTED IN COMMUNITY A
THIRD AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
BEING A COMMUNITY SO BY INVEST
IN IN THE PALACE. SAID THE
MILLION BACKING TRAINING AT THE
NEXT OF HABITAT AND CANNOT
REPAIR YOU CAN SUPPORTING
SUPPORT. JUST THANK YOU. HARPER
NEXT CALL PLEASE. FINDS SIX. HI
MY NAME IS BENJAMIN CHALLENGE
THE CAL IMMIGRANT POLITICS AND
I'M COMMON ON BEHALF OF THE FALL
WE'RE GONNA. A COOKIE FALLOUT
FROM THE KIDS IN NEED OF DEFENSE
NATIONAL HEALTH. LONG BEACH ALLY
FOR FIT URBAN AND INVITE POLICY
INTO. WE'RE CALLING IT THE POOR
- OF THE GUN BACK BUDGET NOW OF
SEATS THAT ABOUT FOR. FIFTY FIVE
AND OVER AND UNLIKE OTHER WHICH
FROM URGE YOU TO BUILD A THE
BALLOT ABOUT EXPANDING SILVA
BENEFITS TO ALL. OF ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OP. THANK CALLER
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOUR. HELLO
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER- I WANT TO COMMENT ON
ITEM TWO ON CAL WORKS-
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE BUDGET
INCLUDED THAT SEVEN POINT ONE
INCREASE THE COW WORK MAXIMUM
EIGHT LEVEL BUT I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT AT THAT ONLY GET THAT
AT 42% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
CAL WORKS GRANTS WERE EQUAL 295%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL BUT
WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO- I
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT COMMENTS
MADE MIKE BY MIKE HERALD ABOUT-
BUT MOVING BARRIERS TO THIS
PROGRAM. ON ITEM THREE I ALSO
WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR THE POOR
FULL PASSED THROUGH A CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS AND THEN ITEM
FOR I WANTED JOINED THE CHORUS
OF FOLKS BETTER SUPPORTED AS
EXPANSION TO THE C. PAP PROGRAMS
AND THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE FENCE ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
NO. EXCEPTION OR EXCLUSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR FOR
PLEASE. LEVINE SAID. NINE GOOD
EVENING CARE ROMULAN MEMBERS I'M
JEFF MARKSTON REPRESENTING
FEEDING SAN DIEGO COMMENTING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR AND I WISH TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION A
C. PAP NUTRITION BENEFITS FOR
IMMIGRATIONS FIFTY IMMIGRANTS
FIFTY FIVE AND OVER AS WE
BELIEVE EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO NUTRITION BENEFITS WE
URGE YOU TO BUILD ON THIS
ALLEGATION THANK SPENDING SEAT
THAT BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL AGES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. DR ARAMBULA
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR FOOD FOR ALL
IS A PERMANENT SOLUTION WHICH
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING ISSUE
INCLUDING SECURITY AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES HEATING SAN DIEGO IS
IN SUPPORT BECAUSE IT WILL
MITIGATE HUNGER AND POVERTY BY
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE'S
NUTRITION SYSTEMS DO NOT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ON BEHALF OF
FEEDING SAN DIEGO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU LINE. EIGHTY ONE. A
GOOD ACTORS ARE LAYING ON TOP OF
THE COUNTY OF PHENOMENA AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN JOAQUIN IS THE
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BALLOTS AT THE TOP THE PART AND
ALSO WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR RANDY LAST A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO- THIS LOOKS
STARTED TO TRY TO COME UP WITH A
MORE EQUITABLE FUNDING LACK. AT
COUNTY AUBURN. AND KOBE THIRTY
THE RAIL SOME OF THE- AND WORK
AT LOOKING TO YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES THE SENATE HAS SORT
OF PUT THAT. BACK ON THE TRACK.
AND FINISHED THE WORK OF FULLY
FUNDING TALK APARTMENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE BUT RIGHT TO. CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT I FOR ONE OF THE TOP
PART PARTNER THANK OU. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. I AM A THREE. THE MINISTER
CARE AND MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER
SPONSORED POLICY ADVOCATE
FEDERAL LAW POVERTY ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
ISSUE FOR ABOUT THE TOPICS
BERENSON- WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO GO FORWARD WITH
EXPERIMENTS TO ALL ALL THE AGE
GROUPS ARE AND ALSO ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
ITEM SIX THE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
ON A SPECIAL THANKS TO TALKING
ABOUT. THE EARLIER SHIPMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATE.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BOB LINE
EIGHTY SIX GOING. AND. THE
TWENTY YES GO AHEAD. I DON'T. MY
NAME IS. I'M A WRECK FRESNO
COUNTY I'M GOING TOWARD ITEM.
FOR AN ITEM THANK. I WANT TO
THANK OUR GOVERNOR. LEADERSHIP
AND ALSO- A MEMBER JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA BURKE YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND FOR YEAH BUT THAT'S THE- FOR
OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT OUR SYSTEM YOU'RE A-
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
PINE. EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON YES
PLEASE CONTINUE. GOOD AFTERNOON
DIAGRAM BUT RESPECT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT LIKE TO OFFER MY
STATEMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP
DISCUSS AN ISSUE SIX MINUTES
JUST CHECK THINGS I'M A CENTRAL
VALLEY RESIDENTS AND THE
DIRECTOR PROGRAMS YOU'RE A
COMPANY CHANGE LAWYERS ON BEHALF
OF OUR ENTIRE TEAM WE ASK FOR
YOU TO SUPPORT IN MAINTAINING
AND EXPANDING THE IMMIGRATION
LEGAL FELLOWSHIP THE FIRST
STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO IMMIGRATION COUNSEL IN
THE MOST UNDERSERVED RURAL
REGIONS OF THE STATE IN MY
CAPACITY YEAR CHANGE LAWYERS. I
WORK DIRECTLY WITH OUR LEGAL
FELLOWS AND THE RESPECTIVE HOST
ORGANIZATIONS EYEWITNESS TO THE
IMPACT THAT THEY'RE CHECKED
SERVICES MODEL HAS HAD ON THE
COMMUNITY AND LARGE PROVIDING
LEGAL SERVICES TO HUNDREDS OF
THE LAST YEAR NOT ONLY ARE WE
BUILDING NEXT GENERATION
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS TO SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT WE ARE
PROVIDING THEM WITH TRAINING
COACHING AND MENTORSHIP SO THAT
THEY IMPACTFUL
COMMUNICATORS AND LEADERS THAT
BRING HIGH LEVEL LEGAL ACCESS TO
OUR MOST UNDERREPRESENTED
REGIONS. THE CURRENT DUE PROCESS
CRISIS AFFECTS RESIDENTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE BUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
ALREADY DISADVANTAGED WILL
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES THAT
STARKLY LACK PRO BONO LEGAL
SERVICES AN ATTORNEY THAT CAN
HELP KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER WE
URGE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
THESE RESOURCES WHICH THE
HIGHEST AREAS OF NEED IN OUR
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LÀ. NINETY AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL CANNELLA AND I'M A
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOW AT THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER AND CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE SIX I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP AS
A FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT IT
HAS BEEN A BLESSING TO SERVICE
THE FOLLOWING THIS PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED ME WITH
AMAZING RESOURCES AND MENTORSHIP
FROM ATTORNEYS LIKELY SOME
KNOCKS TO REPRESENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OF THE SANTA BARBARA
VENTURA AND FAMILIES WILL BE FOR
COUNTIES. CENTRAL COAST ALONE
HAS WELCOMED OVER AT THE I'M-
MINORS. THANKS FOR THE FOLLOW
THAT MY AND MY- HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE CHILDREN AND HELP
THEM PAIN IMMIGRATION RELIEF
STERN SURE THIS THE CURRENT
STATUS IN THE U. S. THANKS TO
THIS PROGRAM I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF THE REUNITING A MOTHER WITH
HER TWO CHILDREN. AFTER BEING
SEPARATED FOR OVER A YEAR THIS
WORK IS SO VALUABLE AND NEEDED I
URGE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. NINETY ONE.
RAMOS NUMBER SEVEN WITH THE
WOMEN'S BUILDING IN SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND TODAY I JUST WANT
THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION
PRETTY FAT NUTRITION BENEFITS
FOR IMMIGRANTS FIFTY FIVE AND
OVER TIME THAT WE ENDED THE
EXCLUSIONARY POLICY- HOWEVER WE
CONTINUE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE ON
THIS ALLOCATION BY EXPANDING
FEEDBACK BENEFITS ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
REGARDLESS. OF AGE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR IT ALSO HER UPPED. THE
LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OF COURSE THIS TIME OF YEAR.
WELL. FIVE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL MY NAME IS WILLIAM
EMAIL AND I'M FROM THE EDUCATION
LEADERSHIP FOUNDATION AND I'M
WRITING TO US FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND- IN MAINTAINING AND
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA
MIGRATION LEGAL FELLOWSHIP- I
WAS NOT BORING. AND I WOULD NOT
RAISE THE THUNDER VALLEY BUT
AFTER BEING HERE ONE YEAR. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IF THERE IS
UNDERSERVED IN ITS ROLE DEPEND
SERVICES. I HAVE WITNESSED FIRST
HAND OF THE NEED AND IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FOR MORE DEFENSE-
I HAVE- MY SERVICES BECAUSE I AM
ONE OF THE LEGAL FELLOW HERE IN
THE AREA- HAVE HAD PROFOUND
IMPACT ON MANY FAMILIES AND NOW.
AND I WISH TO CONTINUE TO DO SO
. THIS PROGRAM IT'S LIFE
CHANGING FOR MANY FAMILIES AND
IT ALSO CHANGING MY LIFE-
BECAUSE IT'S ALLOWING ME TO GROW
I NOT ONLY FOR YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS FELLOWSHIP BUT I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO POSSIBLY ASK FOR A NEW
FUTURE FELLOWSHIP. AND A NEW
COURT I URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT AND EXPAND THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
THESE RESOURCES REACHED THE
HIGHEST EVERY THAT MEETING IN
OUR STATE. AND I SUPPORT. THE
FELLOWSHIP. AND THANK YOU THAT
THE- THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. NINETY TWO.
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS DEFENDED
THE MENACE POLICIES BECAUSE IT
WITH GRACE AND THE ENTIRE PARTY
CALIFORNIA COALITION I JUST WANT
TO BE CONFINED TO THANK CHAIRMAN
PALLOTTA COMMITTEE AND THE WORK
OF DEPUTY CHIEF COPELAND CALLED
MARKETS FOR CRAFTING A BOOK BY
COUNTY DISPATCH IMPECCABLY
EFFORTS AND ADDRESS NECESSARY
ACTUALLY AND PROBABLY
CALIFORNIA- I DID WANT TO ECHO
SUPPORT ON THE NEED TO INCREASE
POWER GRANTED 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- GUARANTEE 1100%
ACCURATE TALK ABOUT THE CHILDREN
ON CAL WORKS. AND CURRENT
PERMANENTLY EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA THE PROGRAM TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS- AND WHAT
THEY WANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
BUY THE EFFORTS SHARE DURING THE
HEARING REGARDING REGARDING THE
QUESTION TRUCK HOW HOW WHAT KIND
OF FAMILIES CAN BE FURTHER
SUPPORT IT- YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO
GREW UP IN A BIG SENATE POWER
GERMANY I KNOW TOO WELL THE
IMPACT OF FAMILIES BEING FORCED
TO CHURCH DOLLARS BECAUSE MY
LEVELS WERE NOT RECOGNIZED UNDER
HORRIBLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR FOR RECOGNIZING THAT-
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE- THANK
YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER. HEY.
SIX SIX NINE. GOOD EVENING HELLO
. WE CAN SEND YOU ARE GETTING
HELLO. SH SH SH. PLEASE CONTINUE
HELLO- STARTED OUT GETTING ME MY
NAME IS NANCY NOVA- WORKING WITH
THE NEXT THAT CONDITION I
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT IN
OXNARD CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO ONE
OF THE LEGAL FELLOW. THE CHANGE-
IMMIGRATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
AND I'M CALLING TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN ISSUE NUMBER SIX-
WORKING AS A LEGAL FELLOW HERE
IN OXNARD ESPECIALLY WITH THE M.
MAKE SPECKLE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY I HAVE SEEN HOW THIS
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED. QUALITY
LEGAL SERVICES WITH THE AID OF
ART MENTORED. AND WITH THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF LAWYERS
WHO HAVE BEEN PRACTICINGIN THE
AREA- TECHNICAL FELLOWSHIP HAS.
PROVIDED MORE ABILITY AND
SERVICES NOT ONLY TO THE-
RESEARCH AREA OF OUR IN CENTRAL
COACH BUT ALSO TO THOSE WHO WORK
IN THE FIELDS WHO LACKED THE
ABILITY TO SPEAK- ENGLISH.
SPANISH BUT THE ONLY RELY ON
THEIR INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE AND I
HAVE SEEN HOW THIS FELLOWSHIP
HAS. STRENGTHENING THE COMMUNITY
AND HAS BROUGHT AND THAT WITH
SOME TYPE OF HOPE WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO AHEAD AND WE
COLLECT THERE- THEIR FAMILY IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES
THAT IS. EXTREMELY HIGH IN THIS
AREA. BECAUSE OF THIS COMPETING
SERVICE AT SERVICES TO THE
SELLERS HALF. TO THE COMMUNITY-
I HAVE SEEN HOW THEY ARE GAINING
MORE FREEDOM THEY'RE GAINING
MORE CONFIDENCE THEY'RE URGING
THEIR CHILDREN TO. PUSH FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE AND TO ALL TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP ON THE RUPES
SO- I'M ASKING FOR YOU TO
SUPPORT THE ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE. NINETY
FOUR. LINE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO GO AHEAD. THANK
HI MY NAME IS ADRIANA GOMEZ WITH
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE THE FRESNO
AND I'M ALSO ONE OF THE FELLOWS
I WOULDN'T CALIFORNIA ORIGINALLY
GONZALEZ IT CONNECT I'M GOING TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT- I GREW UP
IN FRANCE NOW AND I HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE BILL FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS
I HAVE SEEN HOW MY COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN LACKING PRO BONO
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AND THE
FELLOWSHIP HAVE BEEN A GREAT
FIRST STEP AND I HOPE TO GET.
SUPPORT TO GET REPRESENTATION
FOR THOSE OF THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF THE CENTRAL COAST- TO
BE GREAT TO GET THE POINT
EXPANSION- THAT FELLOWSHIP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALL PLEASE. WEHAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR I WILL TAKE
THAT AS THE CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I WILL JUST TAKE A
MOMENT BEFORE WE CONCLUDE TODAY
TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE PANELISTS. AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE STAFF AND
TEAM WHO HELPS TO. MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PREPARED THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO BROADCAST THIS AND WE
ARE. SAFE AND HAVE CLEAN
SURROUNDINGS BUT LASTLY I WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO THANK THE PUBLIC
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND MAKING OUR
HEARING WHAT IT WAS TODAY.
RUEFUL FOR THAT AND IT MAKES A
BETTER PROCESS AND BETTER
PRODUCT AT THE END. WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN FOR TODAY AND HOPE
YOU HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.